THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S HEARING.
A FEW NOTES BEFORE WE START.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO ASK ALL
PANELISTS TO PLEASE BE SUCCINCT
AND BRIEF IN THE PRESENTATIONS.
TWO TO THREE MINUTES I THINK IS
SUGGESTED.
IN ORDER TO FACILITATE TO END
THIS I WOULD JUST SUGGEST IN
ORDER TO FACILITATE THE FLOW OF
THE HEARING.
SECOND WERE ASKING THAT A PUBLIC
COMMENT.
BE LIMITED TO ONE MINUTE PER
PERSON.
A STEP WILL HOLD UP A GENTLE
REMINDER WHEN THE TIME IS
GETTING CLOSE. TO ONE MINUTE YOU
DO REQUIRE ADDITIONAL TIME
BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING TO SAY
SOMETHING NOBODY HAS SAID.
OF COURSE WE WANT TO HEAR FROM
YOU -- WITH THAT LET'S GET LET'S
LET'S LET'S GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED.
I'D LIKE TO ASK FOR THE PANEL ON
ISSUE ONE TO PLEASE COME FORWARD
TO TO THE WITNESS TABLE.
AND FOR THE DEPARTMENT
REPRESENTATIVES TO BEGIN OF THE
DISCUSSION OF WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES. FOR
THE GAP BEFORE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
I'D LIKE TO WELCOME THE ACTING
DIRECTOR FRIEND MUELLER.
STATE OMBUDSMAN JOE RODRIGUEZ
AND DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT LONG.
AND IF WE CAN GIVE TESTIMONY IN
THE ORDER LISTED I WOULD
SINCERELY APPRECIATE IT.
START.
HAPPENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE I'M FRIEND
MILLER I'M THE ACTING DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
AGING AND A CDA.
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HEARD TODAY TO PROVIDE A VERY
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF OUR BUDGET.
AND OUR MAJOR PROGRAMS.
CITY IS THE FEDERALLY DESIGNATED
STATE UNIT ON AGING AND
ADMINISTERS PROGRAMS SERVING
OLDER ADULTS ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES FAMILY CARE GIVERS
AND RESIDENTS IN LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THE DEPARTMENT ADMINISTERS
FUNDING ALLOCATED UNDER THE
FEDERAL OLDER AMERICANS ACT THE
OLDER CALIFORNIANS ACT AND
THROUGH THE MEDICARE PROGRAM.
THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES TWO
ONE AND SIX POINT THREE MILLION
FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
IN APPROXIMATELY THREE QUARTERS
OF THAT IS FEDERAL FUNDING.
CDA CONTRACTS WITH THE NETWORK
OF THIRTY THREE AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING KNOWN AS TRIPLE A.'S.
THAT DIRECTLY MANAGE A WIDE
ARRAY OF FEDERAL AND STATE
FUNDED SERVICES THAT SUPPORT FOR
OLDER AND DISABLED INDIVIDUALS
TO LIVE AS INDEPENDENTLY AS
POSSIBLE IN THE COMMUNITY. TO
PROMOTE HEALTHY AGING AND
COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT HELP OLDER
ADULTS FIND EMPLOYMENT AND
ASSIST FAMILY CARE GIVERS AND
THEIR VITAL KERR GIVING ROLE.
IN ADDITION CITY CONTRACTS WITH
THIRTY EIGHT LOCAL AGENCIES THAT
OPERATE THE MULTI PURPOSE SENIOR
SERVICES PROGRAM.
THROUGH THE MEDI CAL HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED WAIVER FOR THE
ELDERLY AND CDA ALSO CERTIFIES
COMMUNITY BASED ADULT SERVICES
PROVIDERS. FOR PARTICIPATION IN
THE MEDICARE PROGRAM.
A BRIEF UPDATE ON SOME OF OUR
MAJOR PROGRAM AREAS THE SENIOR
NUTRITION PROGRAMS DEPARTMENTS
LARGEST PROGRAM IN TERMS OF
FUNDING.
PROVIDES TWO TYPES OF SERVICES
FIRST IS CONGREGATE NUTRITION
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES
NUTRITIONALLY BALANCED MEALS AND
EDUCATION. TO INDIVIDUAL SIXTY
YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER AT
CONGREGATE MEAL SITES.
THE SECOND IS THE HOME DELIVERED
MEAL PROGRAM WHICH SERVES OLDER
ADULTS WHO ARE HOMEBOUND AND
UNABLE TO GO TO A MEAL SITE.
NEXT PARKING AREA SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES PROGRAM THIS PROVIDES A
VARIETY OF SERVICES DESIGNED TO
ASSIST BOULDER INDIVIDUALS TO
LIVE AS INDEPENDENTLY AS
POSSIBLE.
THESE SERVICES INCLUDE
INFORMATION AND ASSISTANCE LEGAL
IN TRANSPORTATION SERVICES
SENIOR CENTER IS THE LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN.
AN ELDER ABUSE PREVENTION AND IN
HOME SERVICES FOR FRAIL OLDER
CALIFORNIANS.
SENIOR COMMUNITY EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES PROGRAM PROVIDES PART
TIME WORK BASED TRAINING AND
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES AT
LOCAL COMMUNITY SERVICE AGENCIES.
FOR LOW INCOME PERSONS FIFTY
FIVE YEARS OF AGE OR OLDER.
THE PROGRAM OFFERS PERSONAL AND
JOB RELATED COUNSELING JOB
TRAINING AND JOB REFERRALS.
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS AND
PROJECTS INCLUDES THE COMMUNITY
BASED HEALTH INSURANCE
COUNSELING AN ADVOCACY PROGRAM
KNOWN AS HIGH CAP.
I CAN'T PROVIDES PERSONALIZED
MEDICARE ENROLLMENT AND PLANTS
SELECTION COUNSELING COMMUNITY
EDUCATION ASSISTANCE WITH
INSURANCE APPEALS AND
INFORMATION ABOUT LONG TERM CARE
COVERAGE OPTIONS.
LASTLY THE MEDI CAL PROGRAMS
INCLUDE OVERSIGHT OF THE MULTI
PURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES PROGRAM.
AND COMMUNITY BASED ADULT
SERVICES BOTH OF THESE PROGRAMS
ARE ADMINISTERED BY CDA.
THROUGH INTER AGENCY AGREEMENTS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES.
SEA BASS IS A COMMUNITY BASED A
HEALTH PROGRAM THAT PROVIDE
SERVICES TO ADULTS EIGHTEEN
YEARS OF AGE OR OVER.
COURT RISK OF NEEDING
INSTITUTIONAL CARE DUE TO
CHRONIC MEDICAL COGNITIVE OR
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS AND OR
DISABILITIES.
CTA'S ROLE IS TO CERTIFY SEA
BASS CENTERS FOR PARTICIPATION.
IN THE MEDICARE PROGRAM.
EMESIS P. PROVIDES HEALTH AND
SOCIAL CARE MANAGEMENT TO
PREVENT OR DELAY PREMATURE
INSTITUTIONAL PLACEMENT A FRAIL
ADULTS SIXTY FIVE YEARS OF HER.
A IN SUMMARY I'D LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE AND THANK THE TRIPLING
NETWORK R. M. S. S. P. SITES OUR
C. BASS PROVIDERS.
AND THE MANY OTHER LOCAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS FOR THEIR PARTNERSHIP
IN ADMINISTERING THESE PROGRAMS
WITH US.
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
I THINK WHAT WE'LL DO IS WE'LL
HOLD OUR QUESTION KIDS.
UNTIL AFTER ALL THE PANELS
[inaudible]
IT'S OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK -- YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M JOE
RODRIGUEZ THE CALIFORNIA STATE.
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN.
I BELIEVE THE COMMITTEE HAD.
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM ADVOCACY
PROPOSAL.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT -- THIS
PROPOSALS CONSISTENT WITH GOAL
FOR OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE PLAN
ON AGING.
WHICH IS TO PROTECT THE CONSUMER
RIGHTS OF OLDER CALIFORNIANS AND
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES.
AND ASSIST THEM TO OBTAIN NEEDED
BENEFITS.
IN THEIR EVALUATION OF THE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM.
THE INSTITUTE OF MEDICINE.
RECOMMENDED THAT THERE SHOULD BE
ONE FULL TIME EQUIVALENT ON BUT
IT'S BEEN REPRESENTATIVE FOR
EVERY TWO THOUSAND LONG TERM
CARE BEDS.
THESE POSITIONS WERE ENVISIONED
TO BE.
STAFF OMBUDSMAN GOING INTO
FACILITIES WORKING ON COMPLAINTS
WITH RESIDENTS.
AS OF SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA HAS
APPROXIMATELY TWELVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOR NURSING HOMES AND
SEVEN THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN ASSISTED LIVING AND
BOARDING CARE HOMES. FOR A
COMBINED TOTAL OF A LITTLE OVER
THREE HUNDRED AND TWO THOUSAND
LONG TERM CARE BEDS.
USING THE INSTITUTE OF
MEDICINE'S RECOMMENDED RATIO AS
DO OTHER STATES.
CALIFORNIA WOULD NEED A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY ONE FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT POSITIONS.
AS OF SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN LOCAL LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS AT A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN POINT
FIVE ONE FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
POSITIONS.
SOME OF THESE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN POSITIONS ARE ALSO PROGRAM
COORDINATORS AND MANAGERS SIT
MINISTER THE PROGRAM THEY'RE NOT
IN FACILITIES WORKING WITH
RESIDENTS DIRECTLY.
LIMITED OLDER AMERICANS ACT
FUNDING.
DOES NOT ALLOW LOCAL PROGRAMS TO
HIRE ADDITIONAL STAFF.
CALIFORNIA UNLIKE MOST OTHER
STATES ALSO GIVES THE LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM
ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES TO
PERFORM.
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN RIVERS
REPRESENTATIVES RECEIVED REPORTS
OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT FOR
MANDATED REPORTERS AND OTHERS.
IN MOST OTHER STATES OTHER
ENTITIES LIKE ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES OR THE LICENSING AGENCY
RECEIVE THOSE REPORTS. TWENTY
THREE POINT 4% OF ALL COMPLAINTS
MADE TO THE PROGRAM.
OUR ABUSE NEGLECT AND
EXPLOITATION.
MANY OF THESE COMPLAINTS ARE
ALSO FROM FACILITIES STAFF.
IN THE FIFTH IN THE FACILITIES
WHERE THE LONG TERM CARE.
PROGRAM DOES NOT PERFORM
TRADITIONAL OLDER AMERICANS ACT
ADVOCACY.
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE GAVE US
THAT RESPONSIBILITY TO
INVESTIGATE TO THOSE REPORTS?
THEY ALSO ADDED OTHER FACILITIES
BEYOND SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND ASSISTED LIVING
BORN KERR WE ALSO WE SEE REPORTS
FROM.
PEOPLE IN ADULT RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES ADULT DAY HEALTH CARE
C. BASS SITES.
ADULT A PROGRAMS.
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED.
THIS DECREASES THE TIME
AVAILABLE FROM BUTTON PROGRAMS
TO MAKE WRECKED REGULAR VISITS
TO SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
AND ASSISTED LIVING ABOARD CARE
HOMES.
IN ADDITION IN CALIFORNIA ON WAS
BEEN REPRESENTATIVES MUST
WITNESS ADVANCE HEALTHCARE
DIRECTIVES FOR RESIDENTS OF
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES.
LAST YEAR ON BUDGET
REPRESENTATIVES WITNESSED OR
TENDED TO WITNESS CLOSE TO
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED ADVANCED
DIRECTIVES FOR NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS.
THESE THESE DIRECTIVES OFTEN
TIMES REQUIRE SEVERAL VISITS
FROM AN OMBUDSMAN REPRESENTATIVE.
THIS RESPONSIBILITY ALSO IMPACTS
OUR ABILITY TO MAKE REGULAR NON
COMPLAINT RELATED VISITS.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU AND I KNOW THAT --
YOU'VE GIVEN US MUCH OF WHAT --
WOULD BE DISCUSSED UNDER ISSUE
THREE IN GREATER DETAIL I
APPRECIATE THAT I KNOW THAT WHEN
WE GET TO ISSUE THREE THERE WILL
BE SOME SPECIFIC QUESTIONS. TO
HANG AROUND THANK YOU ALL RIGHT --
NEXT ON THE LIST WAS AT LONG.
YES THANK YOU -- I THOUGHT I'D
TAKE A MOMENT IT'S A GIVEN THAT
I KNOW THEIR QUESTIONS ABOUT
NEED IDENTIFICATION AT CETERA
COMING LATER ON THE AGENDA TO
PROVIDE A LITTLE CONTEXT IN
WHICH NEEDS DETERMINATION AND
PLANNING TAKE PLACE.
OF FOR AREA AGENCIES ON AGING
AND THE STATE.
SO ALL TRYING NOT TO GO ON TOO
LONG -- AND PLEASE LET ME KNOW
PLANT [inaudible]
OF AS MS MORTAR AND YOUR AGENDA
HAVE DESCRIBED CDA ADMINISTERS
MOST OF ITS PROGRAMS FOR
SUBVENTION CONTRACTS WITH THE
NETWORK OF THIRTY THREE AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING.
THE AREA AGENCIES ON AGING ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR NEED
IDENTIFICATION PLANNING SERVICES
TERM DEVELOPMENT AND SERVICE
DELIVERY IN THIRTY THREE
PLANNING AND SERVICE AREAS.
ACROSS THE STATE.
TRIPOLI'S OCCUPY A RANGE OF
ORGANIZATIONAL SETTINGS --
COUNTY CITY JOINT POWERS
AGREEMENTS PRIVATE NON PROFITS
AND WE HAVE ONE THAT SITUATED IN
THE UNIVERSITY FOUNDATION.
OF PLANNING AND SERVICE AREAS
VARY IN SIZE DEMOGRAPHIC
CHARACTERISTICS GEOGRAPHY
TYPOGRAPHY RANGE AND VOLUME OF A
RATE AVAILABLE SERVICES AND IT'S
CONSEQUENTLY THE APPROACH TO
NEEDS IDENTIFICATION SERVICE
DELIVERY MUST BE SUFFICIENTLY
FLEXIBLE. TO A NEIGHBOR ENABLE
EACH TRIPLE A TO MEET ITS
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER DIVERSE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
CDA AND AREA AGENCIES ON AGING
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS TRIPLE A IS.
OFTEN DO NOT HAVE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE OR BUDGETARY
AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE POTENTIAL
PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS TO
PARTICIPATE IN EFFORTS FOCUSED
ON NEEDS IDENTIFICATION SYSTEM
DEVELOPMENT AND SERVICE DELIVERY.
NONE THE LESS ASIDE FROM FUNDING
SERVICES DIRECTLY BOTH RELY ON
COLLABORATION COORDINATION AND
THE RELATED ABILITY TO LEVERAGE
RESOURCES TO ADVANCE EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS NEED.
THE APPROACH TO NEED AND SERVICE
DELIVERY EMPLOYED BY TRIPLE A IS
IS CONSISTENT WITH WHAT --
ACTING DEPUTY SECRETARY MARKHAM
YOU TO FROM THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY TALKED ABOUT IS
AN APPROACH WHERE YOU'RE WORKING
WITH PEOPLE.
AND TRYING TO DEVELOP AN PLAN
SERVICES RATHER DOWN -- TRYING
TO PLAN AND DEVELOP SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE.
OF THE FOCUS IS ON ENGAGEMENT.
TRIPLE A.'S IDENTIFIED NEED IN
PLAN SERVICE DELIVERY.
OF IN A MANNER THAT'S CONSISTENT
WITH OPENING PRINCIPLES STATED
IN THE OLDER AMERICANS ACT WHICH
SPEAK TO THE FULL PARTICIPATION
OF OLDER INDIVIDUALS AND THE
PLANNING AND OPERATION OF
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES.
AND PROGRAMS PROVIDED FOR THEIR
BENEFIT AND PROTECTION AGAINST
ABUSE NEGLECT AND EXPLOITATION.
THE OLDER AMERICANS ACT REQUIRES
EACH AREA AGENCY TO DEVELOP AN
AREA PLAN FOR PROVIDING SERVICES.
THROUGH A COMPREHENSIVE AND
COORDINATED SYSTEM.
IN DEVELOPING AND ADMINISTERING
THE AREA PLAN.
TRIPLE A.'S MUST CONSIDER THE
VIEWS OF SERVICE RECIPIENTS AND
ESTABLISH AN ADVISORY COUNCIL.
CONSISTING OF OLDER INDIVIDUALS
AND OTHERS FOR EXAMPLE SERVICE
PROVIDERS LOCAL.
ELECTED OFFICIALS AT CETERA TO
ADVISE THE TRIPLE ON A ON ALL
MATTERS RELATING TO AREA PLAN
DEVELOPMENT IMPLEMENTATION AND
RELATED OPERATIONS.
UNDER THE PLAN DETERMINING THE
EXTENT OF NEED FOR SERVICES IN
EACH TRIPLE A.'S RESPECTIVE
PLANNING AND SERVICE AREA AND
PROVIDING TO MEET SUCH NEED IS A
CORPORATE SPONSOR ABILITY.
FURTHER IN PLANNING SERVICE
DELIVERY TRIPLE IT'S REQUIRED TO
FOCUS ON THOSE WITH HIGH
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL NEED THE
TICKER EARLY LOW INCOME MINORITY
INDIVIDUALS. FOR NEARLY THREE
DECADES CALIFORNIA HAS PROVIDED
GUIDANCE TO AREA AGENCIES ABOUT
EMPLOYING A CONVERGENT APPROACH
TO DETERMINING NEED.
UNDER THIS APPROACH THE DATA AND
INFORMATION USED MAY BE BOTH
OBJECTIVE AND SUBJECTIVE AND
DERIVE FROM A VARIETY OF SOURCES
THE CENSUS AND OTHER NATIONAL
AND STATE DATA SETS.
COMMUNITY CLIENTS IN PROVIDER
SURVEYS FOCUS GROUPS PUBLIC
HEARINGS AND SERVICE METRICS OF
FOR EXAMPLE SERVICE --
INFORMATION AND ASSISTANCE DATA
ABOUT SUCCESSFUL CONNECTIONS TO
SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITY.
TRIPLE A.'S ALSO IDENTIFY THE
SERVICES AND RESOURCES THAT
ALREADY EXISTS TO ADDRESS
IDENTIFIED NEEDS AND RELATED
RESOURCES.
GAPS AND BARRIERS THE PREMISE OF
THIS APPROACH IS TO CONSIDER
MORE THAN ONE TYPE OF MEASURE OR
DATA SOURCE WHEN MAKING PLANNING
DECISIONS.
CDA COMMUNICATES WITH TRIPLE A
IS ABOUT UNMET NEEDS PRINCIPALLY
THROUGH ITS REVIEW OF AREA
AGENCIES AREA PLANS AND THE
UPDATES TO THOSE PLANS.
EACH AREA PLAN INCLUDES
DISCUSSION OF THE TRIPLE A.'S
NEEDS ASSESSMENT PROCESS AND
FINDINGS AND DESCRIBES HOW
INFORMATION FROM THE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT AFFECTS THE TRIPLE
A.'S PRIORITIES.
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES OTHER
EXAMPLES OF CDA ITS MECHANISMS
FOR COMMUNICATING WITH REPLACE
ABOUT NEED INCLUDE DISCUSSIONS
THAT OCCUR IN THE REGULAR COURSE
OF BUSINESS.
DURING PERIODIC MEETINGS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
AREA AGENCIES ON AGING AND
DURING ONSITE MONITORING VISITS
WORD DURING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PLAN ON
AGING.
THOUGH FOR YOUR AREA PLANTS ARE
SUBMITTED TO CDA FOR REVIEW AND
APPROVAL APPROXIMATELY ONE YEAR
BEFORE WE SUBMIT OUR FOUR YEAR
PLAN TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
WE DEVELOP OUR STATE PLAN
PURSUANT TO GUIDANCE RECEIVED
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION ON AGING
WHICH MOST RECENTLY REQUIRED TO
FOCUS ON OLDER AMERICANS ACT
CORE PROGRAMS.
OF DISCRETIONARY GRANTS
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE
ADMINISTRATION THROUGH COMMUNITY
LIVING FOR COMMUNITY LIVING.
OF ELDER JUSTICE AND PERSON
CENTERED PLANNING.
THE VISION MISSION GOAL AND
GOALS AND STRATEGIES ARTICULATED
IN OUR CURRENT STATE PLAN ON
AGING ALIGNED WITH THESE FOCUS
AREAS.
AVAILABLE RESOURCES AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE PUT OUR
COOPERATION AND COORDINATION
WITH OTHER STAKEHOLDERS.
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE NEEDS
OF OLDER ADULTS ADULTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND FAMILY CARE
GIVERS.
AND CDS DESIRE TO SUPPORT TRIPLE
A.'S AND OTHER KEY PARTNERS IN
ADDRESSING THOSE NEEDS ALSO --
SHAPES WHAT WE PUT IN OUR STATE
PLAN.
WHEN DEVELOPING OUR PLAN WE ALSO
TAKE A CONVERGENT APPROACH TO
IDENTIFYING NEED WE REVIEW THE
NEEDS INFORMATION GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES?
IN THE THIRTY THREE AREA PLANTS
WE RECEIVE TO IDENTIFY WHAT
LOCAL PRIORITIES ARE.
OF WE ALSO REVIEW DATA AND
STUDIES FROM A VARIETY OF
SOURCES FOR EXAMPLE THE CENSUS
AND SENSE OF PROJECTIONS THE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY SURVEY AT
CETERA -- AND WE ALSO SOLICIT
INPUT FROM AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION
ON AGING WHICH WHICH HOSTS OUR
STATE PLAN HEARINGS.
AND OTHER KEY STAKEHOLDERS WHO
REVIEW AND COMMENT ON THE DRAFT
STATE PLAN.
CDA ALSO CONDUCTS FACE TO FACE
HEARINGS ON OUR STATE PLAN AND
POSTS IT FOR REVIEW AND COMMENT.
ALL INFORMATION GATHERED IN THIS
WAY IS CONSIDERED WHEN
IDENTIFYING NEED.
AND HELPS TO SHAPE THE FINAL
STATE PLANS GOALS OBJECTIVES AND
STRATEGIES [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MARTHA.
GET YEAH OKAY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- AT LEAST PUSH WROTE
APARTMENT FINANCE NOTHING THAT
HAPPINESS FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE.
THE U. L. L..
ALRIGHT WE HAVE CLAY CAMP THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
GO AHEAD.
HI THANKS FOR HAVING ME HERE AND
I THINK MY ROLE IS TO TALK ABOUT
THESE THINGS FROM -- TRIPLE A
PERSPECTIVE.
SO ED DID A NICE JOB -- AS HAS
THE REST OF THE APARTMENT OF AB
DESCRIBING THE SITUATION IN THE
PROCESS OF THE PROCESS SOUNDS A
LITTLE CONVOLUTED BUT ACTUALLY
WORKS REALLY WELL.
BECAUSE IT'S TAKING INPUT FOR
THE STATE PLAN FROM ALL AREAS IN
ONE OF THE BEST THINGS ABOUT HOW
THE SERVICES WORK.
IS FEDERAL GUIDELINES WITH LOCAL
CONTROL THAT IS SO IMPORTANT AND
SO EFFECTIVE BECAUSE PROVIDING
SERVICES.
IN DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN AND RULE SAN
BENITO COUNTY CELL OF THE ACT
ALLOWS FOR THAT FLEXIBILITY IN
THAT LOCAL EXPERTISE TO MAKE
SURE.
THE SERVICES ARE USED AS
EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE.
I'M A COUPLE THINGS ABOUT ME.
AND AND HOW WE DOCUMENT THAT.
I'M JUST THE SHEER GROWTH OF THE
POPULATION IS IMPACTING TRIPLE
A.'S EXTREMELY HARD AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE NOT DEALING
WITH A POPULATION THAT FOR THE
MOST PART IS AGING AND TO WELL.
THAT WOULD MAKE THINGS SO MUCH
EASIER BUT CALIFORNIA HAS THE
GREATEST PERCENTAGE OF SENIORS
IN GREATEST NUMBER OF SENIORS
LIVING IN POVERTY.
ARM ONE IN SIX ARE ALSO LIVING
ALONE AND LIVING ALONE HAS A
HUGE IMPACT ON HEALTH AND IT'S A
GREAT HEALTH PREDICTOR -- IT'S
BEEN COMPARED THAT TO LIVING
ALONE IN BEING ISOLATED IS
EQUIVALENT TO A SMOKING HALF A
PACK OF CIGARETTES A DAY IN
TERMS OF HEALTH AND IMPACTS SO I
THINK WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING
MORE ABOUT THAT.
IN COMING YEARS IT'S KIND OF A
CUTTING EDGE -- FACTOR RIGHT NOW
THAT PEOPLE JUST STARTING TO
LOOK AT ONE IN FIVE OR MEDI CAL
ELIGIBLE SO WE REALLY HAVE THE
NUMBERS AND I THINK THE
DOCUMENTATION OF THE NEED.
THE CHALLENGES WHAT TO DO ABOUT
IT AND WITH THE POPULATION
HAVING GROWN BY 40% IN THE PAST
DECADE THE DEPARTMENT PROVIDES
SOME REALLY GOOD NUMBERS ABOUT
THAT.
I'M ONE OF THE CHALLENGES IS.
JUST MATCH REALLY THINKING YOU
WOULD EXPECT THE DOLLARS TO AT
LEAST GROW IN A SIMILAR MANNER
IF THE NEED IS STILL THERE AND
YOU'RE TRYING TO EFFECTIVELY
SERVE THOSE PEOPLE.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN THE
STATE WHEN OUR COUNTRY WAS IN AN
ECONOMIC CRISIS AGING PROGRAMS
PARTICULARLY OLDER AMERICANS ACT
RELATED PROGRAMS OLDER
CALIFORNIA'S ACT PROGRAMS.
GOT CUT INTO HOLE BY ABOUT
THIRTY THREE MILLION IN GENERAL
FUNDS WE WENT FROM I THINK SIXTY
FIVE BILLION I MIGHT BE OFF BY
MILLION OR TWO ON HERE. TO THE
SIX FROM SIXTY TWO MILLION TO
THIRTY THREE MILLION.
SO THAT JUST DEVASTATED THE
TRIPLE A NETWORK AND OUR ABILITY
TO MEET.
NEW SERVICES OR NEW DEMAND ON
SERVICE MADE US EXTREMELY
INNOVATIVE I MEAN I WOULD ARGUE
WE ALWAYS HAD BEEN BUT WHEN THAT
HAPPENED YOU SAW PROGRAM
INTEGRATION BEYOND BELIEF BUT
YOU ALSO SAW PROGRAM
DETERIORATION.
IN AN EXAMPLE OF THAT IS HOW DO
WE KEEP MEETING MEAL NUMBERS
MEAL DEMANDING AND I'LL TALK
ABOUT THAT LATER IN A IN ANOTHER
PANEL.
BUT WHEN RESOURCES ARE SHRINKING
LIKE THAT.
DRASTIC STEPS ARE OFTEN TAKEN TO
MAKE SURE SOME YOU'LL STILL GET
OUT THERE SO THERE ARE A LOT OF
PROGRAMS THAT INSTEAD OF
DELIVERING A DAILY MEAL DELIVER
MEALS ONCE A WEEK.
AND THAT TIES INTO ANOTHER THING
JUST THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
SUPPORTS THESE PROGRAMS THE
PROGRAMS ARE DESIGNED TO HELP
REALLY USE VOLUNTEERS.
AND THEY'RE NOT JUST VOLUNTEERS
THAT LICK ENVELOPES OMBUDSMAN IS
A GREAT EXAMPLE OF VOLUNTEERS IN
THE THE HIGH LEVEL OF SKILL.
THE HIGH CAP PROGRAM HEALTH
INSURANCE COUNTS AND ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM THAT RELIES ON
VOLUNTEERS TO EXPLAIN MEDICARE
FOR PEOPLE AND THAT'S A VERY
COMPLICATED SYSTEM FOR SOMEBODY
OFF THE STREET WHO'S NOT
COMPENSATED TO TRY TO DO.
TAX ACCOUNTING PROGRAMS FOR
SENIORS AGAIN THESE ARE
VOLUNTEER PROGRAMS NOW IMAGINE
IF.
H. AND R. BLOCK OR REQUIRED TO
USE VOLUNTEERS TO DO THEIR TAXES
OR IF.
SCHOOLS WERE REQUIRED TO USE
VOLUNTEERS TO TEACH CLASSES OR
YOU KNOW IF BANKERS HAVE THEY
HAVE 75% OF THEIR STAFF BE
VOLUNTEERS WE WE WOULD JUST.
NEVER CONSIDER THAT REALISTIC OR
ACCEPTABLE BUT THAT'S THE WAY
THE AGING COMMUNITY AN AGING
PROGRAMS ARE SET UP BUT YOU HAVE
TO USE PRIMARILY VOLUNTEERS FOR
A LOT OF THESE PROGRAMS.
SO.
THAT'S A CONCERN THAT THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT I KNOW
I'M GOING ON FOR A WHILE SO I'LL
TRY TO WRAP UP HERE -- I THINK
THERE'S THERE'S TWO KEY FACTORS
GOING FORWARD THAT WE SHOULD ALL
THINK ABOUT.
AND ONE IS YOU KNOW DO WE DO
SOMETHING PROGRESSIVE OR
CREATIVE AROUND THIS FOR WEEKS
DO WE JUST TRY TO AVOID IT.
AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS AND WE CAN
DO EITHER SO FAR MOST OF THE
ACTION HAS BEEN TO HOPE FOR THE
BEST WITH NO.
AGGRESSIVE OR PROGRESSIVE ACTION
BEING TAKEN TO DEAL WITH THIS
HUGE INCREASE IN THE POPULATION.
SO IF WE DO THAT WHAT HAPPENS WE
HAVE MORE PEOPLE
INSTITUTIONALIZED WHICH IS
PROBABLY THE HIGHEST
INTERVENTION POSSIBLE FOR THE
ONLY ONE THAT'S HIGHER IS MORE
PEOPLE BEING INJURED OR HAVING
STROKES ARE CATASTROPHIC
ILLNESSES.
THAT DAN AND UP IN HOSPITALS SO
THAT'S THE DO NOTHING ROUTINE
WHICH I THINK YOU KNOW WE COULD
DO THAT BUT WE'RE GOING TO PAY
THROUGH THE NOSE FOR TO HAPPEN
IN THE QUALITY OF LIFE OBVIOUSLY
GOES DOWN. FOR WE CAN LOOK AT
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS THAT TRY TO
AVERT OUR PREVENT OR DELAY THOSE
THINGS FROM HAPPENING.
AND IF WE INVEST A LITTLE MONEY
IN THAT WE CAN LOWER THE OVERALL
COSTS AND INCREASE THE QUALITY
OF LIFE THAT EVERYBODY RECEIVES
IT'S A CHOICE THAT WE ALL HALF.
YOU KNOW IF WE DON'T DO ANYTHING
WHERE BASICALLY CHOOSING LET'S
HAVE THE HIGHEST INTERVENTIONS
OUT THERE POSSIBLE.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO CREATE BRAND NEW
PROGRAMS THE PROGRAMS THAT ED
AND FRAN AND JOE TALKED ABOUT
WORK THEY WORK CHEAPLY AND
EFFECTIVELY.
AND ALL WE NEED TO DO IS MAKE
SURE THERE'S ADEQUATE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THOSE TO WORK
SO IT'S NOT ARE YOU KNOW
ANYTHING NEW INNOVATIVE IS IS
OBVIOUSLY WELCOME AND GREAT.
BUT THE BASS LINE IN COURT IS
ALREADY THERE SO WE CAN HAVE
SUCCESS BOTH FINANCIALLY IN
TERMS OF QUALITY OF LIFE OF JUST
EMBRACING.
THE EXISTING SYSTEM AND MAKE
SURE IT'S POSSIBLE.
SO UNLESS THERE'S QUESTIONS.
THANKS FOR LISTENING TO ME WHY.
I THANK YOU WERE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND NOT GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AND THAT'LL BRING IT
BACK UP TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
ALL RIGHT SEEN NONE.
IN A FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT.
ALL THE RADIO THAT A INDIA.
ISSUE ONE LET'S GO AHEAD AND
MOVED TO ISSUE [inaudible]
TO THIS.
YEAH BELIEVE WE HAVE THE SAME
PANEL SO.
FRAN IF YOU WANT TO GO AHEAD AND
LEAD OFTEN WILL.
MISTER LAW.
CENTER.
OKAY.
IN IN WILL JUST CONTINUE DOWN
THE SAME.
HALF PATH SO WE DON'T HAVE TO
CALL EVERYONE A VIEW OF EACH
TIME THANK YOU.
SO OF THIS IS ESSENTIALLY A
WORKLOAD PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT THE
SEA BASS PROGRAM.
IN ITS RESPONSIBILITIES THEY'RE
REQUESTING SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND FROM FEDERAL FUNDS
THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND GENERAL FUND.
AND THREE ASSOCIATE GOVERNMENTAL
PROGRAM ANALYSTS AND ONE NURSE
EVALUATOR.
THIS IS -- WORKLOAD PC PS I SAID
TO ENSURE THE SEA BASS PROVIDER
RECERTIFICATION IS OCCURRING
WITHIN THE STATUTORILY REQUIRED
TIME FRAME.
PROVIDERS ARE COMPLYING WITH THE
NEW FEDERAL HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED SETTINGS RULE.
AND PREPARE UP AND PROVIDERS
SCREENING REQUIREMENTS AND THAT
NEW PROVIDER APPLICATIONS ARE
BEING PROCESSED IN A TIMELY
MANNER.
WITH REGARD TO THAT LAST --
STATEMENT AS OF THIS MONTH THERE
ARE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE C.
BASS PROVIDERS AND OVER THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND SEA BASS
PARTICIPANTS.
THE NUMBERS OF CENTERS AND
PARTICIPANTS -- NUMBERS OF
CENTERS AND PARTICIPANTS
CONTINUE TO GROW STEP AWAY.
AS OF JANUARY TWENTY NINETEEN SO
WE HAD RESPONDED TO THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR REQUESTS
FOR INFORMATION FROM.
INTERESTED PARTIES ABOUT OPENING
A NEW CIVIC CENTER. ONE HUNDRED
FORTY TWO OF THOSE ENTITIES HAD
SUBMITTED THE REQUIRED PROGRAM
PLANS.
AND FORTY TWO HAD SUBMITTED
THEIR FORMAL SEE THUS
APPLICATION AND ARE AT VARIOUS
STAGES IN THE APPLICATION
APPROVAL PROCESS SO THIS IS A
PROCESS THEY NEED TO GO.
THROUGH BEFORE WE CAN CONTINUE
WITH THE PROCESS OF THEM
BECOMING A PROVIDE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I HAVE
NOTHING TO ADD AB INTERNET
QUESTIONS MAY HAVE.
LA -- CHECK YOUR PROCEDURAL NO
CONCERNS AT THIS TIME.
OKAY PUBLIC COMMENT [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
SHOULD.
NOT RIGHT RIGHT THERE SHE JUST
TURNED ON FOR YOU SIR.
THERE WE GO.
JERRY PASSED MORE WITH THE
CONGRESS OF CALIFORNIA SENIORS.
ON ICE A STRONG SUPPORT OUR
ORGANIZATION STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THE WORK OF SEA BASS.
IT IS HAS BEEN OF SYSTEMATICALLY
UNDERFUNDED FOR OVER A DECADE.
ALL AND IS GROWING IN RESPONSE
TO THE POPULATION GROWTH IT'S
OCCURRING AMONG SENIORS.
BOB AND WE FEEL THAT THE THE
BUDGET REQUEST TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL STAFF. TO REVIEW THE
PROCESS OF OF AT NEW APPLICANTS
AND ALLOWED TO REVIEW THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ONGOING IN THE
SEA BASS.
IS A CENTRAL IF THE SEA BASS
PROGRAM IS TO SURVIVE AND
CONTINUE SERVING.
CALIFORNIA SO WE STRONGLY
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS REQUEST
THANKS.
HI I'M I AM NOT SURE THAT IT
MATTERS WHERE I MAKE MY
STATEMENTS ALL JUST MAKE IT NOW --
PLEASE SOME A LITTLE FROM
REBUILDING TOGETHER OAKLAND EAST
BAY.
AND NOW THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE TREMENDOUS NEED IN THE
SHRINKING RESOURCES FOR FUNDS IN
THE SENIOR AREA -- WHAT I WANTED
TO SAY IS THAT WE SHOULD
PROBABLY JUST GET SMARTER ABOUT
HOW WE USE WHAT WE HAVE?
AND SPECIFICALLY AND CONSIDERING
THOUGHT AND CONSIDERATION ABOUT --
ESPECIALLY WITH TRIPLE A FUNDED
FUNDS IN WITH MEDICARE WAIVERS.
ABOUT DIRECTING THOSE AGENCIES
THE STATE AND COUNTY AGENCIES
THAT ARE RECEIVING THOSE FUNDS
TO BE REQUIRED TO GIVE A HIRING
PREFERENCE WERE CONTRACT
SUBCONTRACT PREFERENCE. TO
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE AGING
IN PLACE HOME MODIFICATION
REPAIRS AND REHABILITATION.
RIGHT NOW THESE PRECIOUS BONDS
ARE CURRENTLY WITH GREAT
FREQUENCY USED TO HIRE FOR
PROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT CHARGE
MORE FOR THE SERVICES SO WHAT
I'M SUGGESTING IS THAT WE THINK
ABOUT THAT.
THAT WE LEVERAGE THE FUNDS
INSTEAD TO PROVIDE THE SAME WORK
AT LOWER COSTS FOR SENIORS
VETERANS FOLKS THAT ARE DISABLED.
AT A HIGH QUALITY LOWER COST AND
LEVERAGE THOSE FUNDS TO SERVE
MANY MORE SENIORS IN NEED.
BY LEVERAGING PHILANTHROPIES AND
PHILANTHROPIC WORK SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS KAREN JOHNSON
WITH THE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM AND SALAS
BESPOKE COUNTY.
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO SAY I I
REALLY SUPPORT SEA BASS PROGRAMS
WE DON'T HAVE A SEA BASS IN ST
LOUIS COUNTY.
THE NEAREST ONE IS IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY.
THE CHALLENGE FOR HAVING IN ST
LOUIS IS WERE HAVING A LOT OF
ISSUES WITH THE MANAGE MEDI CAL
PROVIDER IN OUR COUNTY IS
TERMINATING COVERAGE FOR NURSING
HOME.
RESIDENTS WE CURRENTLY HAVE OVER
THIRTY FOUR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
NOWHERE TO GO.
AND ARE BEING TOLD THEY HAVE TO
LEAVE THE NURSING HOMES THEY ARE
VERY FRAIL SICK INDIVIDUALS AND
THE SEA BASS WOULD IT.
HELP A LOT WITH THIS PROCESS
WHERE THERE WOULD BE SOMEWHERE
FOR THEM TO GO AT LEAST DURING
THE DAY TO GET SOME ASSISTANCE
SO.
I STRONGLY SUGGEST ANYTHING YOU
CAN DO TO HELP FUND -- POSITIONS
TO GET THEM CERTIFIED TO GET NEW
PROGRAMS AND WOULD BE GREATLY
APPRECIATED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LEASE A COMMON
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION OF WHEAT
AS AS A MEMBER ASSOCIATION MADE
UP OF THE THIRTY FIVE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAMS -- WANT TO STAND IN
SUPPORT OF WHAT CLAY WAS TALKING
ABOUT WHEN HE WAS SAYING THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO REINVENT YOU
DON'T HAVE TO HAVE EVERYTHING
NEW.
BUT YOU HAVE TO SUPPORT AND
RESOURCE APPROPRIATELY THOSE
PROGRAMS THAT DO EXIST AND THE
SEA BASS IS A CLASSIC EXAMPLE OF
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES THAT
MAKE A DIFFERENCE AT GREAT COST
VALUE TO THE STATE SO WE
ENCOURAGE.
THIS PROPOSAL AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CLEARLY KITANA
SENIOR SERVICES COALITION OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY -- JUST BASICALLY
STATE STEPPING UP HERE TO SAY
THAT WE FULLY SUPPORT.
THE A FUNDING AND FULL FUNDING
YOU.
THANK YOU.
BACK UP TO THE DíAS.
THANK YOU I JUST NEED SOME
CLARIFICATION PLEASE ON PAGE --
AT PAGE EIGHTEEN THERE'S A CHART
ON WORKLOAD HISTORY.
I AND THERE'S IT BY THE FIRST
SECTION PERCENTAGE OF COURT
QUARTERLY -- UNDER MONITORING
CALLS COMPLETED AND IT LOOKS
LIKE IT'S A 201321470%
201421553% AND SO ON
220-172-2018 IS 25% CAN YOU TELL
ME WHAT THAT MEANS.
AND WHAT IMPACT IT HAS.
IF ANY ON I JUST.
I SAW A SHARP DECREASE IN.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT.
SO I I I THE PROGRAMMATIC NEEDS
I THINK THE DEPARTMENT CAN TALK
ABOUT BUT THE WORKLOAD HISTORY
KIND OF DEMONSTRATES THAT THIS
PROGRAM DOES NEED THE STAFF HAT
WE REQUEST.
GIVEN THAT.
THE THE PERCENT OF CALLS THAT
SHOULD BE A HUNDRED SHOULD BE
UNDER THAT THINK THAT'S THAT'S
THE COLLISION SO WHAT CAN YOU
TELL ME WHAT WAS A HUNDRED
SUPPORTER BECAUSE WE MAKE
QUARTERLY CALLS TO ALL --
CERTIFIED SEA BASS PROVIDERS TWO
OF THEM.
IT'S ONE OF OUR DESK MONITORING
PROCEDURES SO WE CAN DETERMINE.
WHAT THEY'RE DOING -- WITH
REGARDS TO CARE WITHIN THE
FACILITY WE CAN FOLLOW UP WITH
THEM ON CONCERNS WE MADE A PATH
FROM THE PRIOR MONITORING VISIT.
TO DETERMINE THE STATUS OF
CORRECTION THAT SORT OF I'M
SWELLED BUT IT'S SO I GUESS WHAT
MY POINT IS IS IF YOU SEE
THERE'S A SHARP DECLINE IN.
IN AND YOU KNOW THE CALLS AND SO
I KNOW THAT SOME OF THESE --
REQUESTS HAVE BEEN ONE TIME ASK
SOUL WHAT AT WHERE I'M GOING.
WITH THIS IS THAT INSTEAD OF
MAKING ONE TIME ASKS ALL THE
TIME COUNT WE MAKE IS THERE A
WAY TO MAKE THIS.
KIND OF AN ONGOING OF FUNDING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE.
THIS THESE CALLS ARE BEING MADE
AYE THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO
REQUEST ONGOING FUNDING AND THE
FOUR POSITIONS SO THIS IS AN
ONGOING OKAY LUCIEN. TO ADDRESS
THE WORK OF THE NEEDS OF THE PRO
OKAY THAT'S THE MET THAT'S WHAT
YOU SHOULD.
BE TELLING US I THINK THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE POINT THAT'S WHY I'M
I'M I'M TRYING TO POKE YOU TO
THAT TELL ME THAT.
CAN YOU TELL ME CLEARLY WHAT YOU
NEED.
SO A WEEK CLEAR I I WILL. THREE
STATE.
AND SAY THAT WE NEED THESE
POSITIONS ON AN ONGOING BASIS IN
ORDER TO MEET NOT ONLY THE
ONGOING WORKLOAD THAT'S
ASSOCIATED WITH -- MONITORING
AND COMPLIANCE WITHIN SEE THAT'S
POSSIBILITIES BUT ALSO TO ASSIST
US IN MEETING NEW REQUIREMENTS
HAVING TO DO WITH THE HOME
COMMUNITY BASED SETTINGS ROLE.
OF PROVIDERS SCREENING
REQUIREMENTS AND ALSO TO TO
ADDRESS THE INFLUX OF
APPLICATIONS FROM.
ENTITIES THEY'RE INTERESTED NOW
IN THE COMING SEA BASS PROVIDERS
RIGHT AND THEN SO WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN WE'RE ONLY MONITORING
TWENTY FIVE OR MAKE MONITORING
25%.
WELL THE IMPACT I I MEAN SO THE
THE DOWNSIDE OF NOT BEING ABLE.
TO WHAT THE PROVIDER PROVIDERS
THROUGH OUR QUARTERLY CALLS IS
THAT THERE THERE'S INFORMATION
THAT IT IS IMPORTANT TO THE
MONITORING PROCESS THAT WE MAY
NOT GATHER.
AND SO IT IT CREATES AN
INFORMATION VOICE FOR US SO IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
DO QUARTERLY CALL.
IN THIS INSTANCE IN ORDER TO
STAY ON TOP OF PROVIDERS
COMPLIANCE WITH THE APPLICABLE
RULES AND ULTIMATELY TO SUPPORT
OPTIMAL PARTICIPANT CARE.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT I WANTED
TO HEAR.
THE OTHER MEMBERS [inaudible]
RESTAURANTS.
ALL RIGHT THAT CLOSES ISSUE TOO
WE'LL LEAVE THAT FILE ITEM OPEN
AND MOVED TO ISSUE [inaudible]
THREE ITEM.
THREE IF WE CAN MAKE SPACE AT
THE WITNESS TABLE ON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD YEAR OFF.
THE COUPLE SIX FROM.
AND LEASE A COLEMAN YEAH ALL.
WHAT DO YOU WANT?
HOWEVER YOU WANT.
TO SEE.
THERE YOU GO WHEREVER YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU.
I'M REQUESTING A FIVE MILLION
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHT DOLLARS.
IN TWO HUNDRED EIGHT THOUSAND
SIXTY FOUR DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE FUNDS FOR THE LOCAL
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM.
AS YOU HEARD EARLIER THERE
POSSIBLY THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS LIVING IN LICENSE
CARE FACILITIES EVERYDAY.
LICENSE CARE FACILITIES CONSIST
OF SKILLED NURSING HOMES
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES AND
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE L. ELDERLY.
LONG TERM CARE OF OMBUDSMAN
SERVICE A VITAL RESOURCE TO
RESIDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THERE A
LITTLE OVER THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND COMPLAINTS FILED WITH
THE LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN.
THEY INVESTIGATE ADDRESS AND
HELP RESOLVE THE COMPLAINTS OF
UNSAFE CARE OR A VIOLATION OF
RIGHTS RESIDENTS LIVING IN
LICENSE CARE FACILITIES. 60% OF
THE RESIDENTS DO NOT HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS VISITING TO OBSERVE CARE
AND REPORT PROBLEMS.
THERE FOR THE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROVIDES A REGULAR
VISITING PRESENCE IN FACILITIES
WHICH ALL RESIDENTS HAVE AN
IMPERFECT IN IN IN PERSON
CONTACT.
OUR SENIOR POPULATION IS GROWING
RAPIDLY -- WE MUST PROTECT OUR
OUR SENIORS TO MAKE SURE THEY
HAVE AN ADVOCATE.
THAT IS THE PURPOSE OF THE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN THIS FUNDING
WILL IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF CARE
OF OUR RESIDENTS LIVING IN LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU I ALSO GOING TO BE --
THE CHAIR I I'M GONNA BE
DRESSING ITEM NUMBER FIVE WHICH
I CAN DO THAT NOW WE'RE GOING TO
COME BACK LET'S THE SKILL
THROUGH THIS ONE AND THEN COME
BACK AROUND.
THAT'S FINE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LISA
COLEMAN I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
ASSOCIATION.
I'D LIKE TO TO START BY THANKING
THE STAFF FOR DOING SUCH A VERY
COMPLETE AND THOROUGH REVIEW OF
OUR PROPOSAL.
I RECOGNIZE AND I AM VERY
GRATEFUL THAT I AM SPEAKING
BEFORE A FRIENDLY AUDIENCE OF
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM SUPPORTERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO START BY ASKING
THAT THE AGENDA INFORMATION
UPDATED BE -- BUT THE AGENDA
INFORMATION THAT IT BE UPDATED
TO REFLECT THE CURRENT NUMBER OF
VOLUNTEERS IN THE PROGRAM.
AS THE NUMBER LISTED ON PAGE
TWENTY FOUR IS OUT OF DATE -- AS
THE MOST RECENT SADA STATE
OMBUDSMAN REPORT PUBLISHED JUST
THIS MONTH INDICATES THAT THE
NUMBER OF VOLUNTEERS HAS DROPPED
FROM YOUR REPORTED LIST OF SEVEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TO SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WAS A VERY BAD
YEAR. FOR RETENTION OF
VOLUNTEERS.
ADDITIONALLY I'D LIKE TO USE
THIS TIME TO PROVIDE SOME
INSIGHT ABOUT THE RECOMMENDATION
OF A POTENTIAL BUDGET.
STRATEGY BY USING THE INSTITUTE
OF MEDICINE'S REPORT WHICH HAS A
STAFFING TOO BAD RATIO.
BOB.
JOE RODRIGUEZ I THINK WAS MORE
SUBTLE THAN I WOULD LIKE TO BE
AND SO I'M JUST GOING TO BE MUCH
MORE DIRECT ON Y..
AS AN ASSOCIATION WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT THE ONE FULL TIME
EMPLOYEE TO TWO THOUSAND BEDS IS
AN APPROPRIATE STANDARD OF
MEASURE.
MA'AM BE AS CANDID AS YOU NEED
TO BE.
I APPRECIATE THAT OKAY SO SO
WE'RE GONNA START WITH THIS IS
THE INSTITUTE OF MEDICINE'S
REPORT REAL PEOPLE REAL PROBLEM.
THIS POOR REPORT WAS PUBLISHED
IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE USING
NINETEEN NINETY THREE DATA.
SO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO USE THE
WORK THAT WE WERE DOING IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE AS THE
MEASURE FOR FUNDING THE PROGRAM
IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN I'D
LIKE TO POINT OUT A FEW THINGS
THAT HAVE CHANGED.
I'M NOT GOING TO EVEN GO INTO
TECHNOLOGY OR BUDGETS BUT JUST.
WHO HAD THAT RIGHT -- BUT IN.
NINETEEN NINETY THREE THE TOP
COMPLAINT THAT LOCAL OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAMS INVESTIGATED A 21% FOR
QUALITY OF CARE. 18% WERE
RESIDENT RIGHTS LESS THAN 10% OF
ALL THE COMPLAINTS INVESTIGATED
THAT YEAR HAD ANYTHING TO DO
WITH ABUSE.
AND YET IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
FORTY HEARD IT REPORTED.
NEARLY ONE IN EVERY FOUR
COMPLAINTS INVESTIGATED FELL
UNDER THE CATEGORY OF ELDER
ABUSE.
OUR TOP GO GETTER THIS YEAR
RESIDENT ON RESIDENT CONFLICT.
FOLLOWED SHORTLY BY PHYSICAL
NEGLECT.
SO IF YOU WANT TO USE YOUR RATIO
OF ONE TO TWO THOUSAND I THINK
YOU HAVE TO USE THE COMPARISON
THE WORKLOAD AND IT IS CHANGED
[inaudible]
SECOND.
THIS PROGRAM THIS THIS REPORT
IDENTIFIES MINIMUM EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM.
WHY IN THE WORLD WOULD WE WANT
TO USE THAT AS OUR STANDARD? TO
START OUT OUR DISCUSSION WITH
THIS BEING THE MINIMUM
EFFECTIVENESS.
THIS IS CALIFORNIA.
THE OTHER PART OF THAT.
IS THAT WHEN THIS REPORT WAS
WRITTEN IT'S A FEDERAL REPORT.
AN OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS ARE RUN
VERY DIFFERENTLY ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY'RE ON BUT IT'S BEEN
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE -- ONE
CENTRAL OFFICE THAT DOES ALL OF
THE PHONE INTAKE OR ALL OF THE
THE THE AT ADMINISTRATIVE WORK
OR THERE ARE STATES WHERE THEY
HAVE A FEW LOCAL PROGRAMS.
BUT CALIFORNIA AS YOU HEARD
EARLIER WE BELIEVE IN THE TRIPLE
A PROCESS WE BELIEVE IN LOCAL
CONTROL AND SO THE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA.
IS EITHER A CONTRACTED PROGRAM
OR A DOES WRECKED SERVICE
PROGRAM THROUGH THE THIRTY THREE
AREA AGENCIES ON AGING.
SO IF YOU'RE GOING TO USE THAT
STANDARD OF THE ONE TO TWO
THOUSAND THEN YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO FACTOR IN ALL OF THE STAFF
THAT WE HAVE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
DOING PHONE CALLS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR OF INVESTMENT
IN US LAST YEAR THAT EXTRA TWO
POINT THREE MILLION THAT RAISING
OF OUR BASE FROM THE THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND I
AM EXCITED TO TELL YOU THAT
WE'RE BACK TO ANSWERING OUR
PHONES AS HUMAN BEINGS.
THAT MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE WHEN
YOU ARE.
EIGHTY FIVE MAKES A DIFFERENCE
TO ME NOW BECAUSE I GET
FRUSTRATED PUSHING BUTTONS AND
WAITING AND HOLDING BUT IF IF I
DON'T HAVE A PERSONAL PHONE.
IF THE ONLY WAY I CAN REACH AN
OMBUDSMAN IS BY USING THE NURSES
STATION PHONE.
I DON'T HAVE THE OPTION TO PUSH
THE PHONE NUMBER FOR YOU TO CALL.
TO CALL ME BACK.
IT'S NOT MY LINE.
AND WHAT KIND OF CONFIDENTIALLY
CONFIDENTIALITY DO I HAVE.
WHEN THE PHONE LINE GOES TO THE
NURSES STATION AND THE NURSES
SAID ODDS THE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM?
SO HAVING THAT HUMAN BEING
ANSWERING THE PHONE I CANNOT
THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR THAT
INVESTMENT.
GOING BACK.
TO OTHER ASPECTS OF THIS PROGRAM
ARE AT THE REPORT -- THIS REPORT.
IT TALKS ABOUT -- MINIMUM
AFFECTED PROGRAMS.
AND THE BUDGETING THAT'S NEEDED.
SO.
WE'VE LEARNED TODAY THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT.
SO IF YOU WANT TO DO A RATIO YOU
HAVE ONE OR TWO WAYS YOU EITHER.
TAKE OUT OUT OF THAT HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN ALL OF THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE CURRENTLY ANSWERING OUR
PHONES ALL OF THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE DOING ON THE INTAKE ALL OF
THE SUPERVISORY OF STAFF AND
VOLUNTEERS.
AND THE PROGRAM COORDINATORS
[inaudible]
OR YOU YOU SUBTRACT ANY EITHER
WHAT YOU EITHER ADD THAT NUMBER
AND TO THE RATIO.
OF THE ONE TO TWO THOUSAND BEDS
OR YOU SUBTRACTED FROM OUR
CURRENT NUMBER OF A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN BOB.
I I I GUESS. EIGHT A RATIO IS
CERTAINLY A WAY TO FUND THE
PROGRAM.
AND IF YOU DO PREFER TO USE THAT --
WE YET KHALKHAL WHILE WE HAVE
SEVERAL DIFFERENT IDEAS AND AND
EVEN AN OPTION OF A POSSIBLE
STAFF TOO BAD RATIO.
OF BUT WE HAVE OTHER IDEAS ALSO
AND WE'D BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE SUBCOMMITTEE IN THE ALLEY --
IN THE DEPARTMENT TO COME UP
WITH THE RIGHT FIT.
BUT IT HAS TO BE REALLY SOON --
SO.
IT IF YOU.
THE OTHER OPTION OF COURSE IS
THE STATE MIGHT CHOOSE TO USE
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL AS WE'VE
IDENTIFIED IT HERE WHICH IS ON
QUARTERLY VISITS AND THE NEED --
FOR ON THAT'S BEEN IN THE FIELD.
THE PROPOSAL THAT'S PRESENTED TO
YOU TODAY IS A REQUEST FOR FIVE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO TO
CONDUCT QUARTERLY UNANNOUNCED
FACILITY VISITS BY BOTH PAID
STAFF.
AND HIGHLY TRAINED VOLUNTEERS.
THIS PROPOSAL BUYS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FOURTH THOUSAND ADDITIONAL HOURS
OF I'M BUT SPENT EYES AND EARS
AND FACILITIES.
IT BUYS THE STATE PROMPT
ASSISTANCE WITH THE ABILITY TO
INVESTIGATE AN ADDITIONAL EIGHT
THOUSAND COMPLAINTS.
THIS INVESTMENT MEANS THAT YOU
WOULD UTILIZE STAFF INSTEAD OF
RELYING SO HEAVILY ON THE THE
VOLUNTEERS.
BOB TO ADD TO INVESTIGATE ELDER
ABUSE COMPLAINTS.
YOU KNOW I'VE WE'VE ALREADY SAID
ONE IN FOUR COMPLAINTS WAS ELDER
ABUSE WE'RE NOT GOING TO
MAINTAIN AS EVIDENCED BY THE
LACK OF MORE.
VOLUNTEERS LEADING US WHEN I CAN
MAINTAIN A ROBUST VOLUNTEER
PROGRAM IF WERE ASKING
VOLUNTEERS TO DO SO MUCH ELDER
ABUSE INVESTIGATION.
THIS STATEWIDE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM
HAS BECOME SO COMPLAINT DRIVEN
THAT THERE IS LITTLE TIME TO
CONDUCT.
REGULAR UNANNOUNCED ACILITY
VISITS THE LOS ANGELES PROGRAM
THEY CONDUCTED. FIVE FEWER THAN
ELEVEN THOUSAND COMPLAINTS LAST
YEAR.
AND YET THEY WERE ABLE TO VISIT
ONLY 60% OF THEIR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES AND ONLY 7%
OF THEIR ASSISTED LIVING
FACILITIES ON A QUARTERLY BASIS.
SO WHAT HAPPENS WHEN OMBUDSMAN'S
ARE IN FACILITIES.
I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOU TO A
REAL LIVE NINJA.
AT THE END OF THE TABLE OVER
THERE -- MACHEL PERIL UP FROM
THE LOS ANGELES PROGRAM LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN.
THANK YOU THESE THAT AND THANK
YOU EVERYBODY FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY I APOLOGIZE MY BACK.
I FELT TERRIBLE WERE USED TO
JUST MAKE SURE YOU TALK IN THE
MIKE IS IT IS BEING TELEVISED --
MY NAME IS MICHELLE PERELLA AND
I'M THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR OF THE
WISE AND HEALTHY AGING LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN PROS PROGRAMS
SERVING THE CITY AND COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES.
MONITORING VISITS ARE CRITICAL
TO THE FILLING THE PROMISED
REVISED SAFE AND QUALITY LONG
TERM CARE.
IN JANUARY OF TWENTY NINETEEN AN
OWNER OF THREE SMALL ASSISTED
LIVINGS WAS ARRESTED ON FELONY
ELDER ABUSE CHARGES. ONE OF HIS
RESIDENCE A NINETY ONE YEAR OLD
FEMALE WHO IS CONFINED TO HER
BED AND HAD DIAGNOSIS OF
DEMENTIA WAS FOUND IN THE
MORNING BY HER CARE GIVER TO
HAVE A FIGHT ON HER HAND.
FROM A RAT.
IT HAD NOT BEEN THERE THE NIGHT
BEFORE.
DESPITE WAS SO SEVERE THAT IT
EXPOSED HER BONE.
AND WHEN THE CARE GIVER LIFTED
THE BLANKET OFF OF HER TO
PREPARE HER FOR THE DAY I ROUTE
WAS SEEN JUMPING FROM HER BODY.
THERE WERE DROPPINGS AROUND HER
BODY.
AND WHEN HE WENT TO REMOVE THE
SOFT BOOT THAT IS USED PROTECTOR
FOOT ANOTHER ROUTE WAS SEEN
JUMPING FROM HER AND SHE HAD
BITE MARKS ON THE ARCH OF HER
FOOT THAT WERE BLEEDING.
ON THE CARE GIVERS ALLEGE THAT
THEY INFORM THE ADMINISTRATOR
AND THE OWNER.
WEEKLY ON A REGULAR BASIS AND
THAT NO ACTION WAS TAKEN BY THEM.
THE RESIDENT DIED NOT LONG AFTER
THIS INCIDENT OCCURRED.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AN OMBUDSMAN
VISIT AT THIS FACILITY ONCE.
UNFORTUNATELY IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE NEVER HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY.
AND IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE WERE
ONLY ABLE TO VISIT THIS FACILITY.
AFTER THIS HORRIBLE INCIDENT
OCCURRED.
WE DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
MAINTAIN A REGULAR PRESENCE AT
THE FACILITIES.
AND MANAGE THE INCREASINGLY
BURGEONING CASELOADS THAT WE
HAVE IT'S REALLY HARD TO COME
HERE AND TELL YOU THIS TERRIBLE
STORY.
AND TELL YOU WHAT WE'RE FACING.
IF WE COULD DO YOU CONDUCT OUR
REGULAR UNANNOUNCED VISITS.
WE MIGHT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
OBSERVE THIS OR AT LEAST BEEN
AVAILABLE FOR THE STAFF TO BE
ABLE TO SHARE THIS INFORMATION
SO THAT WE CAN TAKE ACTION.
THE THREE FACILITIES WERE SHOT
DOWN -- BY COMMUNITY CARE
LICENSING WITH THE ASSISTANCE
FROM THE ON BUDGETS MEN AND
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES -- THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE RESOURCES
WERE REQUIRED TO AID IN THAT
PROCESS AND WE'RE INVESTIGATING
AND ARE NOW PROSECUTING.
AND WHILE WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR ALL
OF THESE EFFORTS TO SEEK JUSTICE
FOR THIS RESIDENT.
IT'S COSTLY AND IT'S A LINK THE
PATH TO RESOLUTION.
THIS PRESIDENT WAS RELYING ON
CARE GIVERS FOR EVERYTHING SHE
NEEDED SHE WAS RELIANT ON THE
OWNER OF THIS FACILITY TO GIVE
HER A SAFE HOME.
AND SHE WAS RELIANT ON THE
OMBUDSMAN TO BE THERE TO PROTECT
HER RATES AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT SYSTEM DIDN'T BREAK DOWN
AND WE ALL FAILED HER. FOR A
SMALL INVESTMENT.
CALIFORNIA CAN MOVE CLOSER TO
FOR FILLING THE PROMISED PROVIDE
SAFE AND QUALITY CARE. FOR LONG
TERM RESIDENTS.
YOU CAN MAKE THIS POSSIBLE BY
ADEQUATELY FUNDING OUR PROGRAMS.
AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT AND
REALLY THANK YOU FOR THIS TIME
OPPORTUNITY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO WHY DON'T WE TAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS POINT
[inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
YEAH.
AN AFTERNOON I'M GARY PASSED
MORE WITH THE CONGRESS OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS.
AND THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE BEEN
IN THIS SESSION BEFORE.
UP BY THAT I MEAN THIS MAN YOU
KNOW THAT THE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM
IS ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS TO ME AND MEMBERS.
MEMBERS OF MY ORGANIZATION.
GO BACK AND RE READ [inaudible]
HAMMOND.
WHAT YOU'VE BEEN TOLD THERE ARE
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE?
STILL STUCK IN FACILITIES.
AND INSTITUTIONS CARING FOR THEM
IN CALIFORNIA AND IN FACT IN
SPITE OF ALL OF OUR EFFORTS TO
MOVE PEOPLE OUT OF INSTITUTIONS
IN THE COMMUNITY.
THAT NUMBER WILL PROBABLY NEVER
GO DOWN MUCH.
BOB.
THERE ARE A LOT OF CONDITIONS
LIKE ADVANCED DEMENTIA THAT
REQUIRE THAT PEOPLE LIVE IN AN
INSTITUTIONAL SETTING.
SO WE HAVE THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE AND 60% OF THEM
HAVE NO FAMILY MEMBER. TO BE
INVOLVED IN THEIR CARE TO WATCH
AND TO SEEK AS A SPECIAL
ASSISTANT OR REPORT PROBLEMS.
THAT MEANS THERE ARE NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
TODAY.
IN A FACILITY THAT HAVE NO
ALTERNATIVE THAT HAVE NO HELP.
AND THEY ALSO HAVE NO
LEGISLATORS WILLING TO INVEST IN
THEIR CARE.
AND I URGE YOU I URGE YOU TO
PLEASE CHANGE THIS.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON.
DURING EL FARO AND I'VE BEEN
FIVE YEARS AS A VOLUNTEER OF OF
FOR A BUT IT'S BEEN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY.
I COME TODAY YOU'VE HEARD MANY
OF THE OF THE INFORMATION THUS
FAR AND I CANNOT SAY HOW VERY
IMPORTANT IT IS. TO CONSIDER OUR
ASK.
AND AN INCREASE OUR FUNDING
ESPECIALLY FOR UNANNOUNCED
VISITS IN FACILITIES.
IN A I'LL SPEAK FROM MY OWN
EXPERIENCE IN ONE DAY IN ONE
WEEK OF MAKING AN UNANNOUNCED
VISIT.
I HAD -- A RESIDENT.
SCREAMING FOR HELP.
SHE NEEDED IN A TO COME BUT WAS
TOLD TO JUST URINATE IN HER BED.
AND ASKED ME TO PLEASE GET SOME
HELP FOR HER THAT'S THAT'S ONE
TO ANOTHER GENTLEMAN WAS SITTING
IN FECES.
AT IS CALLED LIGHT ON FOR MORE
THAN FORTY FIVE MINUTES.
ANOTHER WE FOUND DEBRIS IN THE
HALLWAYS WHERE RESIDENTS STAFF
VISITORS OR WALKING THAT'S ONE
THAT'S THAT'S JUST ONE DAY IN IN
IN MY LIFE.
IT BEING INSIDE OF JUST ONE
FACILITY FOR ONE WEEK SO I
CANNOT TELL YOU FROM MY OWN
HEART AND YOU'VE HEARD ALL THE
THINGS HOW VERY TRUE.
THE EAST THESE ARE NOT STORIES
THESE ARE REAL ACTUAL INCIDENCES.
FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION ARE VETERANS MAYBE
OUR DOCTORS MAYBE THERE WERE
CLEAR OUR CLERGY.
I LOVED ONES MAYBE ME SUNDAY AND
I SURE HOPE THAT I HAVE IN THEM
BUT IT'S BEEN OUT THERE
ADVOCATING FOR ME BECAUSE WE
NEED IT.
SINCE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PREVIOUS SUPPORT TO OUR PROGRAM
AND I ASK YOU TO STRONGLY
CONSIDER THIS SO THAT I CAN
CONTINUE VOLUNTEERING AND DOING
WHAT I DO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
VOLUNTEERING.
JERRY DEAFENED BY VOLUNTEER FOR
A A. R. P. -- A A RP HAS THREE
POINT THREE MILLION MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL. FOR
FUNDING BECAUSE IT COVERS.
SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS AND MANY OF THEM DON'T
HAVE ANYONE ELSE TO ADVOCATE FOR
THEM AND TO MAKE THESE
UNANNOUNCED VISITS SO THAT.
PROBLEMS CAN BE.
RESOLVED AND MAYBE EVEN
IDENTIFIED SOMETIMES IT'S A
CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE.
AND WE HAVE HEARD NOW TODAY
ABOUT THE INCREASING ABUSE OF
ELDERS AND ELSE'S POPULATION IS
GROWING EXPONENTIALLY.
WE WE NEED TO SUPPORT THIS
PROGRAM IT'S IT'S CRITICAL TO
OUR OUR STATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HI I'M BRANDY FOR OUR
AND I'M A FAIRLY NEW BALLING.
TERROR FOR THE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM
IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY.
AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT I
CAN ATTEST TO THE REAL NEED FOR
THE RESIDENTS HAVING
REPRESENTATION.
AND WE ONLY HAVE YOU KNOW A FEW
VOLUNTEERS FOR TO COUNTIES AND
THAT'S OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FACILITIES.
AND I JUST.
ON BEHALF OF THE RESIDENTS JUST
URGE YOU TO CONSIDER THIS
FUNDING THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SUSAN TO MARS
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION I WANT
TO THANK DOCTOR WOULD FOR
ADVANCING THIS PROPOSAL.
AND FOR ALL THE VOLUNTEER
OMBUDSMAN IN THE ROOM --
ACCORDING TO HAVE A COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENT WHETHER IT'S
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE OR ANOTHER
FORM OF DEMENTIA AND MANY OF
THEM DO HAVE FAMILIES WHO VISIT
BUT THEY'RE NOT THERE TWENTY
FOUR HOURS A DAY SO WE REALLY.
WE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI I'M CHRISTA NELSON.
I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
OF THE SENIOR ADVOCACY SERVICES
FOR CINEMA COUNTY AND I CAN'T
TELL YOU HOW PROUD I AM THAT.
ON MINE MEMBER IS THE ONE WHO
BROUGHT THIS PROPOSAL.
FOR WE ARE SO PROUD OF THE WORK.
WE'RE PRETTY PROUD OF HIM TO
YEAH HE'S PRETTY AWESOME.
I VOTED FOR HIM.
IF I WERE IN THE DISTRICT I
WOULD HAVE VOTED FOR HIM.
TO I VOTE FOR YOU TO THE FOR
THAT MATTER.
I MOVED -- I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
JUST FROM THE PROPOSAL
EVERYTHING'S BEEN SAID BUT YOU
KNOW LAST YEAR WE DID EIGHT
HUNDRED NINETY NINE CASES AND I
ONLY HAVE FIVE THOUSAND BEDS.
I AM VERY STRONGLY SUPPORTED BY
MY TRIPLE A WITH EXTRA FUNDING I
DO A LOT A LOT A LOT OF FUND
RAISING.
BUT I STILL WAS ONLY ABLE TO SEE
17% OF OUR RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES SO NINE HUNDRED CASES
AND ONLY 17%.
THAT REALLY IT SHOWS THE
IMPORTANCE IN THE THE BREAK DOWN
THAT IF YOU'RE ONLY SING 17%
YOU'RE GETTING A LOT OF CASES
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT IN THERE.
SO I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR CONSIDERING AND THANK YOU
DOCTOR.
HI I'M KAREN JONES WITH THE LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATE
ASSOCIATION I'M A BOARD MEMBER
AM ALSO THE MAN AT PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR THE SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY ON BUT BEEN PROGRAM AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI AM NUCLEAR IN THE PROGRAM
COORDINATOR FOR THE LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM IN SANTA
CRUZ AND SAM BENITO COUNTIES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PAST SUPPORT
AND JUST ECHO WHAT DOREEN SAID
WE GO ON THESE FACILITIES ALL
THE TIME A LOT OF TIMES.
RATHER THAN JUST DOING OUR
REGULAR VISIT WERE FLAGGING DOWN
STAFF BECAUSE SOMEBODY IS
SCREAMING FOR HELP SOMEBODY HAS
BEEN SITTING IN THEIR OWN WAYS.
AND YOU THINK THAT FAMILY
MEMBERS GOING VISIT [inaudible]
THEY DON'T.
I'M IN THE FACILITIES ALL THE
TIME AND I RARELY SEE FAMILY OR
FRIENDS.
THERE ARE FEW THAT GO BUT YOU
SHOULD KNOW THAT NO MATTER WHAT
YOUR FAMILY SITUATION IS LIKE
YOU MAY THINK YOU YOU MAY NEVER
BE IN THAT SPOT BECAUSE YOU HAVE
A WIFE FOR A BROTHER OR CHILDREN.
AGING IS GOING TO HAVE A FALL.
AND NOBODY IS IMMUNE TO THESE
FACILITY IF I'M SO JUST KNOW
THAT.
IT'S A IT'S A DIRTY SECRET THAT
OUR COUNTRY KEEPS THAT WE TREAT
OUR ELDERLY THE FLY.
IT'S AWFUL AND WE NEED MORE
OMBUDSMAN IN THE FACILITIES
WATCHING OUT FOR THOSE PEOPLE
THAT CAN'T SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS FEATHER PRITCHARD
I'M A LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
AND SANTA CRUZ IN SAN BENITO
COUNTY.
AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM WE REALLY
REALLY NEED THE SUPPORT WERE
VERY UNDERSTAFFED WE HAVE SO
MUCH TO DO AND SO LITTLE TIME TO
DO IT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO BOB NAYLOR REPRESENTING
THE SIX BEDS INK WHICH IS AN
ASSOCIATION OF OVER TWO THOUSAND
SMALL ASSISTED LIVING ADULT
ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES.
ALSO A CONFIRM THAT AGING WILL
REACH REACH US ALL.
BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY WE THINK
A COMPELLING CASE HAS BEEN MADE
TO THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND
APPRECIATE THAT IS BEING
ADVANCED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO DENISE LAKER INDEPENDENCE
AT HOME IT SCANNED HEALTH PLAN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS AND EVERYTHING
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY
BECAUSE AGING IS A CONTINUUM.
AND IF WE'RE LUCKY WE WE STAY AT
THE HEALTHIER END OF IT AS LONG
AS WE CAN BUT SOMETHING'S GOING
TO GET IN EVERYBODY'S ROAD AND
ALL OF THE SERVICES TODAY ARE
THINGS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
NEEDED OUT THERE FOR ALL OF OUR
AGENTS SENIORS.
AS WELL AS OUR DISABLED
POPULATION BUT THIS PARTICULAR
ITEM THIS IS AT THE END OF THAT
CONTINUUM WHERE PEOPLE ARE AT
THE MERCY OF OTHER PEOPLE AND
THEY SHOULD BE TREATED WITH
DIGNITY AND RESPECT AND THE ONLY
WAY TO DO IT IS TO HAVE PROGRAMS
LIKE THIS IN PLACE.
IN ORDER TO PROTECT THEM IN THE
RIGHT PLACE SUPPORT THE FUNDING.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M NANCY VOLPERT
WITH JEWISH FAMILY SERVICE OF
LOS ANGELES WE SERVE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF SENIORS FROM THE
ACTIVE AND HEALTHY TO THE MOST
FOR ALLEN HOMEBOUND.
WE FULLY SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL
AS PART OF THE BROADER
CONVERSATION AROUND THE NEEDS OF
OUR AGING POPULATION AS THEY
KEEP SAYING.
WE'RE IF WE'RE LUCKY WE WILL BE
AGING ALL OF US AND WE WILL ALL
BECOME SENIORS IF WE ARE SO
FORTUNATE AND WE WANT THESE.
NOT ONLY FOR OUR CURRENT SENIORS
BUT FOR THOSE OF US WHO WHO HOPE
TO BE SENIORS THANKS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CAROL SCHOOL FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA ELDER JUSTICE
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS REQUEST THANK YOU.
DIANA BOY WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
ARE AGENCIES REPRESENTED A
PROTECTIVE SERVICES PROGRAMS
WHICH PROVIDE -- RESPONSE TO
ABUSE AND NEGLECT REPORTS FOR
SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES IN THEIR HOMES AND
COMMUNITIES WELL LONG TERM
OMBUDSMAN -- PROGRAMS ARE
IMPORTANT PARTNERS TO US LOCALLY
IN COMBATING ABUSE WE CAN ATTEST
TO THE VERY DIFFICULT AND
COMPLEX WORK THIS ENTAILS AS
WELL AS THE INCREASE IN RECENT
YEARS AND ABUSE CASES AND WE
STRONGLY.
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I AM AILEEN COONS --
WITH HUNTINGTON HOSPITAL IN
PASADENA WHERE AN EMESIS P.
PROVIDER AND OTHER -- VARIOUS
SERVICES FOR OLDER ADULTS AND
JUST HERE TO SPEAK IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE OMBUDSMAN
PROPOSAL.
AND THE AGING SERVICES IN OUR
NETWORK PROPOSAL BECAUSE THE
ONLY WAY THAT WE CAN BE
EFFECTIVE IN DOING THE JOBS WE
DO BOTH IN ACUTE HOSPITAL AS
WELL AS IN THE COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES THAT MY DEPARTMENT
PROVIDES.
IS HAVING A STRONG CONTINUUM OF
CARE AND ACCOUNTABILITY IS A
GOOD THING AND THIS IS A
BEAUTIFUL MODEL -- REALLY
LEVERAGING VOLUNTEERS -- TO THE
MAXIMUM SO PLEASE SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
VENTURA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS IMPORTANT PROPOSAL TO
PROTECT VULNERABLE SENIORS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ERIN LEAVE I
REPRESENT A CALIFORNIA ASSISTED
LIVING ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORTER AND ON A PERSONAL NOTE
THIRTY YEARS AGO I WASN'T ON ITS
BUTTON.
AND WE HAVE SEEN THIS PROGRAM
GROVE LITTLE TONIGHT SEC STRONG
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ON WHITES WERE
HAD PARTNERS IN CARE FOUNDATION
WE SERVE MANY SENIORS OUT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN HERE JUST TO
SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES CAL CAL TO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING.
I CAN'T STRESS ENOUGH THE VALUE
OF THIS PROGRAM OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND I DID TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
BEFORE HEARING FROM IRAQ
DIRECTOR -- WOULD YOU CARE.
TO COMMENT ON THIS WE DON'T HAVE
ANY SPECIFIC COMMENTS ON THE
PROPOSAL BUT WE'D BE VERY HAPPY
TO WORK WITH MISS COMMON IN YOUR
STAFF TO PROVIDE ANY.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE OR TO WORK
THROUGH THE PROPOSAL WITH THE
WONDERFUL.
I THINK THIS IS WELL AS THE NEXT
FEW ADVOCACY PROPOSALS ARE
REGARD TO BE TALKING ABOUT TODAY.
ALL SEEM TO NATURALLY RELATE TO
WHAT COULD BE IN THE MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING.
OF COURSE GIVEN THE DECADES LONG
ADVOCACY EFFORTS TO RESTORE
THOSE PROGRAMS WITH ONLY SMALLER
PARTIAL SUCCESSES WANT TO SEE
WHAT WHAT STRIDES WE CAN MAKE IN
THE TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN BUDGET.
FOR THE LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM IT SEEMS.
LIKE WE'RE GENUINELY.
CHEN YOU ANALLY UNDER FUNDING A
VALUED ROLE WE'RE BOTH FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS AND STATE MANDATES
ARE GOING UNFULFILLED BECAUSE OF
LACK OF RESOURCES.
THIS IS AT THE HEART OF THE
MATTER.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION -- TO PLEASE
REACT TO THE ISSUES OF FEDERAL
COMPLIANCE RAISED IN THE AGENDA
AND IF THE ADVOCACY REQUEST.
WOULD ALLOW FOR US TO REACH
COMPLIANCE.
I'M GONNA HAVE MISTER RODRIGUEZ
TRANSPLANT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEIZING.
AS I AS I MENTIONED EARLIER IN
MY OPENING COMMENTS THE THE
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVE
DOESN'T ADEQUATELY SUPPORT THE
INSTITUTE OF MEDICINE
RECOMMENDED RATIO OF ONE TO TWO
THOUSAND WHICH WE KNOW.
IS A IS A VERY OLD RATIO AND
DOESN'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT.
THE ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS GIVEN
US THOSE ELDER ABUSE
INVESTIGATIONS AND THE
WITNESSING OF ADVANCE DIRECTIVES.
AS I INDICATED FROM THE DATA
THAT WE DO HAVE.
IF YOU GO BY THE INSTITUTE OF
MEDICINE RATIO WE WOULD NEED A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE FULL TIME
EQUIVALENTS WORKING IN
FACILITIES DEALING WITH THESE
RESIDENTS.
ADDRESSING THEIR CONCERNS AND
ADVOCATING FOR THEM.
RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SEVEN F. T. E.'S.
SOME OF THOSE PEOPLE AREN'T IN
FACILITIES.
BUT RATHER THE ADMINISTRATORS
AND MANAGERS OF PROGRAMS -- IN
ORDER TO TO TO BETTER ADDRESS
[inaudible]
FACILITY COVERAGE.
HERE IN THE STATE -- WE WOULD
NEED ADDITIONAL STAFF. TO MAKE
THOSE NON COMPLAINT RELATED
VISITS EACH QUARTER OF THE YEAR --
THOSE VISITS ARE ARE CRITICALLY
NECESSARY. TO ENSURE THAT
RESIDENTS ARE SAFE THAT THEIR
NEEDS ARE BEING ADDRESSED.
AND TO BE PROACTIVE IN DEALING
WITH PROBLEMS BEFORE THEY BECOME
COMPLAINTS [inaudible]
I THINK.
THE QUESTION STILL REMAINS
THOUGH.
THAT IF WE WERE TO ACCEPT.
LISI'S -- LEASES A PROPOSAL WITH
THAT ALLOW YOU TO COMPLY.
I BELIEVE IT WOULD.
I THINK IT.
I WOULD LIKE.
TO TRY TO SEE.
HOW WE CAN TOGETHER ADVANCE THE
MAIN FIVE POINT TWO MILLION
ADVOCACY REQUEST?
SO IN TANDEM NOT INSTEAD OF I'D
LIKE TO ASK FOR CDA AND
DEPARTMENT FINANCES HELP ON A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE BASIS.
PLEASE WORK WITH THE OMBUDSMAN
ASSOCIATION ON THE REQUEST. FOR
THE REVISED BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
RELATED TO THE STATE HEALTH
FACILITIES CITATION PENALTIES
ACCOUNT.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO ASK FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THIS WOULD
MEAN CONSULTING WITH DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH.
THE DEPARTMENT DEPARTMENT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES -- WITH THEIR
COUNTERPARTS TO CONSIDER HOW THE
QUALITY ASSURANCE FEE.
CONTRIBUTION MIGHT INCREASE
GIVEN THE CONDITION OF THAT FUND.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT LAST YEAR I
AUTHORED.
EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY AND THIS IS
ONE I REALIZED.
THE VERY CRITICALLY UNDER FUNDED
STATE OF THE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM.
AND IT TO HAVE RECEIVED FINALLY
A COST OF LIVING INCREASE OF TWO
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
OF IT AFTER SO MANY YEARS -- I I
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE THE WHAT
THE ADVOCATES -- BROUGHT TO THE
TABLE.
BECAUSE AND THEN LISTENING TO
THE VOLUNTEERS THOSE OF YOU HERE
AND THOSE THAT WE HAVE READ
ABOUT ANECDOTALLY -- IT IS CLEAR.
WITHOUT ANY ANY.
DOUBT THAT WITHOUT THE THE
VOLUNTEERS.
EVEN THE LITTLE THAT IS DONE
COULD NOT BE DONE.
AND SO I WANT TO PUBLICLY THANK
ALL OF YOU.
WHO ARE AND WHO HAVE BEEN
VOLUNTEERS BECAUSE OUR SENIORS
WOULD BE COMPLETELY UNPROTECTED
IF YOU WERE NOT THERE
[inaudible]
OF I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU
REGISTRATION IF YOU'RE AGREEABLE
TO THE REQUESTS THAT I JUST
PRESENTED.
WHAT TO SAY THAT THE TO FUND YOU
MENTION ONE THE SPECIAL DEPOSIT
FUNDS UNDER DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THEN THE?
QUALITY ASSURANCE FEE FUND
THAT'S ALSO UNDER THE PARM
HEALTHCARE SERVICES WOULD HAVE
TO CORNING WITH THEM TO SEE
WHAT'S POSSIBLE BUT WE'RE HAPPY.
TO GAUGE IN THESE CONVERSATIONS.
WELL.
NOT TRYING TO PUT YOU ON THE
SPOT BUT I'M GONNA PUT YOU ON
THE SPOT.
I DO WANT TO COMMITMENT.
IT IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
AND I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
INSTEAD OF SAY WE WILL TRY.
WE HAVE TO DO IT WE HAVE TO LOOK
TO SEE.
BECAUSE LOTS OF WORK HAS GONE
INTO TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
MAKE THE SUSTAINABLE.
AND IF IF THERE HAVE BEEN.
IF THERE'S ALREADY BEEN WORK
DONE TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
WE CAN GET THE MONEY TO MAKE IT
SUSTAINABLE WE REALLY OWE IT TO
THE ADVOCATES. TO FIND OUT.
IF THIS IS DOABLE AND IF IT IS
FIGURE OUT WHAT WE HAVE TO DO.
BUT IT TAKES US BACK TO THE THE
TO THE MASTER PLAN.
OUR OUR GOVERNOR IN THE STATE OF
THE STATE TALKED ABOUT THIS.
SO WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IT BEFORE
IT OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO ARE HERE
HAVE ALSO TALKED ABOUT THIS
BEFORE WE NEED A MASTER PLAN.
OUR DOCTOR WOULD JUST TALKED
ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE NEED A
MASTER PLAN.
OUR GOVERNOR HAS NOW TALKED
ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE NEED A
MASTER PLAN.
WE'RE GOING TO GET A MASTER PLAN.
AND I THINK IT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THAT WE ALL MOVE IN
THAT DIRECTION -- IN THE IN THE
LAST -- SUB ONE A HEARING THAT
WE HAD THERE WAS A REQUEST FOR
MILLION DOLLARS FOR STUDY.
SO WE'RE GOING TO STUDY WITH THE
NEEDS OF OUR SENIORS ARE.
AND THEN WHAT.
WE DON'T HAVE A PLAN WITH WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO WITH THAT.
WITH THE RESULTS OF THIS STUDY
THEN IT BECOMES MEANINGLESS AND
THAT'S A MILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE
SPENT ON THE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM
INSTEAD OF SPENDING ON STUDY.
WE HAVE AN IDEA ALREADY WHAT THE
PROBLEM IS WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY.
AND IT ISN'T TO SAY THAT
SOMEONE'S OF FOLDER SOMEONE'S
NOT AT FAULT WE'RE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER.
WE'RE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER I
SHARED THE STORY LAST TIME THAT
I I ONCE A WEEK.
OR WHAT ONE WEEK PER YEAR I
SPENT ON SENIOR ADVOCACY IN MY
DISTRICT WERE ALL WE DO IS WE
VISIT ALL OF OUR SENIOR CENTERS
ARE HOUSING EVERYTHING HAVING TO
DO WITH MY SENIORS.
AND I THE NUMBER GOES UP FRONT
WAS FOURTEEN NOW LAST LAST YEAR
WAS TWENTY SOMETHING -- SO WE
BRING IN EXPERTS WE WE TALK TO
THEM ABOUT WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE
WE LISTEN TO THEM ABOUT WHAT THE
NEEDS ARE.
BUT THE STORY I WANTED TO TELL
YOU IS THAT I WAS TELLING MY
MOTHER.
MOM I'M SO EXCITED I AM DOING
THIS WHOLE WEEK WITH ALL THE
SENIORS IN.
A WE'RE FINDING OUT WHAT THEIR
NEEDS ARE AND I'M SO EXCITED
BECAUSE THE ONLY WAY THAT I'M
GOING TO REPRESENT MY SENIORS IS
TO KNOW WHAT THE NEEDS ARE.
AND SHE LOOKS AT ME SHE SAYS ME
HE DONE REMEMBER YOU TO OUR
SENIOR.
SO I'M TALKING ABOUT MYSELF I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE NEEDS THAT I
HAVE THIS WELL.
AND SO WHEN WE WORK TOGETHER I
KNOW THE WILL BE ABLE TO COME UP
WITH SOME SOLUTIONS.
BUT WE REALLY HAVE TO SAY BEYOND
JUST -- THAT WE'RE GOING TO TRY
TO SEE WHAT WE CAN DO.
AND I REALIZE WE ARE THAT YOU
YOU WERE THE ACTING -- DIRECTOR
AND I'M SO PROUD TO HAVE YOU
THERE -- TO TO HAVE YOU LEADING
THIS SUCH AN IMPORTANT --
DEPARTMENT AND YOU CAN TELL BY
THE MEMBERS HERE THE TWO HAVE
WILLING PARTICIPANTS YOU HAVE
PARTNERS HERE.
AND WE WANT TO WORK WITH YOU WE
WANT TO ADVOCATE FOR YOU BECAUSE
WHEN WE ADVOCATE FOR YOU AND FOR
THE DEPARTMENT WE'RE ADVOCATING
FOR EVERYBODY IN OUR DISTRICT.
AND ALL OF THOSE WHO ARE
PRIVILEGED ENOUGH BLESSED ENOUGH
TO REACH THE AGE OF BEING CALLED
A SENIOR.
SO DO COUNT ON US COUNT ON US
AND WE WANT TO WORK WITH YOU WE
WANT TO WORK WITH THE ADVOCATES.
WE KNOW THAT WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A BUDGET.
THERE ARE LIMITED FUNDS WE KNOW
THAT WE TO FIGURE OUT.
WHETHER WE'RE GONNA SPEND IT
HERE WE'RE GONNA SPEND THEIR BUT
WHEN WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE PEOPLE
WHO ARE.
NOT LIVING A DIGNIFIED LIFE
ANYMORE AFTERALL THERE YEAR
THEIR YEARS OF SERVING THE
COMMUNITY AND GIVING TO THE
COMMUNITY AND NOW THEY'RE IN THE
FINAL YEARS AND WE JUST TOSS
THEM AWAY.
AND IT'S WRONG.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY WRONG AND THEN
LIKE YOU SAID WE CANNOT TURN A
BLIND EYE ON THAT WE WE WE WE
ARE IN A POSITION TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
AND WE WILL.
WE WILL BECAUSE WE HAVE SO MANY
OF YOU HERE WERE WILLING TO WORK
HARD ON THIS ALL I HAVE TO DO IS
LOOK AT THE VOLUNTEERS IF OUR
VOLUNTEERS ARE WILLING TO PUT IN
ALL THOSE HOURS.
AND I FOUND OUT LAST YEAR HOW
MANY HOURS ARE VOLUNTEERS ARE
PUTTING IN AND I KNEW FOR SURE.
THAT IF THOSE VOLUNTEERS EVER
LEFT US -- GOD SAVE US SO IT
WOULD BE IT WOULD BE SO AWFUL.
BUT TO COUNT ON US WE WANT TO WE
WANT TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE PUT
TOGETHER THIS MASTER PLAN.
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S TALKED ABOUT
IN THAT SO MANY UP HERE OF
TALKED ABOUT WE'VE GOT TO DO IT.
SO THAT WE CAN THEN SAY OKAY
HERE'S OUR PLAN ALL RIGHT SO WE
CAN'T FIND 1100% OF IT.
LET'S FIGURE OUT WHAT'S MOST
IMPORTANT NOW LET'S DO WHAT WE
NEED TO DO.
AND LET'S NOT DUPLICATE IN AN
AREA THAT DOESN'T NEED TO BE
DUPLICATED.
BUT NO WE ARE HERE TO WORK WITH
YOU WE WANT TO WORK WITH YOU AND
WE WILL WORK WITH YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES MISTER FRAZIER.
BUT I'M SURE YOU STOLEN MY
TALKING POINTS BUT AND SO -- ONE
OF THE THINGS I'D LIKE TO HAVE
CLARIFICATION -- WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT THE FORMULA?
ON THE OMBUDSMAN AND YOU TALK
ABOUT THE THE AD MEN AND THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE HIS RING PHONES
AND WHAT NOT WHAT IS THE ACTUAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE GOING OUT IN
THE FIELD.
SO WE HAVE [inaudible]
APPROXIMATELY -- A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY TWO HUNDRED NINETY PAID
STAFF YOU KNOW PEOPLE COME AND
GO.
NOT ALL THOSE NOT ALL OF THOSE
PEOPLE ARE ARE FULL TIME
INDIVIDUALS AS AS WE REFERENCED
EARLIER SOME OF THOSE ARE PART
TIME STAFF.
AS OF THE END OF SEPTEMBER --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE HAD SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY CERTIFIED
OMBUDSMAN VOLUNTEERS.
WHO ALSO PERFORMED THE SAME
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT THE PAID
STAFF DO THEY GO THROUGH THE
SAME EXACT TRAINING?
THOSE VOLUNTEERS THOSE HOURS
VERY PEOPLE.
ARE GENERALLY ASKED TO GIVE AT
LEAST TWENTY HOURS A MONTH. FOR
HOURS A WEEK WE KNOW THAT THAT
VOLUNTEERS GIVE A LOT MORE THAN
FOUR HOURS A WEEK -- WITH THOSE
LIMITED RESOURCES BOTH STAFF AND
VOLUNTEERS -- AND THE SHEER SIZE
OF OUR STATE AND THE NUMBER OF
FACILITIES WE HAVE IT IS
PHYSICALLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR US TO
GET OUT EVERY QUARTER OF THE
YEAR.
EVERY FACILITY IN THE STATE WE
HAVE PROGRAMS.
IN THE FAR NORTHERN PART OF THE
STATE WHERE IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
VOLUNTEER AND MODOC.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE STAFF. FIVE
TO SIX HOURS TO GET THERE BY CAR --
AS A STATE STATED EARLIER THE
THE FEDERAL FUNDS THAT WE
RECEIVED -- SIMPLY DO NOT DO NOT
SUPPORT THE INSTITUTE OF
MEDICINE RECOMMENDED RATIO
[inaudible]
SO.
BUT I'D LIKE TO SEE MANAGERS
THROUGH THE CHAIR IS THAT WHEN
WE LOOK AT A PROPOSAL. TO BRING
US TO AT LEAST COMPLIANCE.
AND NOT A MINIMIZATION OF WHAT
WILL WORK WE'RE GOING TO ACCEPT
THIS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE PASSION
THAT ARE CHAIR HAS AND THIS
WHOLE PANEL?
WE LOOK ABOUT.
WHAT IT WOULD TAKE TO BE
APPROPRIATELY CARING FOR SENIOR
CITIZENS?
IN THESE CARE FACILITIES.
WE DON'T HAVE THIS PROGRAM.
IN THE ID DEPOPULATION
[inaudible]
WHATSOEVER.
SO IF WE'RE GONNA DO THIS WE
NEED TO DO A RIGHT AND NOT
MINIMIZE IT.
HANDS GO FORWARD WITH A PROGRAM
THAT ACTUALLY.
I'M SEEING FEDERAL -- INVESTMENT
CRIME SCENE A VERY SMALL STATE
INVESTMENT [inaudible]
CAN COMPARISON.
AND I THINK WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION.
AS A STATE TO BE ABLE TO STEP UP
AND DO THIS AND I APPRECIATE.
MISTER WOODS COMMITMENT TO
BRINGING THE BAR UP.
BUT I THINK THAT THIS IS A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
BUT I THINK WE HAVE MANY STEPS
TO GO BEFORE WE CAN DO IT.
APPROPRIATELY.
AND I'D LIKE TO SEE THAT WHITE
PAPER.
WHEN YOU CAN DO IT?
I THINK WE ALL LIKE TO FRAZIER
WHITE PAPERS.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER OF
DOCTOR WOULD.
YEAH I JUST LIKE TO SAY A
PERSONAL THANK YOU FOR THE TO
MEMBERS THANK YOU THE CHAIR FOR
YOUR COMMENTS THANK EVERYONE
WHO'S PRESENTED HERE TODAY I
THINK THAT.
I THINK THIS THIS THIS PROPOSAL
THAT THE ASK OF FIVE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IS IS A IS
SIGNIFICANT.
AND I I DO BELIEVE IT'S A SOLID
IT'S A SOLID PROPOSAL -- I A
MOST CONCERNED WITH THAT GOING
FORWARD IN THE NEXT YEAR -- WHAT
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IS AS
BUDGET PROPOSALS COME OUT SO
WHAT I DON'T WANT TO SEE IS HAVE
TO COME BACK NEXT YEAR AND ASK
FOR THE SAME FIVE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS THIS SHOULD BE A
FIVE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLAR
ASK?
AND THAT SHOULD BE ADDED TO THE
BASE LINE GOING FORWARD WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO HAVE ASK FOR
THIS OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
AND GO BACK TO IS A REALLY
CRITICAL NUMBER HERE 60% OF THE
PEOPLE IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND AND AND AND CARE
FACILITIES.
DON'T HAVE A REGULAR VISITOR TO
SEE THEM THIS PROGRAM IS SO
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL OF THAT AND
EVEN IF THE WAY THEIR STAFF NOW
THEY CAN ONLY GET IN IN THE
REPRESENT FOR MY COUNTY CAN ONLY
MAKE IT TO LESS THAN 20%.
OF THE BEDS THAT NEED TO BE
VISITED SO -- SO I I URGE THE
SUPPORT AIRS THE ADMINISTRATION
TO SUPPORT US -- AND RECOGNIZE
TO THAT YOU KNOW THESE THESE
CHALLENGES AND THANK YOU TO THE
LONG TERM CARE ODDS BUT TO OUR
REPRESENTATIVE HERE FOR SAYING
THIS.
WHEN YOU START WHEN YOU START
ADDING RURAL COMMUNITIES TO THIS
AND THE TRAVEL TIME TO GET FROM
ONE COMMUNITY TO ANOTHER YOU'VE
ADDED A WHOLE NOTHER LEVEL OF
COMPLEXITY?
THIS IS IN MANY OF THE DISTRICTS
THAT ARE IN CALIFORNIA ARE NOT
URBAN LOS ANGELES RE CAN GO VERY
CLOSELY TO VISIT A LOT OF PLACES
YOU'VE GOT TO DRIVE HOURS AND
HOURS SOMETIMES. TO COVER A LOT
OF GROUND TO TO VISIT FACILITIES
SO I JUST HELLO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS.
MISTER RAMOS THIS REAL QUICK --
MADAM CHAIR ON SOME OF THE DATA
THAT WAS TALKED ABOUT AS FAR AS
USING NINETEEN NINETY FIVE DATA.
IN ALLOCATING FUNDING BASED ON
AND TWENTY NINETEEN WITH THIS
OUT ALSO START TO ADDRESS THAT
OR IS THAT MORE AT A FEDERAL
LEVEL WHERE THAT DATA IS BEING
COLLECTED.
I THINK THE DATA IS MORE
RELATIVE TO THIS TO THE THE
STAFFING RECOMMENDATIONS -- I
TRUST ME I DON'T LIKE WORKING ON
TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD THAT EITHER
WEEK I THINK I DON'T KNOW HOW WE
FIX THAT -- HECK YOUKNOW WHAT
ARE SOME OF OUR RESERVOIRS IN
CALIFORNIA WERE OPERATING ON
SIXTY YEAR OLD DATA TO DECIDE
HOW MUCH WATER BE RELEASED
DURING RAINSTORMS SO -- SO YEAH
NO I'M SO YOU KNOW SO SO THE DAD
IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL AND AND
BUT WE'RE OPERATE ON THE BEST
DATA WE HAVE BEEN UNFORTUNATELY
IT'S TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD.
I CAN SPEAK TO THAT THAT ISSUE
THE THE INSTEAD OF MEDICINE
REPORT IS AND HOW WE ALLOCATE
FUNDING TO LOCAL PROGRAMS -- THE
RESULT OF THE BILLS -- AUTHORED
BY.
THE THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
HERE LAST YEAR ASSEMBLY BILL.
FIVE FIFTY THAT WOULD HAVE
INCREASED THE BASELINE FUNDING
FOR THE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM RIGHT
NOW EACH LOCAL PROGRAM -- I'M
SORRY PRIOR TO TO THIS YEAR EACH
LOCAL PROGRAM RECEIVED A
BASELINE FUNDING OF THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT WAS JUST.
TO OPEN YOUR DOORS [inaudible]
THAT.
AMOUNT WAS ESTABLISHED IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR THROUGH --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAISES WORK AND
THIS COMMITTEE -- THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION SOUGHT FIT TO
INCREASE THAT BASELINE FROM
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
EACH PROGRAM.
THE REMAINING FEDERAL AND AND
STATE FUNDS THAT WE RECEIVE ARE
THEN ALLOCATED. TO EACH PROGRAM
BASED ON A FORMULA. 50% BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF FACILITIES 40%
BASED ON THE NUMBER OF BEDS IN
THAT SERVICE AREA AND THEN 10%
BASED ON THE SQUARE MILEAGE OF
THAT SERVICE AREA.
THAT'S HOW THE FUNDS ARE
ALLOCATED TO THE LOCAL PROGRAMS.
YOUR WE WELCOME MR MATHIS
[inaudible]
A SO.
UNLIKE DECO PRETTY MUCH
EVERYTHING THAT SORT OF AND SAID --
BUT MISTER WAS AN OLIVE GREEN
OTHERS DEFINITELY BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
ON THIS ALL THE WAY THROUGH IS
THERE SHOULD BE -- I TOO WOULD
LIKE TO HELP WITH THE TRAILER
LANGUAGE -- AND IF THERE'S
SOMETHING WE NEED TO DO WITH THE
FEDERAL SIDE TO GET THAT FORMULA
CHANGED -- I HAVE NO PROBLEM BY.
COMING ONTO AN AJ ARE WITH --
MAYBE MISTER WAS OR ALL OF US.
ON TO ASK THAT COULD CHANGE.
TO I CAN THINK OF CALIFORNIA
OKAY LIKE I CAN ALSO SPEAK TO
THAT THE THE THE ALLEN THE FUNNY
ALLOCATION IS IN.
THE WELL FOR INSTITUTIONS CODE
IN CALIFORNIA LAW BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION ON AGING IS
CONDUCTING A NEW EVALUATION OF
LONG TERM CARE BUTTON PROGRAM.
THAT WILL UPDATE THAT RATIO SO.
THAT IS IMMINENT.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT THAT IS AGAIN A FEDERAL
STANDARD.
THAT IS NOT BASED ON THE
CALIFORNIA MANDATES WHICH WE
DON'T WANT TO GET RID OF BECAUSE
WE BELIEVE THAT IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT.
RESIDENTS HAVE WITNESSING --
ACTIONS FOR ADVANCE HEALTH CARE
DIRECTIVE AND WE WE BELIEVE THAT
THE CURRENT SYSTEM OF THE
OMBUDSMAN BEING THAT AND
MICHELLE RECEIVER OF ELDER ABUSE
ALLEGATIONS THAT THAT SHOULD
CONTINUE THERE'S ONLY FOUR OTHER
STATES IN THE NATION THAT HAVE
THAT SO THIS FEDERAL STANDARD
ONE INCLUDE SOME.
SOME SIGNIFICANT WORKLOAD FOR US
IN A MANTHAT'S WHY MISSION.
AS THE MEMBERS HERE ALL
SUPPORTIVE THAT WE CAN DO AN AJ
ARE ASKING THE FEDERAL.
GOVERNMENT.
TO POSSIBLY CHANGE THEIR FORMULA
[inaudible]
FOR BUT CALIFORNIA.
GOOD LUCK TO US ON THAT QUESTION.
BOB YET MAYBE WILL PUT IT IN ON
MY NAME.
WE JUST MIGHT HAVE.
TO SO AT MY LAST QUESTION.
IF THE IF THE INVESTMENT IS MADE
TO AUGMENT THE LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM TO FUND THE
ABILITY FOR THE PROGRAM TO VISIT
ALL FACILITIES.
ON AT LEAST A QUARTERLY.
QUARTERLY BASIS.
THEN I THINK THE SUGGESTION IS
THAT WE HAVE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE -- TO CODIFY.
THIS PRACTICE.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
WE HAVE A REACTION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION.
MY MY ONLY CONCERN WITH WITH
CODIFYING THAT.
IS THAT -- SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE MINISTRY
ADMINISTRATION DECIDE TO AUGMENT
THIS PROGRAM WITH THIS REQUEST.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THINGS GET BAD
AGAIN AND WE LOSE MONEY?
IF WE HAVE THIS ON THE BOOKS
[inaudible]
WE'RE WE'RE WE'VE GOT A MANDATE
THAT WE CAN'T MEET.
THAT'S THAT'S MY ONLY CONCERN.
IT'S IT'S NOT IT'S IT'S AN
IMPORTANT STANDARD THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ON AGING WANTS US
TO STRIVE [inaudible]
FOR BUT THEY KNOW THAT THEIR
FUNDING.
AND THE FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVE
FROM CONGRESS.
ISN'T ALWAYS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THAT IN EVERY STATE.
I THINK PART OF THE PROBLEM
THOUGH IS THAT IF WE DON'T SET A
STANDARD AND THAT'S WHY I THE
FIRST PART OF MY SENTENCE WAS.
IF AN INVESTMENT IS MADE TO
AUGMENT IT.
DO THEN CODIFY IT BECAUSE IF.
WE AUGMENTED THE IF WE INCREASE
THE FUNDING.
AND WE DON'T CODIFY IT THEN I I
I'M NOT SAYING THIS IS WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN.
BUT CLEARLY.
THERE COULD BE THAT MONEY COULD
BE USED FOR SOMETHING ELSE.
WHERE IS IF WE CODIFY IT THEN WE
ARE SAYING THIS IS WHAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN THERE NEED TO BE
QUARTERLY -- VISITS.
ARE UNANNOUNCED VISITS AS HAVE
BEEN HAVE BEEN TESTIFIED TO
THERE HAVE TO BE QUARTERLY
VISITS WITH THEM ARE ABLE TO
PROTECT OUR SENIORS IN A BETTER
WAY THAN WE'RE ABLE TO NOW -- IF
THE CIRCUMSTANCES SHOULD CHANGE
THEN CERTAINLY THE LEGISLATURE
HAS THE ABSOLUTE POWER TO CHANGE
THE LANGUAGE ALSO OF WHAT IS
REQUIRED OF YOU.
IF IT'S AN UNFUNDED MANDATE
WE'RE TELLING YOU YOU'VE GOT TO
GO OVER A QUARTER AND YET WE
GIVE YOU ENOUGH TO JUST GO ONCE
A YEAR -- THE LEGISLATURE JUST
AS WE WOULD WANT TO WORK WITH
YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
WORK WITH YOU THEM.
WE CAN'T EXPECT YOU TO DO
SOMETHING YOU CANNOT.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE FUNDING.
FOR PLEASE WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY
SOMETHING -- I HAVE DONE A QUICK
POLL OF OUR MEMBERS.
AND THAT BY AND LARGE THE
MEMBERS ARE SUPPORTIVE OF BEING
GIVEN SOME GUIDELINES.
THAT CONCERNS ARE THAT IT NOT
HAPPEN ON JULY FIRST THAT YOU.
GIVE US FIVE POINT TWO MILLION
AND EXPECT BY THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THAT WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO MEET THAT.
ARE HIGHER BARK IT WILL TAKE US
A NUMBER OF YEARS TO GET FROM
SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX
VOLUNTEERS BACK UP. TO THE
THOUSAND OR MORE THAT WE NEED AS
WELL AS TRAINING STAFF THIS IS
NOT A JOB THAT YOU CAN WALK IN
ON MONDAY AND DO IT ON FRIDAY.
SO IF YOU GIVE US A FEW YEARS OF
TIME TO GO FROM OUR 60%
COMPLIANCE OP.
THE OTHER PART TO CONSIDER IS
THERE WAS ALWAYS GOING TO BE A
PERCENTAGE OF BLOCKS JUST A
SIMPLE EXAMPLE IF S. A FACILITY
IS NAMED ABC IN THE VERY FIRST
QUARTER OF THE YEAR.
AND THEN SOMETHING HAPPENS AND
THE CHANGE ON OUR SHIP AND ON
THE SECOND QUARTER OF THE YEAR.
THEY TURN INTO X. Y. Z. FACILITY.
THE OMBUDSMAN'S CURRENT
REPORTING STATUS WOULD SAY YOU
VISITED ABC IN THE FIRST QUARTER
BUT YOU DID NOT VISIT THEM IN
THE SECOND THIRD AND FOURTH
QUARTER.
THEY DIDN'T EXIST.
SO YOU WE GOT DETAINED FOR THAT
ONE ABC FACILITY AND THEN
BECAUSE YOU NOW HAVE THE X. Y.
Z. FACILITY THAT IS OPEN AND YOU
VISITED THEM SECOND THIRD AND
FOURTH QUARTER YOU WOULD STILL
BE DOING.
BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T GET TO THAT
FACILITY ALL FOUR QUARTERS WAR
YOU HAVE EXAMPLES OF FACILITIES
THAT WERE IN FIRES THOSE
FACILITIES BURNED DOWN THERE
WOULD BE NO POINT IN GOING TO
VISIT A FACILITY.
THAT HAS BEEN OPENED SO I WOULD
SAY IF YOU DON'T EXPECT A 100%
IF YOU SAID MAYBE 8085% WELL
RATHER THAN SAY PERCENTAGE.
I I THINK THAT IF YOU WERE TO IF.
THE OMBUDSMAN APPROACH.
PEOPLE WERE TO COME TO US AND
SAY.
THIS FACILITY BURNED DOWN SO WE
CAN'T IN -- VISIT.
RIGHT THE LANGUAGE WOULD
CERTAINLY BE PUT IN I WOULD THAT
HAPPEN WE HAVE TO WORK ON THE
LANGUAGE YES WE KNOW WHAT THE
CONCEPT IS WE KNOW WHAT IT IS WE
WANT TO ACCOMPLISH.
SO IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE MONEY
IN IS GOING TO REQUIRE THE
LANGUAGE TO CODIFY IT IS TO WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE SPENDING THE
MONEY ON YEAH.
WE ARE IS ALL WE WERE ABLE WE
JUST HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO GET THE MONEY.
AND THEN HOW WE'RE GOING -- TO
CODIFY THE THE THE REQUIREMENTS.
THAT WE WANT. FOR WHICH WE WANT
THAT MONEY TO BE SPENT.
BUT IT'S GOING TO TAKE EVERYBODY
WORKING TOGETHER ON THAT AND
WORKING SPECIFICALLY ON THE
LANGUAGE SO I DO APPRECIATE TO
THE THE MINISTRATIONS --
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US --
WE'RE ALL GOING TO DO THIS WE'RE
GOING TO DO THIS BECAUSE YOU TO
AS MY MOTHER SAY IT WILL ONE DAY
BE THAT SENIOR.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ALL.
LET'S BRING UP THE NEXT PANEL
.
THIS PANEL NUMBER FOUR IS --
GETTING SITUATED ON PANEL --
FIVE DOCTOR WOULD IS ALSO ONE OF
THE PANELISTS.
AND A MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE I
WOULD HOUSE THAT HE GIVE HIS
TESTIMONY NOW. TO PROVE IT JUST
IN CASE YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO
RETURN AND A TIMELY MANNER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR THIS IS THE PAN THIS
IS RELATED TO THE THE MULTI
PURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES PROGRAM --
AND AND SO DURING THIS FOR THIS
SO -- PROGRAM I'M REQUESTING A
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR A ONE
THàNH A ONE TIME TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ON A ONE TIME
ONLY BASIS TO BE SPENT OVER THE
NEXT THREE BUDGET YEARS. TO
RIGHT SIZE THE FUNDING FOR THE
THIRTY EIGHT NONPROFIT MULTI
PURPOSE SENIORS -- SERVICE
PROGRAMS.
M. S. P. P. SITES -- SERVE
ALMOST TWELVE THOUSAND FRAIL
OLDER ADULTS LIVING IN THEIR
HOMES MOSTLY ALONE BY PROVIDING
BOTH SOCIAL AND HEALTH CARE CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
WHO WISH TO REMAIN IN THEIR
HOMES.
AND THEIR AND COMMUNITIES.
SERVICES INCLUDE CASE MANAGEMENT
ADULT TO ADULT DAY SOCIAL CARE
HOUSING ASSISTANCE IN HOME CHORE
AND PERSONAL CARE SERVICES
RESPITE SERVICES TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES PROTECTIVE SERVICES
MEAL SERVICES.
AND SPECIAL COMMUNICATION
ASSISTANCE THE GOAL OF THE
PROGRAM ISSUES AVAILABLE
COMMUNITY RESOURCES AND AND
RESOURCES PREVENT OR DELAY
INSTITUTIONALIZATION OF THESE
FRAIL CLIENTS.
THE PROGRAM SEPARATE TO
SIGNIFICANT RATE DECREASES IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AND TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THERE HASN'T
BEEN AN AUGMENTATION FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS.
MORE THAN THIRTEEN YEARS.
THE CASA PROFESSIONAL STAFFING
OPERATIONS HAS INCREASED
CONSIDERABLY INCLUDING SALARIES
WORKERS COMP STAFF TRAINING AND
DEVELOPMENT RENT AND UTILITIES.
THEREFORE I THAT WRIST
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THE SMALL
INVESTMENT IN THE M. M. S. S. P.
PROGRAM.
OF BE MADE AVAILABLE TO CARE FOR
OUR STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE
SENIORS AND I KNOW IT IS AN
UNUSUAL REQUEST THAT THIS IS A
ONE TIME REQUEST OVER A THREE
YEAR PERIOD.
HOWEVER JUST TO YOU KNOW IF YOU
WERE TO SPLIT IT.
UP IN JUST A ONE TIME THING IT'S
JUST NOT GOING TO BE ENOUGH TO
HELP THIS PROGRAM ALONG ONCE
AGAIN THERE HASN'T BEEN AN
INCREASE IN THIRTEEN YEARS.
BOB THE GOAL HERE IS TO KEEP
PEOPLE OUT OF SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES FOR AS LONG AS
POSSIBLE WHICH SAVES EVERYBODY
RESOURCES.
AND IS A HUGE IMPROVEMENT IN
QUALITY OF LIFE SO I'VE AS AS
THE TIME COMES FOR THIS.
WE HEAR THIS ISSUE THAT'S THAT
IS THAT IS MY QUOTE REQUEST.
THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING THAT IT
WAS IMPORANT THAT WE HEAR FROM
YOU.
ALL RIGHT ON PANEL.
ON THE ISSUE.
ON ISSUE.
FOR WHEN WE GET TO MY NOTES
PLEASE.
SING YOUR NUTRITION ADVOCACY
PROPOSAL.
VERY GOOD AND I WOULD LIKETO
WELCOME OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KANSEN CHU -- THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE WITH US TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY AND I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN WITH YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR TâM AM A
MEMBERS IN FOR TOM ALL OF THANK
YOU AND THE STAFF -- FOR
ACCOMMODATING MY REQUEST TO
PRESENT TODAY -- AS A MEMBER AND
AS TO THE SENIOR CITIZEN.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON A NUMBER.
FOUR AN ON ON YOUR AGENDA AND
LOW BUT MORE.
I'M A DOES NUMBER FOUR IS ASKING
FOR SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT SENIOR
NUTRITION PROGRAM.
ADD THIS NEW FUNDING WILL
PROVIDE AN EXTRA ONE POINT TWO
MILLION MEALS PER YEAR AND HELP
AND ADDITIONAL TWELVE THOUSAND
SENIORS IN CALIFORNIA.
SINCE THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
RECESSION SENIOR SERVICES
PROGRAM HAS BEEN SLASH.
AND WE'D NEVER RECOVERED --
PROGRAM LIKE MEALS ON WHEELS
THAT OFFER HEALTHY FOOD FOR OUR
AGING POPULATION IS SUFFERING
AND IF WE DO NOTHING.
WELL WHAT HAVE SENIOR GOING
HUNGRY. 54% OF THE SENIOR LIVING
IN CALIFORNIA ARE LIVING BUT
LOOK BELOW THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL.
THIS NUMBER IS NOT GOING TO GET
LOWER -- GET BATTERED AND
FUNDING NEEDS TO BE ADJUSTED TO
ME THIS DOES OF URGING NEEDS.
WE ALL SEE FOOD AS A BASIC.
A DAILY NEED FOR THOSE SENIORS
IT COULD ALSO MEAN THE ONLY TIME
OFF TO DATE OF THEIR DAY.
DAD DO YOU GET TO INTERACT WITH
ANYONE ANYONE ELSE -- THEY COULD
MEAN THAT IS STILL ONLY HEALTHY
MEAL FOR THE DAY.
HELLO WITH A FUNDING FOR
NUTRITION PROGRAM.
I WOULD LOVE TO MAKE SURE A TO
MAKE SURE TRANSPORTATION IS ALSO
SUPPORTED.
MANY OF THOSE SENIOR A LIVE
ALONG WITH ALL SUPPORT AND
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES.
ARE IMPORTANT TO KEEP THEM FROM
OF ISOLATION AND CONNECT THEM TO
AVAILABILITY PROGRAMS AVAILABLE
PROGRAMS -- OWN INCLUDING MALES
AND ACTIVITIES.
IN ADDITION TO THIS AGENDA I
TURNED I'M ALSO HERE. TO
ADVOCATE FOR A CONTINUES TO
APPROPRIATION OF TWENTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
ROAD TO THE FOR THE SENIOR VERY
VERY REAL SYSTEM SENIOR SUPPORT
PROGRAMS ON I DEFINITELY AGREE
YOU AGREE WITH YOU THAT.
OF OF WOULD LOVE TO SEE OF A
LONG TERM PLAN IN PLACE.
IN AND PUT SOME STANDARD ON ON
THE SENIOR SERVICES BUT IN A AND
ENFOLDED NEXT BUDGETING BUDGET
YEAR -- THE LOVE TO ASK FOR
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
TO HELP LOW INCOME SENIORS IN
THE SENIOR EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM.
A PLUS THIRTEEN POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS TO GO TOWARDS
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES SUCH AS THE
ADULT ADULT DAYCARE CARE GIVER
SUPPORT.
AND SEE SENIOR CENTER ACTIVITIES.
AND ALSO W. ADVOCATE FOR THAT
FOR FIVE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR US OF THOSE DID TO
SUPPORT THOSE WHO LIVING IN LONG
TERM CARE FACILITY.
PLUS FOUR POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS TO SERVE TO MEDICARE.
ELIGIBLE SENIORS AND WITH ME
TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS REQUEST OUR WENDY.
WENDY PETERSON AND THUGS OKAY HE
WELL THE REALLY.
QUICKLY A AND K. WANNA.
HE WON WHATEVER YOUR DOOR.
AND OF ACTIVE SO -- HIS TO IF IF
IT'S OKAY CAM AMID DENTURE COME
WE ASK -- GIVE GIVE A FEW
MINUTES -- TO WENDY AND COOLEY.
SITTING IN THE BACK [inaudible]
ALREADY HERE -- OKAY WHEN YOU
WERE YOU OVER.
WELL.
BECAUSE WE HAVE SO MANY OTHERS
ON THE PANEL IF I MAY ASK THAT.
CAN YOU BE SUCCINCT IN YOUR
COMMENTS AND PERHAPS TWO TO
THREE MINUTES [inaudible]
OLA.
I'LL TRY I'LL TRY TO BE SUCCINCT
FROM I THINK WHAT WOULD HELP IS
IF THE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR BY
THE WAY -- AND FAMILY MEMBERS IF
YOU HAVE A COPY OF THE BUDGET
REQUEST.
DETAIL THAT ALSO HAS A CHART ON
THE LAST PAGE I THINK THAT WOULD
HELP ME TO BE SUCCINCT BECAUSE I
COULD POINT YOU IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION -- SO I THINK THAT.
HAPPENED.
WE MAY HAVE THESE ALREADY WHAT
DO.
LOOKS LIKE THAT.
SENIOR SERVICES COALITION HE A
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OKAY I'M I'M WENDY PETERSON -- I
DIRECTOR THINNER SERVICES
COALITION OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
WHERE COALITION OF FORTY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE.
HEALTH IN SUPPORT OF SERVICES --
FOR SENIORS IN OUR COUNTY WHERE
ONE OF MANY OF REGIONALES BRING
THE MICROPHONE CLOSER TO YOU.
WE'RE ONE OF MANY REGIONAL
COALITIONS ACROSS THE STATE --
OF ORGANIZATIONS THAT LIKE BOYS
PROVIDE SERVICES ACROSS THE
STATE ARE.
I FIRST WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS --
OUR GRATITUDE TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU -- AND HIS ABLE AND
GENEROUS STAFF FOR REALLY HAVING
THE BIG PICTURE THINKING. TO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
BRINGING FORWARD A REQUEST.
DOT COM IS COMPREHENSIVE AND
WOULD REALLY -- IMPACT IN A
SYSTEMS CHANGE WAY ARM THIS
PROPOSAL.
OF A FAMILY MEMBER CHOOSE --
REQUEST FOR A TOTAL OF FORTY
FIVE POINT NINE TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL GENERAL
FUNDING. FOR THIS YEAR -- IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING -- TO
SUPPORT TO BUILD LOCAL IF
INSTANCE CAPACITY WITH STEPPED
IN INCREASES IN TWO SUBSEQUENT
YEARS AROUND THOSE ARE WOULD
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT.
THE ADDITIONAL DOLLARS -- THAT
THE EMPHASIS P..
ASSOCIATION IS IS SEEN NEEDED IN
YOUR TO IN YOUR THREE ARM.
FIFTH LONG OVERDUE FUNDING
REQUEST IS UP IT'S REALLY IT'S
AN INVESTMENT IN A CONTINUUM I
THINK ONE OF THE PUBLIC SPEAKERS.
ARE MENTIONED THAT AGING IS A
CONTINUUM.
ARM AND THE SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
TO SENIORS THE THE THE THING THE
SERVICES THAT NEED TO BE OUT
THERE IN THE COMPOUND IN THE
COMMUNITY NEED TO BE A CONTINUUM
AS WELL -- SO THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO SERVE THOSE IN ACUTE CARE
FACILITIES.
ARMS THOSE WHO ARE -- A NURSING
HOME LEVEL BUT STILL WANT TO
LIVE IN THEIR HOMES.
THOSE WHO.
REALLY NEED PREVENTION SERVICES
THEY NEED NAVIGATION -- WE WE
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO MOVE UPSTREAM --
THIS REQUEST INCORPORATES.
ALL OF THE BUDGET REQUEST FOR
OMBUDSMAN AND A FIFTY AND SENIOR
NUTRITION THAT CLAY IS ABOUT TO
SPEAK ON END I AM.
YOU ARE YOU'VE HEARD -- FROM
OTHERS SPEAKERS ABOUT OF THE
STATE'S GENERAL FUND INVESTMENT.
REALLY BEING A DISINVESTMENT
THAT THE GENERAL FUNDING IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING TODAY IS.
IS ESSENTIALLY HALF WHAT IT WAS
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT IF YOU
ADJUST FOR INFLATION.
BOMB FOUND OUR REQUEST TAKES
THAT INTO ACCOUNT.
I I THINK THAT THE IMPACT OF OF
THIS CHRONIC DOES DISINVESTMENT
HAS REALLY BEEN FELT LOCALLY AND
YOU'VE BEEN HEARING FROM
SPEAKERS TODAY ABOUT.
THE IMPACT THE LOCAL IMPACT AND
I HOPE THAT YOU CAN CONSIDER OUR
REQUEST.
AS A REQUEST FROM THE FIELD --
OUR LOCAL PROVIDERS EVERY DAY WE
SEE THE REALITY OF OLDER ADULTS
GRAPPLING WITH ECONOMIC AND
SECURITY WITH ISOLATION WITH
HOUSING AND FOOD AND SECURITY.
WITH HEALTH AND MOBILITY
CHALLENGES -- AND THE TASK OF
NAVIGATING COMPLEX SYSTEMS AND
WE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL ARE
EXPERIENCING AN URGENT NEED. TO
INVEST IN ALL OF THESE PROGRAMS
WE CAN'T DO IT PIECEMEAL THE
CONTINUUM NEEDS TO BE FUNDED --
THIS IS A MODEST INVESTMENT.
AROUND IT RESTORES FUNDING TO
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT LEVELS WITH
ADJUSTMENTS FOR INFLATION.
I I URGE YOU.
TO NOT TO WAIT FOR STUDY I URGE
YOU NOT TO WAIT FOR THE MASTER
PLAN WE NEED THIS BASIC
INFRASTRUCTURE OF SERVICES.
IF WE'RE GOING TO BUILD INTO
ANYTHING THAT'S BETTER.
THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO NOW CALL
ON CLAY CAMP EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
SANTA CRUZ SAN BENITO AREA
AGENCY ON AGING AND THANKS ICE I
SHOULD ALSO MENTION I'M
LEGISLATIVE CO CHAIR.
FOR CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
AREA AGENCIES ON AGING SOME
BRING A COUPLE HATS -- FIRST OF
ALL I JUST WANT TO REALLY THANK
ASSEMBLYMAN CHIU AND WINDY
PETERSON FOR THEIR PROPOSAL
[inaudible]
IT'S A IT SHOULD BE THE STARTING
POINT THIS SHOULD BE THE MINIMUM
THAT WE DO AND THIS IS HOW WE
FIX WHAT IS LITERALLY A BROKEN
SYSTEM.
SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE WE START
BY FIXING WHAT WAS BROKEN TEN
YEARS AGO.
BY PUTTING BACKING AND WHAT WORK
BEFORE.
AND AFTER THAT THEN LET'S TALK
ABOUT THE MASTER PLAN ON AGING
SO WE CAN FIGURE OUT HOW TO DEAL
WITH THE GROWTH.
IN THE POPULATION AND FIGURE OUT
BETTER WAYS TO DO THINGS BUT I
THINK THIS IS THE STARTING POINT.
REGARDING THE NUTRITION ASK
SPECIFICALLY.
THERE'S NO STANDARD ABOUT HOW
MANY SENIORS CAN GO HUNGRY.
THERE'S NO PERCENTAGE --
CALCULATION ABOUT WHAT'S
ACCEPTABLE THERE'S NO
CALCULATION ABOUT HOW MANY
SENIOR SHOULD BE EATING DOG FOOD
IN OUR COMMUNITY AND WE KNOW
THAT IS HAPPENING.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT DROVE THE
CREATION OF OLDER AMERICANS ACT
IT WENT AWAY FOR AWHILE BUT NOW
WITH THE STAGNATION OF FUNDING
OR THE LOSS OF FUNDING.
THE D. INVESTMENTS.
THAT'S BECOME A REALITY AGAIN
AND WE'RE HEARING DIRECT STORIES
IN OUR COMMUNITY ABOUT THAT
HAPPENING.
IT'S REALLY NOT OK.
WE ALSO KNOW THERE IS ONE POINT
TWO MILLION.
SENIORS THAT ARE FOOD INSECURE.
RIGHT NOW OUR MEAL PROGRAMS ARE
FEEDING ABOUT A QUARTER OF A
MILLION SENIORS PER YEAR
[inaudible]
SO.
MY LACK OF ACTION AND BY NOT
FUNDING THESE PROGRAMS WERE
BASICALLY SAYING THAT THE
STANDARD IS.
THAT IT'S OKAY THAT 80% OF OUR
AT RISK SENIORS GO HUNGRY.
OR THE EAT POOR MEALS.
AND THAT'S REALLY TO ME YOU KNOW
I LOVE MY STATES BUT THAT'S AN
EMBARRASSMENT THAT WERE SAYING
THAT FOUR OUT OF FIVE SENIORS IN
ME FACING HUNGER FACING THE
CHOICE BETWEEN A MEAL.
AND THEIR MEDICATION OR OTHER
ESSENTIAL.
MY SUSTAINING ACTIVITIES THAT
THEY HAVE TO GO WITHOUT FOOD.
PROGRAMS I MENTIONED EARLIER
HAVE SURVIVED BY.
CREATIVE APPROACHES TO KEEPING
THEIR PROGRAMS OPEN.
BY NOT PAYING STAFF WAGE
INCREASES FOR A DECADE.
AND WHAT WE DO WITH THAT IS WE
CREATE A POVERTY REALITY FOR
EVERYBODY PROVIDING THESE TYPES
OF SERVICES IF YOU WANT TO DO
GOOD IN YOUR COMMUNITY AND SERVE
SENIORS.
AND YOU'RE A STAFFER.
YOU HAVE TO DECIDE THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO TAKE A VOW OF POVERTY
YOURSELF AND END UP MEETING THE
SAME SERVICES THAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO HELP THE COMMUNITY.
RECEIVING HALF.
AND THAT'S NOT OKAY.
AND I THINK ALL OF US AND I
APPRECIATE THIS COMMITTEE HAVING
PASSING AROUND THESE ISSUES.
AND IT'S IT'S REFRESHING TO SEE
THAT THERE'S PASSION HERE ABOUT
DOING SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
WE ALSO HAVE FEWER PROVIDERS
THAT WE CAN FIND TO GET SERVICES
FROM MANY OF OUR CONTRACT TO
PROVIDERS ARE JUST BREAKING
CONTRACTS OR SAYING NO MORE
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT CONTINUE TO
MEET THE NEED.
ON THE POOR REIMBURSEMENT RATE
THE TRIPLE A.'S OR OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES ARE PROVIDING.
AND I THINK WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT WHAT REALLY HAPPENS NOT
ONLY WHEN SOMEBODY DOESN'T GET A
MEAL I THINK THAT PART IS EASY
TO GRASP.
WE HAVE DATA AND AND A LOT OF
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW.
POOR NUTRITION LEADS TO
INCREASED HEALTH COSTS INCREASED
INSTITUTIONALIZATION INCREASE
STROKES INCREASED HEART ATTACKS
NONE OF WHICH IS OKAY.
BUT THE CUTS PROGRAMS ARE BEING
FACED TO MATE.
OUR DRASTIC AND I DON'T THINK WE
HEAR ABOUT THOSE IN EARLIER I
MENTIONED THE ISSUE OF ONE
STRATEGY IS RATHER THAN VISITING
AT SENIOR EVERY DAY WITH THE
HOME DELIVERED MEALS.
A LOT OF PROGRAMS ARE UNDER
PRESSURE TO DELIVER FROZEN MEALS
BE THERE ONCE A WEEK OR OR
WHATEVER AND ONE OF OUR LOCAL
PROGRAMS IS FACING THAT RIGHT
NOW.
THERE ARE DISCUSSION SHOULD THEY
START PROVIDING FROZEN MEALS AND
VISIT ONCE A WEEK OR NOT.
AND THIS LAST YEAR DURING ONE OF
THEIR HOME VISITS AND DELIVERIES
THEY FOUND A CLIENT LYING ON THE
FLOOR IN HER OWN WAY STE WHO'D
BEEN THERE SINCE ABOUT TEN
O'CLOCK THE NIGHT BEFORE.
SHE HAD FALLEN COULDN'T GET UP.
AND LUCKILY WAS RESCUED BY HER
DRIVER WHO SAW THIS AND CALLED
AUTHORITIES AND SHE WAS ABLE TO
BE TAKEN TO A HOSPITAL IN
REHYDRATED IN AND BASICALLY
RECOVERED AND CONTINUES.
TO LIVE AT HOME TODAY.
NOW IF THIS PROVIDER HAS TO CUT
CORNERS ONE MORE TIME AND ONLY
DELIVER MEALS ONCE A WEEK THAT
PERSON WOULD BE DEAD.
IN AND THAT'S THE REALITY IN THE
CHOICE THEY WERE PUTTING OUR
PROVIDERS IN.
THE EITHER HAVE TO KNOW THAT A
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF THOSE THEY
SERVE WILL DIE.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO STOP MAKING
DAILY DELIVERIES OR A LARGER
PERCENTAGE OF THE PEOPLE IN NEED
IN THEIR COMMUNITY WILL GO
HUNGRY.
AND THEY'LL DIE ALSO BUT IT
WOULD BE A SLOWER LONGER DEATH
THAT THEY'LL BE LIVING AN
EXTENDED PERIOD.
OF OCT IN AN INSTITUTION OR WITH
OTHER HELP.
SO JUST TO WRAP OP YOU KNOW
ECONOMICALLY.
THESE ARE GOOD TIMES.
I'M STAFF IS MENTIONED IN HERE
THIS IS A REQUEST THAT'S BEEN
HERE FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS IN A
ROW I FORGET IF THIS IS YOUR
THREE OR YOUR FOR BUT IT'S CAN
BE IT'S COME HERE MANY TIMES.
IT'S NEVER BEEN FUNDED.
PERSONALLY I DON'T THINK THERE'S
MUCH MORE BASIC SERVICES BEEN
FEEDING PEOPLE ESPECIALLY THINGS
LIKE MEALS ON WHEELS WE ALL KNOW
HOW EFFECTIVE THAT IS YET IN
GOOD ECONOMIC TIMES.
WE'RE NOT FUNDING THIS PROGRAM.
IF WE'RE NOT FINDING IN NOW WHEN
ARE YOU GOING.
TO AND WE KNOW.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T WANT TO OVER
EXTEND OUR RESOURCES BECAUSE WE
KNOW AT SOME POINT THE ECONOMY
WILL TAKE A TURN FOR THE WORSE.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW WHEN THAT
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN HAPPENS WE'RE
PROBABLY GONNA CUT THESE
PROGRAMS AGAIN.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS EVERY CYCLE
AGING PROGRAMS GET CUT AND
REDUCED SO DURING THE GOOD
ECONOMIC TIMES IF WE CAN'T DO
SOMETHING TO ADDRESS THIS I MET
ME NOW.
WHEN ARE WE EVER GOING TO DO IT?
AND FOR NEVER GOING TO DO IT.
SHAME ON ALL OF US AND I I'M NOT
TWENTY TO ALL OF YOU BUT I THINK
EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM IF WE
CANNOT PROVIDE THESE CRITICAL
SERVICES.
WHERE FAILING AS A STATE MORALLY
FISCALLY AND REALLY PROBABLY
EVER EVERY MEASURE OF WHAT A
QUALITY LIFE IS FOR OUR
RESIDENTS OURSELVES AND OUR
RELATIVES?
SO HOPEFULLY THIS REQUEST --
WILL GAIN SUPPORT THIS TIME
AROUND AND WE WILL -- BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THIS THIS KEY AND BASIC
ISSUE AND HE THANKS [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- DIRECTOR
[inaudible]
MOTOR.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
COMMENTS WERE VERY HAPPY TO WORK
WITH [inaudible]
YOUR STAFF.
IN THE TROUBLING AT WORK TO
REVIEW THE PROPOSAL AND PROVIDE
CAPITALIST.
YEAH AND IT IS CONSISTENT WITH
OUR STATE PLAN ON AGING.
OF THE GOAL WE HAVE A GOOD GOAL.
SAYING THAT WE WISH TO PROVIDE
OLDER CALIFORNIANS PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEIR
CAREGIVERS.
WITH THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO
SUPPORT THEIR HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF ONE OF THE OBJECTIVES
SENATOR THAT GOAL.
IS TO SUPPORT OLDER ADULTS
INCREASING THEIR ACCESS TO
NUTRITIOUS FOOD.
OKAY I I WON'T COMMENT ON IT YET
UNTIL WE FINISH WITH THE REST OF
THE SPEAKERS THEM -- LOUISE
BOURGEOIS.
YES -- DEMONSTRATION NOT TAKING
A POSITION AT THIS TIME I ALSO
HAVEN'T SEEN THIS MORE
COMPREHENSIVE PROPOSALS WOULD BE
GREAT TO GET MORE INFORMATION
AND TO THE LEGISLATURE WISH TO
PURSUE PRIORITIZE PROPOSAL WE
CAN WE'RE COLLABORATIVE WITH
YOUR STAFF TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE [inaudible]
HELLO.
I'M WE WOULD ALSO OFFER ANY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT
MEMBERS AND STAFF WOULD REQUIRE
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
MS RUBIO THANK YOU -- THANK YOU
FOR FOR THE ASKING I KNOW IT'S A
IT'S HEARTBREAKING FOR ME AS
WELL TO SEE THAT THAT YOU WE
HAVE TO KEEP COMING BACK AND
COMING BACK AND I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE AT SOME POINT FOR US TO FIND
AS WE DID SOME WORK.
A COUPLE YEAR ACTUALLY TWO YEARS
AGO -- FOR A SITCOM SIMILAR
PROGRAM IT'S CALLED ANGEL FOOD
PROJECT AND IT'S A PILOT PROGRAM
THAT.
IS HAPPENING IN OF MULTIPLE
COUNTIES BUT THE ONE ANGEL FOOD
PROJECT IS SPECIFICALLY AND LA
COUNTY.
AND I VISITED AND I'VE ACTUALLY
DELIVERED FOOD FOR THEM BUT SO
THAT THE I PROMISE OF THE
PROGRAM IS THE FOLLOWING --
CONGESTIVE HEART FAILURE.
OF FOLKS.
THAT ARE RECEIVING NUTRITIOUS
MEALS AND OF DIE.
THE I. WHAT IS IT CALLED THAT
APPROPRIATE UP MEALS FOR
WHATEVER AILMENT THEY HAVE BEEN
SOLD IT'S A THE PILOT PROGRAM
RIGHT NOW AND SO WERE WERE
FOLLOWING FOLKS THAT -- ARE YOU
RECEIVING THE MEALS AND OTHER
FOLKS THAT ARE NOT AND WE'RE
TRYING.
TO MAKE THAT CORRELATION ABOUT
HOW MUCH MONEY WE SAVE UP BY
FEEDING THESE FOLKS AND MY LONG
TERM GOAL AND YOU KNOW THIS IS A
PIE IN THE SKY TYPE OF GOAL IS
THAT.
YOU KNOW AT SOME POINT --
NUTRITION IS MEDICATION SO THAT
DOCTORS ARE ABLE TO PRESCRIBE
NUTRITIOUS FOOD.
AS PART OF A A RECOVERY --
PROGRAM AND I THINK.
IF WE THOUGHT ABOUT FOOD AS
MEDICATION THEN WE WOULDN'T HAVE
THESE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE NOW
AND HOPEFULLY.
AGAIN PLAN THIS GUY A TYPE OF
THINKING BUT IF DOCTORS WERE
ABLE TO PRESCRIBE AND WE WOULD
SPEND THE MONEY ON FOOD THAT WE
DO ONE MEDICATION I THINK THEY
WOULD BE YOU KNOW SOMETHING THAT
WE COULD -- ALL GET AROUND -- OR
SUPPORT -- I THINK WE ALL SEE
THAT WE SUPPORTED BUT IF WE
DON'T SEE ANY DATA -- TO WE HAVE
THE DATA BUT IF WE DON'T LOOK AT
IT LIKE OUR BUDGET FOLKS LOOK AT
IT AS A LINE ITEM ISSUE AS
OPPOSED TO A YOU KNOW FEEL GOOD
ISSUE.
BOB WE'RE NOT GOING TO EVER --
CONTINUE THE FUNDING WITHOUT
HAVING TO CUT IT AND YOU KNOW
AND THE DON DOWNTURN.
ECONOMIC TIMES BUT ANYWAY SO I
DID SOME FOOD DELIVERY AND JUST
TO SEE THE REACTION FROM THE
FOLKS THAT ARE BEING -- VISITED.
YOU KNOW ONE COMPONENT IS THE
FOOD BUT THE ACTUAL HUMAN
CONTACT.
ESPECIALLY FOR THE THE ELDERLY
POPULATION IS JUST AS CRITICAL
AS THE NUTRITION THAT THE
RECEIVING AND SAW IT.
I KNOW I'M SPEAKING TO THE CHOIR
BUT THE THESE PROGRAMS ARE
CRITICAL BUT I THINK IN THE LONG
TERM.
A YOU KNOW BUDGETARY -- LOOK IS
THERE GOING TO SAVE US MONEY BY
PROVIDING -- THESE PROGRAMS AND
THE AND THE FOOD TO TO THE
ELDERLY BECAUSE IF NOT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE FOLKS THAT ARE
FALLING OR NOT BEING RESCUED
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO BUY A HOUSE
THEM AND THEN -- RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES ARE GOING TO
COST MUCH MORE SO I HOPE BUT
THAT THAT AT SOME POINT WE GET
TO THE POINT WHERE WE'RE LOOKING
AT THESE AS PREVENTION.
OF PREVENTATIVE OF MEASURES SO
THAT WEEK IF WE LOOK AT IT IS
THAT BUDGETARY ISSUE WE'RE
SAVING MONEY IN THE LONG RUN.
AND SO I HOPE THAT WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO TRY AND MAKE THESE.
ONGOING FUNDING NOD ONE TIME AND
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO KEEP
COMING BACK EVERY SINGLE TIME
BECAUSE FOR US IF WE LOOK AT
LINE ITEMS.
IT'S ONE THING BUT IF WE LOOK AT
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE BEING
AFFECTED.
WHEN WE DO THESE BUDGET CUTS
IT'S IT'S IT'S HUMBLING YOU'RE
RIGHT ALL OF US ARE GOING TO BE
THERE ONE DAY?
AND THE SILVER TSUNAMI THAT WE
ARE ALL PART OF WAITING FOR IS I
THINK IT'S HERE.
I THINK IT'S HERE AND KEEP WE
KEEP REFERRING TO IT AS IT'S
GOING TO COME IN THE FUTURE IT'S
ALREADY HERE.
AND SOUL YES TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IS NEEDED BUT I THINK
IT'S WE NEED MUCH MORE THAN THAT
WE NEED SOME FORWARD THINKING
ABOUT HOW WE CAN MAKE THESE
MEASURES -- A A MEDICARE A A
PRESCRIPTION.
OR SOME TYPE OF OF OF PROGRAM
THAT IS PAID FOR ALREADY WITHOUT
HAVING TO DO A SEPARATE BUDGET
ASK SOUL SO YES THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANT IS NEEDED BUT MUCH
MORE THAN THAT HOW CAN WE MAKE
THIS PART OF A I DON'T KNOW MEDI
CAL.
OF PRESCRIPTION METHOD OR IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN JUST ALL.
YEAH THE HELP ME HELP US DO THIS
BECAUSE IF I THIS IS MY THIRD
YEAR ON THIS COMMITTEE AND JUST
TO TO HEAR THE TRAGIC STORIES.
ABOUT WHAT YOU ALL SEE OUT THERE
IS HEART BREAKING AND AT SOME
POINT.
WE CAN YOU KNOW JUST ALLOW
PEOPLE TO LIVE -- LIKE THE LIKE
THIS WITHOUT EATING DOG FOOD OR
NOT EATING AT ALL SO ANYWAY IT'S
KIND OF MORE OF A COMMENT THAN A
QUESTION BUT THE OR IT IS A
QUESTION HOW CAN YOU HELP US.
MAKE THIS A PRIORITY OR A
PREVENTATIVE PREVENTATIVE
MEASURES SO THAT YOU DON'T HAVE
TO KEEP COMING BACK -- AND
ASKING FOR THIS MONEY AND SO IF
WE CAN ALL PUT OUR YOU KNOW
THINKING HATS AND YOU KNOW
BUDGETARY HATS TOGETHER -- YOU
KNOW THEY HAVE AN EAR WITH THE
GOVERNOR TO MAKE THAT AN ISSUE
THAT IS PART OF THIS ONGOING --
PREVENTION.
OF METHODS THAT WE ARE ALL
LOOKING FOR TO HELP THE SENIOR
POPULATION BUT I THINK YOU KNOW
ALL OF THE POPULATIONS OF WE CAN
GET.
FOOD AS A PRESCRIPTION I THINK
THAT WOULD HELP NOT JUST THE
ELDERLY POPULATION BUT ALL OF
OUR POPULATIONS AND I WON'T GET
INTO THE WHOLE DIABETES ISSUE
BUT THAT WOULD BE FOR ANOTHER
CONVERSATION BUT I THINK IF WE
THOUGHT OF FOOD AS AS PREVENTION
AND HIS MEDICATION AND THAT.
WE WE WOULD BE ALL HAPPY TO
SUPPORT.
EVERYBODY CELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO IT THAT
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE'RE DOING.
AND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS WE'RE
THINKING OUTSIDE OF THE BOX
BECAUSE WE KNOW WE HAVE TO FIND
A SOLUTION.
ALASKA NOW ALLOWS DOCTORS TO
PRESCRIBE HOUSING.
SO IF HOUSING IF THE DOCTOR
COULD BRING OUT HIS HIS --
PRESCRIPTION PAD AND SAY THIS
PERSON NEEDS HOUSING THAN
ABSOLUTELY THE EVEN TO A GREATER
DEGREE THEY NEED TO HAVE FOOD
THEY NEED TO TUITION.
SO THINKING OUTSIDE OF THE BOX
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND THIS
IS WHAT WE HAVE.
TO THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE TO DO I
KNOW YOU HAD SOMETHING YOU
WANTED TO SAY I DO BECAUSE I I
TOTALLY AGREE WITH WHAT BOTH OF
YOU ARE SAYING AND JUST ONE
SUGGESTED AROUND THAT IS TO LOOK
AT ELEVEN FIFTEEN WAIVERS WHICH
WOULD ALLOW.
MEDICAID DOLLARS TO BE USED FOR
NON MEDICAL.
CARE AND THAT WOULD BRING IN
FEDERAL DOLLARS TO IT WOULDN'T
BE STATE FUNDING SO IF WE COULD
LOOK AT THAT AND OUR NEXT WAIVER
PROCESS WHICH IS ABOUT A YEAR
FROM NOW.
THAT COULD BE A REAL CREATIVE
SOLUTION THAT HELPS ALL OF US
AND YOU KNOW TO ME FOOD AND
HOUSING YOU BOTH SAID IT THOSE
ARE SO CRITICAL HELP.
THAT WOULD FIT IN AND ON BOTH
SIDES WE CAN GET SOME DATA THAT
SUPPORTS THE COST BENEFIT OF
DOING THAT SO I'D LOVE TO WORK
WITH.
THE COMMITTEE EITHER ONE OF YOU
ON ON IN THE INVEST.
INVESTIGATING THAT A LITTLE BIT.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS.
I WOULD SAY ALL THREE OF US SAY
THAT -- YEAH YOU WERE BEHIND.
IT'S THE YOU KNOW WAS REMARKABLE
IS THE ABILITY IN THIS PROGRAM
TO KEEP THE COST OF SELL LOW
[inaudible]
ALREADY ALEX.
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR THE ABILITY
TO DO THAT BECAUSE I'M I MEAN
I'M SAID HERE AND I'M GOING.
IN A WALMART DELIVERS AT HOME
NOW UBER EATS ALL THESE OTHER
THINGS AND AND AND I'M GOING
OKAY.
IN TODAY'S DAY AND AGE YOU KNOW
YOU GET YOU GET CLICK A BUTTON
ON A TABLET FOOD SHOWS A BIGGER
TOWARD IT'S IT'S CRAZY BUT THE
IT BLOWS MY MIND I IN I A SAID
ON AS VICE CHAIRMAN OF THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE.
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOW
WE'RE ON THE VERGE OF BECOMING
THE FOURTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD NOW [inaudible]
IT YEAH.
I'M SITTING HERE GOING.
HOW THE HELL?
WE BRAG ABOUT BEING THE LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD BECAUSE IT
BECAUSE WE HEAR THAT ALL BUT HI.
AND WE HEAR ABOUT A TWENTY ONE
BILLION DOLLARS SURPLUS.
AND WE'RE STARVING OUR SENIORS.
IT'S A SHAME.
AND I KNOW LAST YEAR IN AND
MEMBER RUBIO AND I SAT ON THIS
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR.
AND WE PUSHED THE SAME ISSUE AND
THE FUNDING.
AND TO HAVE A JOB LOST WITH THE
MINIMUM WAGE INCREASES AND ALL
THESE OTHER MARKET MEASURES THAT
THE DRIVE UP THE COST OF FOOD
AND PRODUCTION EVERYTHING ELSE
ON US. TO WE WE HAD ALL THIS SET.
THE ASSEMBLY THE ASSEMBLY ALL
THE LEGISLATORS AGREED AND IT
GOT IN INTO THE THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS WERE OR GET TO
WHAT THEY CALL THE THREE WAY
DEAL WHERE WE'RE NOW THE SENATE
THE ASSEMBLY ARE.
DEBATING WITH THE GOVERNOR.
AND WE LOST.
SO WE HAVE A NEW GOVERNOR NOW.
SO HOPEFULLY HE'LL Là.
BE WILLING TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES MORE AND OBVIOUSLY I KNOW
THE THE DIRECTOR KNOWS AS WELL
THESE ISSUES ARE BEING LOOKED A
LOT BETTER -- SO I THINK WE HAVE --
A LOT BETTER CHANCES THIS YEAR.
ON MODE AFFORD AND I KNOW --
MEMBER RUBIO IS WORKING ON HER
BILL WHICH HE LOT OF BROTHER NOW
AND SHARE YOUR IDEAS GIRL.
BUT WE WE CAN DO THESE THINGS.
AND WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
THESE THINGS -- THAT IN YOUR
SUGGESTED OF LOOKING AT OTHER
WAYS WHEN WE COME UP IN A YEAR
FROM NOW ON THOSE ISSUES IS
REALLY GOOD AS WELL [inaudible]
I'M JUST.
SERIOUSLY AND I'M ON THE VERGE
OF THE FOURTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD.
AND IN WE'RE LISTENING. TWO
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT OUR SENIORS
EATING [inaudible]
DOG FOOD.
NOT OKAY WITH THAT.
THAT'S SOMETHING WE'VE GOT A
FICTION AND GAVIN HOPEFULLY
YOU'RE LISTENING OR YOUR PEOPLE
ARE PAYING ATTENTION.
YOU KNOW I I THOUGHT THAT
GOVERNMENT ONLY DOG FOOD SHE
NEEDS REAL FOOD SO LET'S GET
THIS FIXED.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK FINANCE --
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW WE
BUILD A CREDIBLE ESTIMATE?
ON SENIOR NUTRITION.
WELL I HAVE TO DEFER DEPARTMENT
ON WHAT DATA WE HAVE TO BUILD AN
<c.blue>STIMATE I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH</c>
ANY SPECIFIC NUTRITION ESTIMATE --
I CAN WORK FOR EXAMPLE WITH THE
DEMOGRAPHICS UNIT WITHIN FINANCE
TO SEE WHAT DATA WE HAVE.
I'M JUST NOT FAMILIAR RIGHT NOW
WITH KIND OF HOW TO BUILD.
ONE WELL THERE'S SOME TALK ABOUT
THE WAITING LIST.
DO WE HAVE A GOOD GRASP ON WHAT
THIS WAITING LIST IS.
THE AMOUNT ON THE WAITING LIST.
NOT ALL TRIPLE A.'S ARE FOR AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING A RECALL.
AGENCIES ON AGING AND THEIR
PROVIDERS ARE REQUIRED TO KEEP
WAITING LISTS.
SOME DO.
SOME DON'T SO THE INFORMATION
THE ONE WITH HALF AROUND WAITING
LISTS WOULD.
VERY ACROSS SYRIA AS AN
PROVIDERS SO YOU COULD HAVE
PARTIAL INFORMATION.
BUT IT'S NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU A
PICTURE OF WHAT OF WAITING LISTS
LOOK LIKE ACROSS THE STATE.
YOU'D YOU'D BE ASKING DOES
PROVIDERS AND AREA AGENCIES TO
KEEP THAT INFORMATION TO SHARE
ABOUT BUT IT'S NOT.
A REQUIREMENT ACROSS THE PROGRAM.
DO THE LOCAL PLANS GIVE US THAT
INFORMATION.
OF THE LOW.
WE'D HAVE TO LOOK AT THE LOCAL
PLAN SPECIFICALLY FOR THE HOT.
IT'S CERTAINLY CONCEIVABLE THAT
CERTAIN PLANS WOULD CERTAIN
PLANS MAY NOT IT AGAIN.
WAITING LIST INFORMATION MAY OR
MAY NOT SHOW UP IN A AN AREA
PLAN BECAUSE IT'S NOT REQUIRED
INFORMATION.
SHOULD BE REQUIRED.
I THINK THAT THERE WOULD BE.
THAT THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION TASK
WHEN WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
RESOURCES FOR PROVIDERS WHO ARE.
STRUGGLING.
I THINK THE ANSWERS YOU ARE ALL
OF STRUGGLING THEM WELL NO BUT
WHAT I'M SAYING IS.
THERE IT BUT THERE ARE CONCERNS
ABOUT ENABLING PROVIDERS TO
PROVIDE SERVICES.
WITHOUT ADMINISTRATIVE
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE GOING TO
BE BURDENSOME TO THEM UNLESS
THEY HAVE THE FUNDING TO MEET
THOSE REQUIREMENTS.
IT IS SO IT THE ANSWER SO YOU'RE
SAYING THIS CITIZENS MATHIS
SORRY SO SO WHAT I'M SAYING IS
IF YOU'RE ASKING PROVIDERS TO
KEEP WAITING LISTS.
PROVIDERS WOULD.
IT SHOULD BE READ IT SHOULD BE
RESOURCE TO DO THAT.
I UNDERSTAND THAT IF WE'RE
TRYING TO DETERMINE HOW MANY OF
OUR SENIORS ARE NOT RECEIVING
THE NUTRITION.
HOW DO WE COME UP WITH A NUMBER
HOW DO WE COME UP WITH THAT
ESTIMATE?
I SO [inaudible] ONE IT'S NOT AN
EASY ANSWER.
OF BECAUSE NUTRITION SO UNDER
THE OLDER AMERICANS ACT PEOPLE
WHO WORSE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
SERVICES.
OUR SIXTY AND OLDER.
THEY MAY BE LOW INCOME THEY MAY
NOT BE.
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF SERVICES
THAT A FACT [inaudible]
NUTRITION [inaudible]
OF THE HOME DELIVERED MEALS AND
CONGREGATE MEALS.
ADDRESS NUTRITIONAL NEEDS SO DO
COMMODITIES PROGRAMS BROWN BAG
PROGRAMS.
OF ACCESS. TO TWO OF THE PLACES
TO GET GROCERIES IMPACTS THE
ABILITY OF PEOPLE L. WHO.
SOLD ME SO WHAT I'M SAYING IS
THERE IS THERE IS NOT A SIMPLE
ANSWER TO THE QUESTION OF HOW DO
YOU GET THAT.
NEED THE GENERAL ACCOUNTING
OFFICE [inaudible]
IN. TWENTY FIFTEEN GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTING OFFICE DID THE STOCK
TRY TO GET OUT UNMET NEED.
IN OLDER AMERICANS ACT NUTRITION
PROGRAMS.
WHAT THEY DID IS THEY LOOKED AT?
THE DATA FROM THE CURRENT
POPULATION STUDY.
AND THEY'VE TRIED TO UNDERSTAND
AMONG LOW INCOME ADULTS.
WHAT WERE THEY RECEIVING?
WITH REGARDS TO SERVICES THAT
WERE SIMILAR.
TO OLDER AMERICANS ACT TITLE.
THREE NUTRITION SERVICES.
OF WHAT THEY FOUND A THEIR THEIR
DATA FOCUSED ON ADULTS SIXTY AND
OLDER LIVING IN HOUSEHOLDS WITH
INCOME.
IT'S THAT WERE BELOW A HUNDRED
AND 85% OF POVERTY.
SO THEY COULDN'T BE GENERALIZED
TO THE POPULATION OF PERSONS WHO
MIGHT HAVE.
A LITTLE MORE RESOURCES.
AND WHAT THEY FOUND THAT THEY
CAME UP WITH AN ESTIMATE THAT
90% OF LOW INCOME OLDER ADULTS.
DID NOT RECEIVE MEAL SERVICES
LIKE THOSE FUNDED.
BY TITLE THREE PROGRAMS.
AND ABOUT 83% DID NOT RECEIVE
MEALS AMONG -- 83% OF OLDER
ADULTS WHO WERE FOOD IN SECURE
WERE.
AS MEASURED BY SUCH THINGS AS OF
WORRYING ABOUT FOOD.
SKIPPING MEALS BECAUSE THERE
WASN'T ENOUGH MONEY FOR FOOD.
OR NOT EATING FOR A WHOLE DAY
BECAUSE THERE WAS NOT ENOUGH
MONEY FOR FOOD.
WE'RE NOT RECEIVING.
SERVICES SO GIVE ME FOR
INTERRUPTING YOU.
OKAY I I HAVE A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION BUT I WOULD LIKE --
MISTER MATHIS HAS A QUICK.
QUESTION HE WANTS TO ASK PLEASE
MR MATHIS OKAY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I'M LISTEN THIS
CONVERSATION AND AND AND THAT
I'M NOT LIKE IN ANY OF THE
ANSWERS BECAUSE IT'S WE WE DON'T
KNOW HOW TO DO THAT I I GOT A
FOREIGN EXCHANGE UNITS IN HIGH
SCHOOL I KNOW.
HE NEEDS. TEN DOLLARS A DAY FOR
LAUNCH.
IT'S FIVE DAYS A WEEK THAT FIFTY
BUCKS A WEEK THE THESE ARE
SIMPLE MULTIPLICATION PROBLEMS
OF MY NINE YEARS OLDS COULD
FIGURE OUT.
SO I'M VERY FRUSTRATED WITH THAT
AND THE FACT THAT IN THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM WE FIGURED OUT FREE AND
REDUCED BREAKFAST AND LUNCH FOR
ALL OF OUR KIDS REGARDLESS.
OF THEIR INCOME BRACKETS.
MAYBE TALKING OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH. TO FIGURE SOME OF
THIS OUT -- THEN YOU GUYS THIS
ISN'T ROCKET SCIENCE.
AND I THINK ALL MEMBERS ARE
EXTREMELY FRUSTRATED AND I THINK
THE PUBLIC EVEN MORE FRUSTRATED
ABOUT THIS.
BUT IF WE CAN FIGURE OUT FREE
AND REDUCED LUNCH IN OUR SCHOOLS.
WE WE ALREADY HAVE DEPARTMENTS
DOING THIS TALK TO EACH OTHER.
PLEASE WELL.
I I WILL SAY.
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
HAS WITHIN THE RESOURCES THAT WE
HAVE.
TRY TO ADDRESS ISSUES OF FOOD IN
SECURITY THROUGH COLLABORATIONS
WITH OTHER DEPARTMENTS.
WE'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK AROUND
CAL FRESH OUT REACH.
WE'RE WORKING RIGHT NOW WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SOCIAL
SERVICES IN THE AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING TO WORK ON SS I CASH OUT --
WE WE HAVE BEEN WORKING TO
ADDRESS ISSUES OF FOOD IN
SECURITY FOR AWHILE.
ALL I'M SAYING IS GETTING OUT AN
EXACT PERCENTAGE OF UNMET NEED.
IN IN MY OPINION PERHAPS THAT'S
NOT AS IMPORTANT IS RECOGNIZING
THAT THERE'S NEED.
BUT I THINK IF WE'RE GOING TO
PUT MONEY.
WE ALL KNOW THERE'S NEED RIGHT.
ARE WE ALL KNOW IT.
AND I A SHE EIGHT MR MATHIS'S
COMMENT.
WE REALLY DO NEED TO KNOW WHAT
THE NEED IS BECAUSE IF WE'RE
GOING TO PUT THE MONEY FOR GOING
TO BUDGET THIS.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT.
IT'S THIS INFORMATION HAS BEEN.
HAS NOT BEEN PROVIDED. FOR TEN
YEARS.
OR MORE AND IN ORDER FOR US TO
IF THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING SAYS
WE HAVE AN UNMET NEED.
WE WE WE HAVE SENIORS WHO ARE
NOT RECEIVING THE THE MEALS THAT
THEY SHOULD.
WE ALL AGREE.
BUT WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE THE
ONES THAT ARE CORE TO START
FIGURING OUT WHAT THE UNMET NEED
IS AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TO GO
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
AND YOU HAVE TO TELL US YOU NEED
TO BE OUR THOUGHT PARTNERS IN
THIS THINK THIS THROUGH.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO SAYS OKAY LET'S THINK
OUTSIDE THE BOX HOW DO WE TAKE
CARE OF THIS IT'S A SERIOUS
ISSUE.
SO SHE HAS THOUGHT OUTSIDE THE
BOX ABOUT SOME AWAY THAT WE
MIGHT BE.
AS SHE SAID MAYBE PART OF THE
SKY.
SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO DREAM BIG
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT OUTSIDE OF
THE BOX HOW WE TAKE CARE OF THIS.
WE REALLY DO LOOK TO YOU TO TO
TELL US WHAT IT IS THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING NEEDS.
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT GOING TO GUESS.
BUT WE'RE LOOKING TO THE PUBLIC
AND WE KNOW THERE'S A NEED WE'RE
LOOKING TO OUR CONSTITUENTS WE
KNOW THERE'S A NEED.
WE'RE LOOKING TO YOU TO HELP US
BUILD GOOD NUMBERS SO WE CAN
FIGURE OUT WHAT IT IS WE NEED TO
DO.
BECAUSE THIS IS A PERSISTENT
NEED MADAM CHAIR IF I COULD I'D
LIKE TO HEAR FROM MS MILLER
PLEASE.
THANK YOU WE ABSOLUTELY CONCUR
THERE NEEDS TO BE BETTER
COORDINATION COMMUNICATION AND
COLLABORATION ACROSS ALL OF THE
DEPARTMENTS AND THAT HOW DO WE
DO IT IS.
THAT OUR GOVERNOR'S VISION FROM
ASPEN WILL FIGURE IT OUT CAMINO
I WORK TOGETHER AND I I REALIZE
YOU'RE NEW.
AND I REALIZE THAT THIS IS.
NOT AN UNFAIR BURDEN BECAUSE YOU
TOOK IT ON AND I KNOW YOU'RE
CAPABLE I'VE READ ABOUT YOU YOU
YOU HAVE A LONG HISTORY WITH
STATE.
AND I KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO DO GREAT THINGS.
I WANT YOU TO NOTE JUST HOW HOW
HOW URGENT TO THIS NEED IS
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE ANOTHER
YEAR. TO THINK THIS THROUGH AND
TO THINK WELL HOW WE GOING TO DO
THIS.
IT IS TAKING AS PERHAPS MISTER
FRAZIER WOULD SAY TAKING THE
BULL BY THE HORNS AND SAYING
OKAY.
WE GOT TO TAKE CARE OF THIS HOW
WE GONNA DO IT WE'RE DOING IT
NOW.
AND BRINGING THE STAKEHOLDERS
BRINGING WHOEVER IT IS YOU NEED
TO BRING IN -- IN FACT I THINK
THAT IT WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO
ASK.
FOR A I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
REPORT [inaudible] TO US.
BEFORE THE MAY REVISE.
AND IF NOT A REPORT WE'RE NOT
ASKING FOR EXACT NUMBERS I DO
WANT THAT TO BE CLEAR.
I THINK IF YOU HAD THE
IMPRESSION THAT ANYBODY HERE ON
THE DíAS WAS ASKING FOR AN
EXACT NUMBER I WANT.
TO I WANT YOU TO KNOW.
NOBODY IS ASKING FOR AN EXACT
NUMBER.
BUT WE DO NEED THE BEST
ESTIMATES WHEN YOU KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE BASED ON BECAUSE THIS
ISN'T A NEW REQUEST -- THE THIS
ISN'T TO WE KNOW THAT THE THE
FUNDING WAS REDUCED THIS HAS
BEEN TALKED ABOUT.
SO IT'S BEEN REDUCED NOW WE NEED
TO BRING IT UP TO WHAT IT WAS.
WHY DO WE NEED TO BRING IT UP TO
WHAT IT WAS BECAUSE THESE ARE
THE NUMBERS OF SENIORS THIS IS
OUR BEST ESTIMATE?
BASED UPON THIS FORMULA THESE
ARE THE NUMBERS OF OF SENIORS
THAT HELP IN OUR THAT ARE NOT TO
BE.
RECEIVING THEIR NUTRITION.
MR MATHIS TALKS ABOUT THE FACT
THAT.
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT ROCKET
SCIENTISTS SCIENCE SCIENCE.
WE ALL KNOW THAT IT'S NOT.
WE NEED YOUR HELP WE NEED FOR
YOU TO BE OUR PARTNERS IN THIS
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE NEED IS.
SO THAT WE'RE NOT COMING UP WITH
THE NUMBERED SAYING OKAY WE SAY
FIVE MILLION.
WHAT WE WHAT WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE GETTING THAT NUMBER FROM?
WE NEED TO WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
SAY WHAT IT'S BASED ON WE WANT
TO GET THERE.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT IT'S BASED
ON I WOULD DO DEPEND.
AND WE WILL EXPECT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT THAT WE RECEIVE THE
INFORMATION.
WE WILL WORK TOGETHER
[inaudible]
DOT.
YES MISTER MATHIS YOUR
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM JUDGES A IN REAL
QUICK AND I I'VE I APOLOGIZE I
GOT ANOTHER COMMITMENT.
WE WANT TO WORK WITH YOU I'M I'M
BURKE WERE NOT HERE.
THE THE MEMBERS ON THIS WE WE
CAN BE YEP EVERYDAY OF THE WEEK.
OR WE CAN WORK TOGETHER IN JUST
GET THIS DONE.
AS AN ARMY SERGEANT FOR TEN
YEARS WHEN YOU GONNA COMBAT YOU
CAN HAVE A 100% PLAN.
IN THE MOMENT YOU STEP IN THE
PLAN GOES TO HELL.
A IN YOUR IN.
A I'D RATHER GO WHEN WITH THE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE NOW.
KNOWING THAT THE POPULATIONS
INCREASE NOR NO WE WE THERE ARE
KNOWN KNOWNS THAT WE HAVE IN
THERE ARE KNOWN UNKNOWNS.
AND THERE ARE KNOWN UNKNOWNS.
DONALD RUMSFELD AND BUT WE CAN
ACT.
IN THAT IS OUR DUTY AND OUR
RESPONSIBILITY.
AS A LEGISLATIVE MEMBERS OF OUR
OFFICE.
AND AS THE APPOINTMENTS THAT
YOU'VE ACCEPTED AND WE CAN DO
THIS TOGETHER IN IN THAT TRUST
ME THEY'RE GOING TO BE A PERSON
FIGHT IN THIS [inaudible]
ONE IT'S THE THE WILL OF THE
LEGISLATURE SHOWN.
I MEAN WHICH IS THIS IS MY FIFTH
YEAR NO ONE THIS.
WHERE WERE HALF A DECADE IN AND
IT STILL ISN'T FIXED?
IN THE MEMBERS ON THIS COMMITTEE.
HAVE ANOTHER ALMOST DECADE THE
GAL.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO COME BACK
NEXT YEAR AND BE HAVING THE SAME
CONVERSATION.
AND I THINK A LOT OF US ARE SICK
OF HAVING THIS CONVERSATION OVER
AND OVER AND OVER.
BECAUSE WERE READY TO GET THIS
DONE WE'RE READY TO GET DOWN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
[inaudible]
SO.
YOUR NEW LET'S WORK TOGETHER
LET'S LIFT EACH OTHER LET'S
THROW EVERYBODY IN OUR
CONFERENCE ROOM AND FIGURE THIS
OUT.
I'M FINE WITH THAT.
BUT I WE NEED THAT COMMITMENT WE
NEED THOSE REPORTS WE NEED THOSE
THINGS AS THE CHAIR SAID TO COME
BACK.
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSION.
ALL RIGHT I WANT TO THEM AND
WITH THIS.
I DO WANT TO ASK THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
TO ASSIST US WITH UNDERSTANDING
WHAT THE NEEDS ARE FOR THE
SENIOR NUTRITION PROGRAMS.
MEALS ON WHEELS.
AND CONGREGATE IN NUTRITION.
I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU TO CONSULT
WITH THE ADVOCATES.
WITH MISTER CAMP.
DARRYL KELCH.
AND GET THE MOST BURKE. TO
SURVEY THE PROGRAM SITES IN THE
CELLS WITH THEIR ANNUAL ON
AVERAGE WAITING LISTS LOOK LIKE.
IN THE FAIREST WAY POSSIBLE.
AND THEN DEVELOP A GENERAL FUND
ESTIMATE FROM THAT.
THIS SHOULD GIVE US A REALISTIC
PICTURE OF WHAT THE CURRENT.
DOCUMENTED NUTRITIONAL NEED FOR
THIS PROGRAM IS.
AND IT WILL HELP US TO
CONTEXTUALIZE THIS PROPOSAL.
IF AS YOU'RE DOING THIS YOU FEEL
THAT THERE IS A BETTER WAY TO DO
IT. TO REACH OUT TO US.
AND LET US KNOW WHAT YOUR BETTER
METHOD IS.
CAN THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DO THIS
SURVEY PROVIDE THE INFORMATION.
TO THIS COMMITTEE.
I MEAN WHAT I CAN I CAN LOOK TO
SEE WHAT HOW I JUST CAN'T COMMIT
RIGHT NOW IT'S GIVEN THE
WORKLOAD BUT I AM DEFINITELY.
YOU KNOW WORK WITH THE ADVOCATES
AND SEE HOW WE CAN DO THIS.
I AM ASKING FOR REPORT BY APRIL.
I NEED THE REPORT BEFORE WE CAN
LOOK AT THE MAY REVISE.
IF THERE IS AN ISSUE.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT EFFORTS WERE
MADE. TO DO THIS.
WHY THOSE EFFORTS COULD NOT BE
ACCOMPLISHED?
AND WHAT THE NEXT STEPS WILL BE.
I NEED YOUR HELP.
OUR SENIORS NATURE HELP.
THAT MEANS I NEED YOUR HELP.
I'M BEING REDUNDANT RIGHT.
AS A CHAIR I NEED YOUR HELP AS A
SENIOR I NEED YOUR HELP.
I KNOW WE CAN DO THIS.
BUT I DO WANT IT BY APRIL
BECAUSE WE NEED TO HAVE THIS
INFORMATION BEFORE THE MAY
REVISE [inaudible]
YES [inaudible] THREE ANYTHING
ELSE FROM THE MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT WE SKIPPED OVER OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT I'D LIKE TO OPEN
IT UP TO PUBLIC COMMENT NOW.
I WAS JUST ASKED TO MAKE IT
CLEAR.
OF WHEN WE SAY APRIL WILL
REFERRALS NEXT WEEK SO.
THE END OF APRIL.
ALL RIGHT. TO THE END OF APRIL.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT PUBLIC COMMENT MADAM
CHAIR DARRYL COACH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING.
THE DISCUSSION AND THE QUESTIONS
THAT THE COMMITTEE HAD
[inaudible]
THE I CAN ONLY SAY THAT TO
HASN'T ASSOCIATION WE'RE
COMMITTED. TO ALSO WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE LA LOW.
AND YOUR STAFF TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN COME BACK TO YOU WITH
SOME.
SOME OF THE ANSWERS TO THESE
QUESTIONS SO THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GARY PASSED MORE CONGRESS OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS I DON'T THINK
IN IN EIGHTEEN YEARS OF SITTING
THROUGH THESE HEARINGS I'VE EVER
HEARD A DISCUSSION QUITE LIKE
THIS.
AND ON AND I THINK IN FAIRNESS
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING STAFF.
YOU'VE GOT TO UNDERSTAND THAT
FOR THOSE EIGHTEEN YEARS AND
MAYBE LONGER.
ANY TIME THEY CAME IN AND ASKED
FOR AN EXPANSION THEY WERE
TURNED DOWN AND THEY WERE
DISCOURAGED FROM THEIR UPPER.
UP MANAGERS NOT TO GO IN AND
KEEP ASKING AN EMBARRASSING THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR NOT FUNDING
IT THAT'S THE REALITY.
WE HAVE LIVED IN A WORLD FOR A
FOR A GENERATION AND WHICH
ASKING WHAT WAS NEEDED.
WAS DISCOURAGED AND AND SO OUR
SYSTEM.
IS IS DESIGNED NOT TO GENERATE
THE KIND OF DATA THAT YOU NEED.
UP IN RESPONSE TO UP ASSEMBLY
MEMBER [inaudible]
ROSA.
RUBIO I'M SORRY I CAN'T REMEMBER
YOUR NAME.
OUT THERE ARE STATES THAT ARE
DOING WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
OR THINKING ABOUT AT LEAST.
A NUMBER OF STATES ARE LOOKING
AT THEIR MANAGED CARE PLANS AND
BUILDING IN NUTRITION AS A
COMPONENT OF THE CARE GIVEN AND
MANAGE CARE.
AND IN FACT THREE YEARS AGO WE
DO WE STARTED WORKING ON THAT
AND WE'RE JUST BEATEN DOWN I
MEAN WE WERE TOLD DON'T EVEN GO
THERE DON'T EVEN MENTION IT
BECAUSE THE COSTS ARE TOO GREAT.
BUT IT IS A CROCK ACOSTA
AVOIDANCE AS WELL.
BY HAVING HEALTHY.
UP MEMBERS OF A OF A MEDICARE
PLAN OR MEDICAL PLAN BUT AT ANY
RATE I JUST WANTED TO TELL YOU
THAT.
I'VE DREAMED ABOUT THIS DAY AND
WE WILL BE AN AVAILABLE. TO WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO DEVELOP
NUMBERS I WOULD SAY THE PLACE TO
START IS THE MILLION.
SENIORS BETWEEN THAT NUMBER A
DONE TO FIGHT AS OF BEING AT
RISK OF BEING FOOD INSUFFICIENT.
AND THE NUMBER THAT WERE
ACTUALLY SERVING IN THAT
DIFFERENCES ABOUT A MILLION
PEOPLE SO IF YOU START WITH THE
MILLION AND FIGURE OUT WHAT IT
COSTS TO DEAL.
WITH ONE INDIVIDUAL FOR THE
MEALS THAT THAT WE DO FEEL
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROVIDING AND
MULTIPLY IT TIMES A MILLION THEN
YOU'RE PROBABLY IN THE BALLPARK
AND NOT I KNOW IS A VERY.
UP.
ROUGH WAY OF DOING IT BUT I CAN
GUARANTEE YOU I'M NOT VERY FAR
OFF [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI BUT I THAT IT WOULD YOUR
COMMENTS.
NOT.
I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH YOUR
COMMENTS.
AND I THINK THAT IT IS IMPORTANT
TO EMPOWER THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING.
SO THAT THEY ARE ABLE THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WHATEVER THEY
REQUEST THEY'RE GOING TO RECEIVE.
BUT IN ORDER FOR US TO EVALUATE
PROPERLY.
WE NEED TO KNOW.
WHY THE REQUEST IS BEING MADE
AND THEN TO PROPERLY EVALUATE WE
ARE NOT IN A POSITION TO
PROPERLY EVALUATE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS THE
BATTERY I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
LIFE ELDER CARE AND THE NEARLY
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED VULNERABLE
HOMEBOUND SENIORS THAT WE SERVE
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY WITH PROGRAMS
LIKE MEALS ON WHEELS.
FALL PREVENTION FRIENDLY
VISITORS AND ASSISTED
TRANSPORTATION AS WELL AS
CORPORATE CARE COORDINATION WITH
OUR PARTNER AGENCIES.
THE SUPPORT THAT WE GIVE TO THE
SENIORS HELPS KEEP THEM STRONGER
MORE INDEPENDENT AND CONNECTED
WITH THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THERE IS A GROWING NEED FOR SUCH
SERVICES ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR
SENIOR PROGRAMS.
SUCH AS WHAT RELATED TO
NUTRITION AND OTHER ESSENTIAL
SERVICES FOR OUR EIGHT AGING
OLDER POPULATION.
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE YOU TO
A LOVELY ELDERLY COUPLE THAT
HAVE TRAVELED HERE FROM FREMONT
TO SHARE THEIR STORY.
STARS SAM A HER IN THEIR ENTIRE
SOME BEANS.
THEM.
HE WOULD LIKE WELL WE WANT HIM
TO STAND IN.
WHATEVER HE WANTS -- HER IN
THEIR BASE FROM CALIFORNIA FREE
LONG.
I HAVE A QUESTION HERE.
I WOULD REQUEST THAT.
SPEAK MADAM SPEAKER IS THERE ANY
SPECIFIC PROGRAM FOR THE BLIND
SENIORS [inaudible]
THAT'S IT [inaudible]
THE A PROGRAM OF THE ESO SIDE
ESOS P. PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY.
HE IS EMOTIONALLY BECAUSE HE'S
RELYING.
HE HAS A HEART PATIENT HE'S
GONNA CICERO SO HE GARCIA.
BUT I AM USING THE VA BE LIABLE
FOR THE LAST IT IT TWO YEARS WE
ARE READY.
IF WE DON'T HAVE THAT PROGRAM
THEN MAYBE HE YOU HE WOULD RE
READ PATIENT.
THAT THE PROGRAMDAIS DREW PART
OF THAT.
DOCTOR THE USERS.
AND THAT TED OF THREE ANY READ
THE PRIVATE PROVIDERS THAT IT'LL
GO TO THAT DO YOU GET OFF HIM.
I AM LOVE.
BUT CONSENT THRONE ROOM.
THANK GOD BIG GET OUT OF HIM.
SO THERE'S THAT BUT WHY IT IS
STAY WITH THEM AND THE DOCTORS.
SO WE ALREADY HAVE BE ICE
[inaudible]
I THINK [inaudible]
THE LIFE FRIENDLY GOOD VERY
NEEDS MORE FARMS DREW.
MAKE USE READ MODE BEST
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IT IS CLEAR THAT WE
NEED MORE FUNDS MORE MONEY TO
MAKE.
THESE PROGRAMS BETTER I WANT TO
THANK YOU BOTH FOR COMING.
OF AND TO HEAR FROM.
THOSE WHO USE THE SERVICES THAN
THOSE WHO ADVOCATE ALTHOUGH I
LIKE THE ADVOCATES.
TO THANK YOU THANK YOU I JUST
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
A WENDY PETERSON -- MADAM
CHAIRMAN AND ALL OF YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR SENIOR SERVICES
ACROSS THE STATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MIGHT THE GUERRERO
REPRESENTED THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL.
I'M LOS ANGELES COUNTY -- ON OUR
OUR AVERAGE -- FROM THE STATE
GENERAL FUND IS ABOUT 14% WHICH
COMES TO LA COUNTY FOR THE
SENIOR TRICIA PROGRAM.
AND CURRENTLY WE DO HAVE A WAIT
LIST OF ABOUT THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY EIGHT PEOPLE -- AND ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX ARE
OVER NINETY DAYS SO WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE -- GETTING THIS --
FUNDING BECAUSE IT WOULD HELP
THOSE THAT ARE IN NEED AS A
SOCIAL WORKER MYSELF PROVIDING
SERVICES TO THE ELDERLY FOR
MEMORY RELATED ISSUES.
THEY'D SIGNIFICANTLY NEED THAT
CASE MANAGEMENT SUPPORT SOMEBODY
YOU CAN GO AND SOMEBODY WHO CAN
PROP THEM REMIND THEM TO TAKE
THEIR MEDICATIONS -- OR JUST
PROVIDE YOU KNOW JUST STUFF A
LITTLE -- YOU KNOW PROBLEM
SOLVING YOU KNOW I NEED TO GO
SEE MY DOCTOR I FEEL THIS.
AND THEN JUST PROBLEM SOLVING
AND HOW TO GET ACCESS TO THEIR
DOCTOR JUST VERY BASIC NEEDED
HELPS TO PREVENT AN EMERGENCY
ROOM SITUATION.
THESE ARE VERY PREVENTABLE
THINGS IS SOMETHING THAT
SOMEBODY CAN JUST KEEP TRACK OF
AND JUST PROVIDE A QUICK CHECK
SO I THINK THIS PARTICULAR
PROGRAM IS VERY HELPFUL.
AND PROVIDING -- YOU KNOW THE
SUPPORT FOR THE ELDERLY IN THE
SENIOR TUITION PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD APP MISSING MOMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON LEASE A COMMON
WITH CALCOT LIKE TO THANK MEMBER
CHIU FOR INCLUDING THE LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN IS A PART IS THIS
BUDGET REQUEST WE'VE TALKED
BEFORE ABOUT ALL OF THE SPOKES
IN A WHEEL ALL OF THE PARTS OF
THE MASTER PLAN.
AND THE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED IN THIS PROPOSAL ARE
INDEED VITAL SERVICES -- SIMILAR
RUBIO YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT
WE HAVE RESIDENTS IN LONG TERM
CARE TODAY FOR THE LACK OF A HOT
MEAL.
AND AT THE COST OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS A MONTH FOR SKILLED
NURSING CARE.
A MEALS ON WHEELS PROGRAM IS A
MUCH BETTER INVESTMENT FOR THE
STATE THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING
THESE PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
THERESE OLIVERI FROM HUMBOLDT --
COUNTY AND I WORK WITH FOR
HUMBOLDT SENIOR RESOURCE CENTER
AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY ON OUR
WAITING LIST RIGHT NOW IN A
RURAL COUNTY WHICH WERE NOT ABLE
TO SERVE ALL OF OUR COUNTY WE
HAVE OUR IN THE SIXTIES.
AND THAT MEANS TONIGHT OVER
SIXTY PEOPLE ARE GOING. TO SLEEP
WITHOUT A HOT MEAL AND THAT JUST
BREAKS MY HEART [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND THE VENTURA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THESE
PROPOSALS WANTED TO UNDERSCORE
THE LINK BETWEEN HUNGER AND
HEALTH -- FOOD INSECURE SENIORS
ARE AT HIGHER RISK -- INCREASED
RISK OF HAVING A CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITIONS INCLUDING THINGS LIKE
ACTIVATED.
HEART DISEASE AND DEPRESSION --
I REALLY ENCOURAGE US TO THINK
ABOUT THIS AS AN INVESTMENT IN
THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
CALIFORNIA SENIORS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JAMES
TO JERRY AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOR
SENIORS WERE AT TRIPLE A
PROVIDER PROVIDING FREE LEGAL
SERVICES IN THE HIGH CAP PROGRAM
FROM A COUNTY -- I AM HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ALL OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE --
PROPOSED BUDGET REQUESTS -- IN
TEN YEARS OF PROVIDING LEGAL
SERVICES TO LOW INCOME OLDER
ADULTS I'VE YET TO MEET A CLIENT
WHO'S COMING MY DAUGHTER WHO --
DIDN'T NEED MORE OR ALMOST ALL
OF THE SERVICES WERE TALKING
ABOUT SO I THINK IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL TO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
THE BIG PICTURE OF WHICH
NUTRITION IS AN ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL PART.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CAROL SO FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING AND ALSO
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ELDER JUSTICE COALITION.
WE KNOW THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
A A REQUIREMENT TO CONSIDER THE
OTHER ECONOMIC SECURITY INDEX
WHEN DEVELOPING THE STATE PLAN
AN AGING AND THE LOCAL STATE
PLANS ARE ALSO -- OBLIGATED TO
LOOK AT THOSE NUMBERS THAT IS A
OF OF ELATION THAT'S DONE AT
UCLA THE CENTER FOR HEALTH
POLICY RESEARCH THAT LOOKS AT
THE ACTUAL COST.
OF PROVIDING OF OF MAINTAINING A
SENIOR AT A BASE LEVEL OF OF
HEALTH AND ACT ECONOMY -- I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
INCORPORATE THAT CONSIDERATION
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT WHAT
NEEDS REALLY ARE BECAUSE IT DOES
VERY AROUND THE STATE.
AND THAT IS -- A VERY VALID
FIGURE THAT COULD BE USED IN
LOOKING AT WHO REALLY DOES NEED
FOOD WE KNOW THAT CURRENTLY
NUTRITION PROGRAMS FEED PROBABLY
FEWER THAN 20% OF THOSE IN NEED
RIGHT NOW.
AND SO THERE IS THERE IS A HUGE
GAP THAT NEEDS TO BE FILLED WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONCERN ABOUT
THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MY NAME IS
OFFER PASSED I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF DAYBREAK ADULT CARE
CENTERS WHERE THE NETWORK OF
ADULT DAY SERVICES IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WHAT
WE SEE AS THE MOST DEVASTATING.
RESULTS OF THESE BUDGET CUTTING
IS THE LOSS OF DIGNITY BASIC
DIGNITY OF HUMAN BEINGS.
AND THIS IS DEVASTATING NOT JUST
FOR OLDER ADULTS IT'S
DEVASTATING FOR A SOCIETY THAT
IS ALLOWING THIS TO HAPPEN -- SO
ALL THESE PROGRAMS UPPER TALKING
ABOUT OUR LIFELINE TO KEEP THIS
DIGNITY IN PLACE TO KEEP US AS
SOCIAL AS A SOCIETY.
IN A BETTER POSITION AND THIS
FUNDING IS REALLY THE OXYGEN TO
KEEP THIS A PROGRAMS A LIFE SO
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW
THE LUXURY WE'RE TALKING REALLY
ABOUT BRINGING THINGS TO THE
BASIC HUMAN.
DIGNITY NEEDS THAT PEOPLE HAVE
OUT THERE.
M. AND I REALLY WANT TO SAY THAT
I APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU FOR BRINGING THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR CHAMPIONING THIS
BECAUSE THIS IS READY FOR US --
THIS IS BEYOND PARTNERSHIP THIS
IS YOU KNOW THIS IS WHAT WE NEED
ON GROUND PEOPLE LIKE Q. RUNNING
AND SUPPORTING US TOGETHER TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE LIVING
HERE WITH GREAT DIGNITY.
IN THE LAST TWO YEARS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CECILIA CUNNINGHAM.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU US THAT
WOMEN.
MEMBER SURE YOU. FOR YOUR BUDGET
REQUEST BECAUSE WE DEFINITE
IMMEDIATE.
THIS BUDGET REQUEST.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ME.
AND OTHER THINGS YEARS BECAUSE
BY PUT THE MONEY BACK.
AND PROGRAMS AND SERVICES WE
NEED.
TO IT WILL MAKE SURE THERE ARE
SERVICES AVAILABLE TO US.
WE WE NEED THEM.
I THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR SERIOUS
CONSIDERATION OF THIS REQUEST.
EVERYONE IS AGED.
AND CALIFORNIA SHOULD MAKE SURE
WE ARE RESPECTFULLY PROVIDING
THE SERVICES SENIORS DESERVE.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BUDGET
REQUESTS AGAIN THANK YOU AND I
WANT TO SAY -- TO THE BOND
MATHIS WHEN HE MENTIONED ABOUT.
THE OF THING YEARS EVEN DOG FOOD
NOT JUST DOG FOOD ALSO CAT FOOD
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ADVOCACY.
I'M LARA CALIBER WITH THE
SPECTRUM COMMUNITY SERVICES WE
PROVIDE SENIOR NUTRITION
PROGRAMS AND FALLS PREVENTION
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS HOME HOME
ENERGY ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS
[inaudible]
ON I KNOW THAT YOU GUYS HAVE A
LOT OF ISSUES THAT COME BEFORE
YOU EVERY DAY.
AND THEY'RE ALL VERY MEANINGFUL.
TODAY'S BEEN A VERY EMOTIONAL
DAY FOR ME I AM A PROUD NATIVE
CALIFORNIA.
AND I GREW UP VERY PROUD TO BE
THE ONE BUT TODAY WAS BEEN A
VERY SAD DAY.
IN HEARING WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON
HERE.
AND THEN I GOT MAD.
AND I GOT REALLY MAD ABOUT HOW
WE'RE TREATING.
THE RESIDENTS IN THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
CAN I GOT HOPEFUL WHEN I WAS
HEARING FROM THIS COMMITTEE.
THE YOUR ALSO PASSIONATE.
ABOUT THIS.
THAT THIS HAS BEEN COMING BEFORE
YOU AND THIS IS SOMETHING YOU
CARE ABOUT AS WELL. FOR THOSE OF
US WHO DO THIS WORK EVERY DAY
THANK YOU.
I HAVE TO STOP AND WONDER.
IN THE NEXT THREE MONTHS.
WHICH ONES HAVE YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO VOTE FOR BUDGET.
IN LESS THIS FUNDING IS INCLUDED
IN IT.
WHICH ONE OF YOU GUYS ARE GOING
TO BE THE CHAMPIONS AT STAND UP
AND SAY YEAH WE PASS THIS FOR
SEVERAL YEARS.
BUT WE'RE NOT GOING TO PASS A
BUDGET WITHOUT THIS AGAIN.
YOU ASKED HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
WAITING LIST I DO CONGREGATE
MEALS AND HOME DELIVERED.
IN THE THREE SMALL COMMUNITIES
THAT I SERVE HOME DELIVERED
MEALS.
OUR ALLOCATION FOR MEALS.
ARE ONLY HALF.
OF THE I NEED TO TO SERVE MY
COMMUNITY [inaudible]
HALF.
AND OUT OF THAT ALLOCATION.
ONLY THE FUNDING ONLY COVERS
HALF OF WHAT I NEED I HAVE TO
RAISE THE REST OF THE MONEY.
AND I'M DOING IT WITH VOLUNTEERS
AS WELL I HAVE 20% OF MIGHT
SENIOR INTRUSION PROGRAM ON
STAFFING OPEN. FOR THREE MONTHS
I'VE HAD JOB POSTINGS I CAN'T
FILL AND THAT'S REALLY CLEAR
BECAUSE I CAN'T PAY ENOUGH.
I HAVE A BIG HOLE IN MY BUDGET
BECAUSE I'M TRYING TO KEEP UP
WITH MINIMUM WAGE.
AND I'M NOT BEING ABLE KEPT KEEP
UP WITH MARKET RATE.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING. TO THE
RESIDENTS THE CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M NANCY WILBERT
WITH JEWISH FAMILY SERVICE OF
LOS ANGELES AGAIN -- WE ARE
LARGE MULTI SERVICE PROVIDER WE
ARE STANDING HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS AS SOME OF YOU HAVE HEARD.
MEMBERS I'VE SPOKEN WITH WE
PROVIDE ABOUT A THOUSAND MEALS A
DAY TO SENIORS THROUGH THE
SENIOR NUTRITION PROGRAM HOME
DELIVERED IN CONGRESS SITES.
EVERY DAY ACROSS LA.
AND WE PROVIDE THOSE MEALS IN
WARM SETTINGS AND IT PEOPLE'S
HOMES AND WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
VETERANS WHO THE ONLY PERSON
THEY SEE EVERY DAY AS THEIR
DRIVER.
WE HAVE A GENTLEMAN WHO WAITS
OUTSIDE HIS DOOR FOR HIS DRIVER
TO GET THERE WITH HIS MEAL.
HE HAS TO BE FIRST ON THE LIST
BECAUSE OTHERWISE HE SITS
OUTSIDE.
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS A PROBLEM
WE HAVE BEEN IN THIS COMMITTEE
BEFORE TODAY'S CONVERSATION WAS
FASCINATING AND EXHILARATING.
LITTLE CHALLENGING ON THE ELDER
INDEX IS AN INCREDIBLE TOOL THAT
WE SHOULD BE USING IN THIS
CONVERSATION TALKING ABOUT.
THE GAP BETWEEN NEEDS AND
REALITY IN THE STATE BUT THE
OTHER THING IS AND I DIDN'T HEAR
IT MENTIONED SO I WILL THROW IT
OUT THERE.
WE KNOW WITH SEQUESTRATION CUTS
TO THINGS LIKE SENIOR NUTRITION
OLDER AMERICANS ACT WERE ON THE
TABLE CUTS WERE MADE ONCE BEFORE
AND WE EXPECT TO SEE THOSE
POTENTIALLY AGAIN.
THIS FALL WHEN THAT HAPPENS WHEN
WE LOSE SEVEN ANOTHER SEVEN AND
A HALF PERCENT FUNDING IN THE
STATE.
I DON'T KNOW WHICH SEVENTY FIVE
SENIORS OF OUR THOUSAND WE'RE
NOT SUPPOSED TO SERVE WHICH ONES
ARE WE SUPPOSED TO TELL YOU GO
HUNGRY TODAY.
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE MONEY FOR
THESE MAILS AND SO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THIS SO SERIOUSLY WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO DENISE LIKER INDEPENDENCE
AT HOME IT'S CAN HELP ON LOS
ANGELES COUNTY I STAND HERE IN
SUPPORT OF ALL OF THESE PROGRAMS
NUTRITION IS A FUNDAMENTAL BASIC
NEED.
NONE OF US IN THIS ROOM CAN
SURVIVE WITHOUT FOOD NEITHER CAN
OUR SENIORS PLEASE CONSIDER THIS
REQUEST [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD.
EVENING I'M I'M EILEEN KOONTZ
WITH HUNTINGTON HOSPITAL IN
PASADENA SERVING THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY.
I OUR PROGRAM MULTI PURPOSE
SENIOR SERVICE PROGRAM DEPENDS
HEAVILY ON OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
PROVIDERS LIKE -- HOME DELIVERED
MEALS AND CONGREGATE MEALS
PROGRAMS BECAUSE WE LEVERAGE A
LOT OF THOSE RESOURCES BEFORE WE
DIP INTO THE WAIVER TO BE ABLE.
TO BUY OUR WAY OUT OF OTHER
NEEDS THAT THEY CAN'T BE MAD
ANOTHER WAY SO WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT A ROBUST NETWORK
INCLUDING.
THE MEALS PROGRAMS AND JUST
REALLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M CLEARLY KITANA WITH
SENIOR SERVICES COALITION OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY -- I WANT TO
THANK GOD ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
FORD YOUR HONOR COURAGE AND ALL
WISDOM.
IN PROPOSING A ON A BUDGET LIKE
WE ALL WILL DO IN TERMS OF
BUDGETING FOR OUR OWN PERSONAL
NEEDS WE DON'T JUST LOOK AT ONE
THING WE LOOK AT EVERYTHING THAT
WE NEED.
AND SO THE HOLISTIC APPROACH IS
A VERY BRAVE AND STRONG APPROACH.
I ALSO WANTED TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT -- I WORK EVERY DAY
WITH THE THE OLDER ADULTS IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY OF WHO ARE
WORKING ON POLICY AND ADVOCACY.
AND SO I HAVE TO EXPLAIN ALL OF
THIS TO THEM LIKE IN PLAIN TALK
BECAUSE THEY REALLY YOU KNOW
HONESTLY IS BUT BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T GET IT IS JUST THAT THAT'S
NOT REALLY HOW THEY WANT TO BE
USING THEIR BAND WITH.
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT ALL
THE THE BILL NUMBERS IN THE
FANCY TALK THAT WE ALL DO WHEN
WE COME AND TALK UP HERE.
AND OF MISS CUTTING HIM AS ONE
OF OUR ADVOCATES -- BUT ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE DO ON A DAY
TO DAY BASIS AS THEY THINK ABOUT
HOW ALL OF THIS IS ALL PART OF
THEIR ECOSYSTEM.
THEY DON'T JUST SHOW UP FOR MIL.
THEY'RE NOT JUST INTERESTED IN
TRANSPORTATION THEY DON'T JUST
NEED US ALL TO SERVICE SUPPORT
SERVICES THEY DON'T JUST NEED
LEGAL SUPPORT.
OR OR EVEN THE PROTECTION WHEN
IT COMES TO THEM -- IN IN
SITUATIONS WHERE THEY ARE THE
MOST VULNERABLE THEY ACTUALLY
NEED ALL OF THIS AND SO WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT LIKE A DAY LIKE
TODAY WHERE IT'S IT'S A RAINY
DAY.
AND SOME PEOPLE HAVE A UMBRELLA
AND THESE SERVICES ARE PART OF
THEIR UMBRAL.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY SOME OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE ABLE TO GET
UNDER THE UMBRELLA.
SO BY NOT FUNDING THE ALL THE
PROGRAMS WERE ACTUALLY LEAVING
PEOPLE OUT IN THE RAIN AND I
JUST WANTED TO LEAVE THAT
METAPHOR WITH YOU AND HELP YOU
TO UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS TO THINK HOLISTICALLY ABOUT
THIS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SENATOR JOHN PORTER CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE -- AS A CHAIR
OF THE ADVISORY COUNCIL FOR THE
CITY OF LAGUNA MIGUEL AND ALSO
ORANGE COUNTY HAVE SEEN FIRST
HAND.
WHAT THE CONGREGATE MEAL AND ME
ALONG WHEELS PROGRAMS CAN HAVE
AS AN IMPACT ON SENIORS HEALTH
AND NUTRITION GO HAND IN HAND?
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I WANT TO THANK THE PANELISTS.
FOR PROVIDING US LOTS OF
INFORMATION AND INDULGING US AS
WE TRY TO WORK TOGETHER. TO
PARTNER TO GET TO WHERE WE NEED
TO BE.
I MOST ESPECIALLY WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KANSEN CHU FOR CHAMPIONING THIS
AND FOR PROVIDING.
THE VERY -- DETAILED BUDGET
REQUEST -- THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
GIVING THAT PRESENTATION TO US
TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO WOULD LIKE TO CALL
THE NEXT PANELISTS.
THE NEXT PANEL IS MULTI PURPOSE
SENIOR SERVICES PROGRAM ADVOCACY
PROPOSAL.
AND BEFORE WE GET WOULD BEGIN
TESTIMONY ON ISSUE NUMBER.
FIVE I WOULD LIKE TO ASK MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA
RUBIO SHE IS ON ISSUE NUMBER.
SIX AND I WANT TO BE SURE WE
HEAR HER TESTIMONY.
JUST IN CASE IT DOESN'T MAKE IT
BACK SO.
SO -- I MS RUBIO WOULD YOU
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR TESTIMONY ON
ISSUE NUMBER.
SIX YOU CAN DO IT FROM THERE.
THANK YOU -- YES SO MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
TO PRESENT TO THE COMMITTEE
TODAY -- ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATE SURE
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST CONTINUES
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO KEEP THE C. S. L.
OPERATIVE -- AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
ALREADY KNOW THIS YES I WAS
INITIALLY FOUNDED.
BY FORMER STATE SENATOR HENRY
MELLOW QUINN NINETEEN EIGHTY
CONVENE THE FIRST SILVER HAIRED
LEGISLATURE.
OUT SINCE THEN THE CSL HAS
CONTINUED TO SERVE AS A CRITICAL
RESOURCE TO THE LEGISLATURE SO
THAT WE MAY BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE ISSUES AND PRIORITIES OF THE
AGING COMMUNITY.
IN FACT THROUGH CS CELLS EFFORTS
OVER TWO HUNDRED BILLS THAT
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
CALIFORNIA SENIORS HAVE BEEN
SIGNED INTO LAW.
THE CSL EXISTS UNDER THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND LIKE EVERY
ENTITY HAS SIGNIFICANT COST
ASSOCIATED WITH ITS OPERATION.
TO DATE THE CSO HAS BEEN FUNDED
IN PART BY GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATIONS AND BY THE INCOME
TAX CHECK OFF PROGRAM.
UNFORTUNATELY WITH THE
DECREASING DONATIONS MADE TO THE
TAX CHECK OFF PROGRAM AND
INCREASING OPERATION EXPENSES
THE FUTURE OF DSL IS IN JEOPARDY.
THE SI SL HAS WORKED TIRELESSLY
WITH THIS COMMITTEE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE TO
FIND SOLUTIONS TO REMAIN SOLVENT.
AS A RESULT THE CSO HAS MADE
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IN
OVERHEAD COSTS REDUCE THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE ANNUAL
SESSION AND WORK TO FIND A HOME.
UNDER DIFFERENCE THE DEPARTMENTS.
WHILE REDUCTIONS IN OVERHEAD
COSTS HAVE HELPED THE CSL
REQUEST TO BE HOUSED UNDER THERE
WAS THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
UNSUCCESSFUL. TO FACILITATE THE
SUCCESS OF THIS REQUEST I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO ASK THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. TO FURTHER
IMPROVE FUEL CELLS BUDGET
ESTIMATES AND CONSIDER OPTIONS
FOR BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO
CODIFY CONTINUAL GENERAL FUND
ALLOCATION TO SUPPORT CSL
PERSONNEL.
AN OPERATING AND EQUIPMENT
EXPENSES. TO BE QUITE FRANK THE
SEE ALSO THE C. S. L. IS IN DIRE
FINANCIAL SITUATION.
GIVEN THEY AFFECT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE CSL AND THE
ORGANIZATIONS UNIQUE ABILITY TO
ACCURATELY INFORM MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
ON KEY ISSUES OF OUR STATES
GROWING SENIOR POPULATION I'VE I
BELIEVE THIS SMALLER PREPARATION
IS NECESSARY WORTHY AND
JUSTIFIED.
I'M.
LATER YOU WILL HEAR FROM -- JOHN
POINTERS SEE ALSO OF
REPRESENTATIVE BY ON A PERSONAL
LEVEL -- AND THE LEGISLATIVE
LEVEL I GUESS WE IT'S ALL.
INTERTWINED WE NEED TO HEAR FROM
THE SENIORS DIRECTLY I'VE HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH
THE SENIOR LEGISLATIVE.
A LEGISLATORS FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS AND THEIR INSIGHT ON WHAT.
WE NEED.
IS CRITICAL AND THEIR CRITICAL
TO OUR SUCCESS I'VE EVEN
SUGGESTED I THOUGHT OUTSIDE THE
BOX I SUGGESTED TO SEE A CELL TO
REQUEST THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER MEMBER -- AS A DONATION --
TO TO THEIR PROGRAM I FIGURED
YOU KNOW A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
TIMES THREE YOU KNOW WHERE I'M
TRYING TO DO MATH TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN BE
SUPPORTIVE.
IF THE THE THE ARM ARE OUT
BUDGET OF THE GENERAL FUND CAN'T.
AND SO I'VE EVEN IN -- SUGGESTED
THAT YOU KNOW FUNDRAISING
OPPORTUNITIES BUT IT'S JUST A
TEMPORARY FIX I CAN DONATE MY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND DO
SOME FUNDRAISING FOR THEM BUT
THE REALITY IS THAT.
AS OUR AGING POPULATION
INCREASES THEIR HELP IS IS ARE
MORE CRITICAL BECAUSE THEY THEY
ARE OUR BOOTS ON THE GROUND THEY
ARE THE ONES THAT ARE PROVIDING
THE LEGISLATORS.
ARE THE INFORMATION THAT WE NEED
WE CAN'T BE AT ALL PLACES AND
THESE HEARINGS UNFORTUNATELY
ONLY HAPPENED A FEW TIMES A YEAR.
BASIS IS NEEDED AND WE NEED TO
FIND THEM HOME AND WE NEED TO
FIND THAT -- ALLOCATION SO I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT WE
CONSIDER THAT BUDGET ALLOCATION
AND WE THOUGHT OF WAYS AND IF
YOU CAN PROVIDE THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
AND HELP US FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CAN HOUSE THEM.
OUT WHERE WE CAN HELP THEM AND
IF FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR IS TOO
MUCH TOO LITTLE HELP US FIGURE
THIS OUT -- AGAIN -- THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM FROM CSL
JUMP POINT OR WILL BE --
DISCUSSING AND I THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO DO THIS --
EARLIER THAN -- AN ISSUE.
SIX THANK YOU MS REPEAL WILL.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY IMPERATIVE THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU SO I WANTED TO
BE SURE THAT WE HEARD FROM YOU
BEFORE YOU LEFT.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO
TAKE YOU OUT OF TURN
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
AS YOU WILL RECALL BEFORE DOCTOR
WOULD LEFT HE DID GIVE HIS
TESTIMONY. ONE OF THE KEY THINGS
HE TALKED ABOUT IS THE FACT
THERE'D BEEN NO AUGMENTATION FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS. FOR A NUMBER OF
THINGS HE TALKED ABOUT THAT WAS
THE ONE THING.
THAT I PUT AN ASTERISK NEXT.
TO ALL RIGHT SO -- LET'S BEGIN
WITH JANET HE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE THIRTY
EIGHT EMESIS P. PROGRAMS IN THE
STATE.
I'M HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A ONE TIME ONLY
SUPPLEMENTAL INCREASE OF TWENTY
FOUR POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS.
IN GENERAL FUND. TO BE
DISTRIBUTED OVER THREE YEARS.
AS YOU KNOW AND ARE WELL AWARE
OF THE SENIOR POPULATION IS
GROWING RAPIDLY.
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN REPORTED
ON DISABILITIES AMONG SENIORS
AND THEY PREDICTED.
THAT OLDER CALIFORNIA'S TURNING
SIXTY FIVE BETWEEN THE YEARS OF
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN WILL LIVE AN AVERAGE OF
TWENTY THREE POINT SIX YEARS --
BEYOND.
SIXTY FIVE AND WILL EXPERIENCE
FOUR AND A HALF YEARS WITH A
DISABILITY.
IN A SURVEY THAT WE RECENTLY
CONDUCTED AMONG THE EMESIS P.
SITES WE FOUND THAT OUR AVERAGE
CLIENT IS ON FOR THREE AND A
HALF YEARS.
AND THAT'S JUST THE AVERAGE WE
HAVE CLIENTS ON FOR MORE THAN
FIFTEEN YEARS SOMETIMES.
WE DO PROVIDE SERVICES FOR A
VERY LONG TIME FOR THESE PEOPLE.
WE WERE WILLING TO HELP WITH
THIS AGING DILEMMA THAT WE'RE
FACING AND THE WIND ONE OF THE
WAYS THAT WE DO THAT IS
PROVIDING IN COORDINATING
SERVICES. FOR SENIORS ON
MEDICARE ALL WHO HAVE PHYSICAL
AND OR COGNITIVE IMPAIRMENTS WHO
ARE LIVING AT HOME.
WE PREVENT AND DELAY NURSING
HOME PLACEMENT BY USING
COMMUNITY BASED SUPPORT
ALTERNATIVES SUCH AS I HSS.
ANSWERED MEALS ON WHEELS.
OR ADULT DAYCARE.
AND WE OFFER PROFESSIONAL STAFF
THAT CONSIST OF REGISTERED
NURSES AND SOCIAL WORKERS WHO
EVALUATE THE BENEFICIARY'S NEEDS
AND HELP THEM ACCESS A NETWORK
OF COMMUNITY BASED RESOURCES.
THAT INCLUDE MEDICAL
INTERVENTIONS AND ADDRESS
ENVIRONMENTAL AND SOCIAL ISSUES
THAT IMPACT ONCE HELL.
THE SUPPLEMENTAL INCREASE THAT
WE'RE REQUESTING WOULD BE SPREAD
OVER THREE YEARS.
A FIRST YEAR 25% INCREASE IN THE
BASE -- RATES -- WOULD MAKE UP
FOR THE RATE OF INFLATION
BETWEEN TWENTY AND SEVENTEEN
TWENTY SIX AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AND THAT WOULD BE A 25% INCREASE.
THAT WOULD ALLOW THE EMPHASIS P.
SITES TO REBUILD AND TO
STABILIZE THE PROGRAMS THAT.
HAVE NOT SEEN A RATE INCREASE AS
YOU SAID FOR THIRTEEN YEARS AND
IN THAT THIRTEEN YEARS WE'VE
ALSO EXPERT EXPERIENCE TO BUDGET
CUTS TO TOTAL TWENTY TWO AND A
HALF PERCENT.
SO THESE BUDGET CUTS IMPOSED AN
ONGOING STATEWIDE REDUCTION OF
220-004-0090 SEVEN IMUS'S PIECE
LOTS.
SO WE ARE DOWN FROM WHERE WE
WERE IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIX THE
SPENDING PROPOSAL RESTORE 50% OF
THOSE SLOTS IN YOUR TO AND THE
OTHER 50% IN YOUR THREE BRING
CALIFORNIA BACK TO PRE RECESSION
CAPACITY OF ELEVEN THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
SLOTS.
KEEP IN MIND THAT WE THAT IS NOT
A ONE FOR ONE THAT WE OFTEN HAVE
CLIENTS THAT REVOLVE OFF THE
PROGRAM SO WE FIGURED THAT
THAT'S LOOKING AT ALMOST.
FOURTEEN THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO SERVE.
IN THIS IT ALSO SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE OUR WEIGHTLESS WHICH IS
CURRENTLY AT FIFTEEN HUNDRED
STATEWIDE.
AND THAT'S WITHOUT HAVING ANY
KIND OF AGGRESSIVE.
RECRUITMENT PROCESS AND PROCESS
AND AND JUST KIND OF LIVING
PEOPLE BE REFERRED TO AS WE
STILL HAVE FIFTEEN HUNDRED IF WE
AGGRESSIVELY RECRUITED I'M SURE
THAT WOULD DOUBLE VERY QUICKLY.
SO -- THEY'RE WEIGHTLESS IF WE
CAN REDUCE THAT THAT WOULD
INCREASE THE PROGRAM'S ABILITY
TO DIVERT.
AFFORDABLE NURSING HOME MISSION
AND TO DE INSTITUTIONALIZE OLDER
ADULTS WHO ARE ABLE TO RETURN TO
THE COMMUNITY FROM.
THE NURSING HOME FACILITIES.
OF I JUST WANT TO REMIND YOU
THAT NURSING HOMES NOW CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA FOR SEMI PRIVATE
ROOMS AROUND A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND WITH THIS PROPOSAL -- OF
INCREASING OUR BASIC RATES
EMESIS P. WILL REMAIN A BARGAIN
AT FIVE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX DOLLARS PER PERSON PER
YEAR -- WHICH IS MATCHED WITH
FEDERAL MEDICAID DOLLARS.
AND THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- WE'VE GOT NEXT.
FRAN MULLER.
YES SPECIFIC COMMENTS THAT WE'RE
HAPPY TO PROTECT HIM STAFF.
WONDERFUL JOE RODRIGUEZ.
ED LONG.
AGAIN THIS IS OF THE PROPOSAL
THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE GOAL
UNDER OUR STATE PLAN TO ENABLE
OLDER CALIFORNIANS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEIR
CAREGIVERS TO BE ACTIVE AND
SUPPORTED.
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND UNDER THAT GOAL THIS
PROPOSAL IS ALSO CONSISTENT WITH
OBJECTIVES.
TO INTEGRATE LONG TERM CARE
SERVICES INTO CAL MANY CONNECT.
IMPLEMENTS HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED SETTINGS REQUIREMENTS
WITHIN THE EMPHASIS P. PROGRAM.
AND IN EMPLOYMENT NECESSARY
OPERATIONAL CHANGES RELATED TO
PERSONS CARE.
THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME.
BERMAN FINANCE HAVE NOTHING.
HELLO HAPPY TO PROVIDE ANY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
[inaudible]
WONDERFUL.
I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION.
WHAT IS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
VIEW ON THE DESIGN OF THIS
ADVOCACY PROPOSAL?
OVER YOUR ARE YOU MEAN THE
SPECIFICS -- I DON'T HAVE THE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION OVER THREE
YEARS.
I SUPPOSE IT COULD'VE BEEN TEN
MILLION PER YEAR ON GOING BUT I
THINK HERE AGAIN TRYING TO BE
CREATIVE GIVE US TWENTY FIVE
MILLION WILL SPREAD IT OUT OVER
THREE YEARS WE'LL COME BACK IN
THREE YEARS AND TELL YOU WHAT WE
DID AND WHAT WE NEED NOW
I CAN SAY FROM THE WE DO NEED TO
LOOK AT THE PROPOSAL BUT I I
WILL SAY THAT I DID HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT THE ONE TIME ONLY
NATURE.
YOU DID OR DID NOT DID. TWO ONE
ELSE GETS.
ALL RIGHT WELL I THINK I DO OKAY.
VERY GOOD [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
VERY GOOD LET'S TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
HI DENISE LAKER INDEPENDENCE
HOMES CAN HEALTH PLAN I AM THE
SITE DIRECTOR FOR MS US BE SITE
NUMBER FIVE ONE OF THE ORIGINAL
FIVE THAT BEGAN FORTY YEARS AGO
IN THIS PROGRAM BEGAN AS A
DEMONSTRATION. FORTY YEARS LATER
WE ARE STILL ADMINISTERING THIS
PROGRAM.
THIS IS A LIFELINE SERVICE WE
ARE OFTEN THE SERVICE OF LAST
RESORT FOR THE SENIORS.
MOST OF THE SENIORS IN ON OUR
PROGRAM ARE THE AVERAGE PROFILE
IS FEMALE IN HER EIGHTIES ALONE
WITH EITHER WIDOWED.
OUTLIVE HER FAMILY MEMBERS.
HAS MULTIPLE CHRONIC CONDITIONS
INABILITY TO TAKE CARE MEET HER
BASIC NEEDS.
A LOT OF THE TIME ALSO NON
ENGLISH SPEAKING AND TRYING TO
PUT IT ALL TOGETHER.
ON MEDI CAL WITH NO SHARE OF
COST WHICH MEANS THAT HER INCOME
IS ONLY AND IN THE SIX SEVEN
HUNDRED DOLLAR RANGE PER MONTH
IF THAT.
IN ORDER TO MAKE EVERYTHING
HAPPEN ALONE IN TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW DO I GET SERVICES THE
STATE DOES NOT HAVE A ROBUST WAY
THAT SOMEBODY CAN WALK IN THE
DOOR.
AND AT SENIOR CAN WALK IN THE
DOOR AND BE ASSESSED AND BE
EASILY LED TO THE TYPES OF
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED AT HOME.
AND SO THIS TYPE OF PROGRAM WHEN
THEY COME TO US WE ARE THE JACK
OF ALL TRADES WE ARE THE
RESOURCE OF LAST RESORT PUT IT
TOGETHER FOR THEM AND TRYING TO
BE ABLE. TO MAKE THEM BE A THE
GIVE THEM THE ABILITY TO LIVE AT
HOME AND BE SAFE.
THERE'S NOBODY THAT WANTS TO
MOVE INTO A NURSING HOME.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE
INDEPENDENT AND AS HEALTHY AS
POSSIBLE AND IN THE COMMUNITY AT
LARGE.
AND SO THIS PROGRAM IS VITAL
SURVIVAL LIFELINE AND WE REALLY
NEED YOUR SUPPORT FOR FUNDING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING ONCE AGAIN I'M
EILEEN KOONTZ WITH HUNTINGTON
HOSPITAL IN PASADENA A VERY
PROUD PROVIDER OF THE EMPHASIS
P. PROGRAM FOR THE LAST THIRTY
FIVE YEARS I'M VERY PRIVILEGED
HAVE BEEN SUPPORTED BY MY
ORGANIZATION THIS WHOLE TIME. TO
BE A SORT OF AN ODD DUCK FOR AN
ACUTE HOSPITAL TO BE OUT IN THE
COMMUNITY DRIVING THROUGHOUT THE
SAN GABRIEL VALLEY.
I'M OUR SOCIAL WORKERS RACK UP
AND AND PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES
RACK UP A LOT OF MILES VISITING
PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES AND WE
WORK IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS WE
WORK WITH HEALTH PLANS UNDER THE
COORDINATED CARE INITIATIVE.
AND I WILL TELL YOU THAT THEY
WILL HAND OFF TO WAS -- WHEN WE
CAN GET IT HEALTH RISK
ASSESSMENT DATA THAT THEY'VE --
EITHER CONDUCTED A SELF
ASSESSMENT BY THE INDIVIDUAL OR
THAT THEY HAVE CONDUCTED WITH
THE INDIVIDUAL AND I THERE IS
NOTHING LIKE EYES ON WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THAT HOME SETTING
AND THERE'S NOT A LOT OF
PROGRAMS OUT THERE THAT DO WHAT
EMESIS P. IS ABLE TO DO.
AND I I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS NOT FOR EVERY SENIOR YOU
SEE ON THE STREET.
THIS IS A VERY TARGETED
POPULATION THAT FAILS USUAL CARE
SOLUTIONS -- THEY CANNOT
ADMINISTER ADD THEIR OWN IDEA TO
SASS AND THEY CAN'T NECESSARILY
TOLERATE BEING ON THE PHONE FOR
AN HOUR.
I'M TRYING TO APPEAL A DECISION
THAT THAT AN ENTITY IS MADE OR
I'M GET TO A PHYSICIAN VISITS
THEMSELVES I'M EVEN WITH
TRANSPORTATION THEY NEED ESCORTS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT AND SO
WE'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE THOSE
CUSTOMIZED SOLUTIONS. FOR
POPULATION THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
BE IN A NURSING HOME PLEASE
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON I'M LAURIE ALL
RIGHT TIME MSP CASE MANAGER
SOCIAL WORK CASE MANAGER FOR
MARIN COUNTY.
ADMINISTERED BY JEWISH FAMILY
AND CHILDREN'S SERVICES SO I'M
ACTUALLY A CASE MANAGER OUT
THERE.
WORKING WITH THAT WITH THE
PEOPLE -- SO THE FACT THAT I
EVEN GOT HERE TO SACRAMENTO IS A
BIG THING FOR ME TODAY -- THEM
YEAH I THINK YOU I SO I JUST
LIKE TO SAY THAT WE ARE WORKING
OUR HEARTS OUT -- WE HAVE A
SMALL PROBLEM PROGRAM IT'S
EIGHTY OUR CLIENTS AND THERE'S
ONLY THREE OF US SO ARE NURSES
BEEN PART TIME FOR YEARS -- AND
THEY'RE JUST ONE OTHER ON SOCIAL
WORK HIS MANAGER AND MYSELF AND
WE HANDLED THAT CASELOAD -- WE
ARE DRIVING ALL AROUND ALL THE
TIME -- AND ATTRITION AND OUR
PROGRAM OVER IN THE PAST DECADE
I HAVEN'T BEEN THERE THAT LONG
JUST GOING ON TWO YEARS BUT
LOOKING AT THE CASE NOTES AND
LOOKING BACK.
ATTRITION HAS BEEN A BIG PROBLEM
WITH THE CASE MANAGERS LEAVING
IN THIS PROGRAM.
AND PEOPLE SAY THEY LEAVE FOR
BETTER OPPORTUNITIES ARE SO --
WE ARE REALLY IMPACTED THAT WAY --
I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT THIS PROGRAM AS ARE SO
MANY PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO --
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING US
QUARTERLY AND FURTHER ANNUAL
REASSESSMENT VISITS WE DO A LOT
TO KEEP THEM IN THEIR HOME WE
SAVE THE STATE A LOT OF MONEY.
OZ SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
FOR SUPPORTING IN MISSISSIPPI
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING I'M CURRENT JONES I
AM THE APPROACH OF MS AS P.
PROGRAM DIRECTOR.
FORESIGHT EIGHT WHICH SERVICE
LAKE IN MENDOCINO COUNTIES.
REMEMBER LOW INCOME REMEMBER
AVERAGE AGE [inaudible]
EIGHTY REMEMBER ALONE.
AND PICTURE THIS [inaudible]
SOUTH -- LOOKED UP ON A
WHEELCHAIR.
BUT THE BATTERY WAS SEVEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS.
IN MISSISSIPPI WAS ABLE TO HELP
HIM GET A WHEELCHAIR BATTERY.
PICTURE ALICE T. ALONE AND A
LITTLE SHOVELED IN HER MIND.
SHE'S ON EIGHT MEDS.
AN MS AS P. WAS ABLE TO SEND THE
CONTRACTORS OUT TO HER TO SET A
PERMITS.
PICTURE FRED ARE.
SITTING IN A RAGGEDY OLD WOODEN
CHAIR WITH A VERY THIN PAD IN IT
THE ONLY CHAIR IN HIS HOUSE.
IN MISSISSIPPI WAS ABLE TO HELP
HIM GET.
A RECLINER.
PICTURE MARY A AGAIN ALONE.
NO FAMILY LEFT.
NO FRIENDS LEFT.
MSP WAS ABLE TO HELP HER GET AN
EMERGENCY RESPONSE SYSTEM.
PITCHER SIMON DE.
AN OLD CHAIR FOR THE LAST FOUR
FIVE YEARS TO SLEEP IN.
EMMA SAYS P. WAS ABLE TO HELP
HIM GET A BAD.
WITH A FRAME AND A MATTRESS AND
SHEETS AND BLANKETS [inaudible]
AND BILLS.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO IT'S NOT
DUPLICATED ANYWHERE ELSE BY
ANYBODY ELSE THE WAY THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO DO IT.
AND I JUST WANT TO REMIND YOU
THAT WHEN YOU'RE OLDER YOU'RE
EIGHTY A HEATING PAD
INCONTINENCE SUPPLIES ALL THOSE
THINGS WHICH MEANS NOTHING IF
YOU HAVE MONEY.
MEAN EVERYTHING IF YOU DON'T AND
THERE'S AN ORGANIZATION THAT CAN
HELP YOU TO GET IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO PLEASE PLEASE.
DO WHICH YOU CAN'T FORCE THANK
YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS JENNIFER
POWELL AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF DIGNITY HEALTH
CONNECTED LIVING.
WE SERVE SHASTA TRINITY SISKIYOU
LASSEN AND MODOC COUNTY IS A WE
PROVIDE NEARLY EVERY PROGRAM
SERVICE THAT WAS LISTED HERE
THIS AFTERNOON BUT I'M GONNA
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS AND ASSESS
PETE.
I AM NOW THE SITE DIRECTOR FOR
EMPHASIS PETE WE HAD ONE WHO
RETIRED AND WE WERE UNABLE TO
FIND HIS REPLACEMENT SO I BECAME
THE SITE DIRECTOR.
I WAS SHOCKED TO LEARN IN THE
LAST YEAR THAT WE LOST NINE
SENIORS ON OUR WAITING LIST THEY
PASSED AWAY WHILE THEY WERE
WAITING.
WE IF YOU'RE FAMILIAR HAVE WE
HAVE BOTH THE CAR FRE AND THE
CAMP FIRE IN OUR VICINITY A CAR
FIRE IN REDDING KAMPAR IN
PARADISE.
BECAUSE WE WERE ABLE TO HAVE
THAT MRS P. PROGRAM WE WERE ABLE
TO ASSIST THE PARADISE RESIDENTS
WERE.
MISPLACED INTO READING AND
BECAUSE OF EMESIS P. WE COULD
HELP THEM AND OFFER THEM
SERVICES.
BECAUSE OF OUR LARGE SERVICE
AREA WE HAVE TO OFFER TO PAY FOR
A HOTEL ROOM FOR OUR OUR IN
BECAUSE IT FOR HER TO DRIVE OUT
AND SEE HER CLIENTELE.
AND MEET WITH FOLKS AND ABLE TO
DRIVE HOME IS OVER EIGHT HOURS
SO THERE FOR WE HAVE TO PAY FOR
A HOTEL ROOM AND AND HER MEALS
AND TRANSPORTATION -- BECAUSE WE
ARE A HEALTH SYSTEM I'M VERY
FAMILIAR WITH WHAT OUR INS
TYPICALLY MAKE AN IN THE
EMPHASIS P. PROGRAM OUR OUR AND
MAKES LESS THAN HALF.
OF WHAT ARE IN DOES IN OUR
HOSPITAL SETTING BECAUSE OF THAT
WE OFTEN GET ARE IN CENTER
ALREADY RETIRED AND THEY JUST
WANT SOME EXTRA CASH EXTRA MONEY --
ANOTHER THING IS BECAUSE OF THE
MINIMUM WAGE AND AND AGAIN
INSUFFICIENT FUNDING MOST OF OUR
PROGRAM AIDS ARE WORKING POOR.
AND THEY DO HAVE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF OUR FOOD BANKS THAT
WE ALSO RUN SO MY OWN EMPLOYEES
ARE USING MY OWN FOOD BANK
[inaudible]
AND LASTLY.
I HAD A CONVERSATION WITH MY
HOUSE WILL PRESIDENT YESTERDAY
MORNING.
AND HE SAID.
IS IT REALLY WORTH YOUR TIME
JENNIFER TO GO DOWN IS BECAUSE
THESE HEARINGS.
AND I HOPE I CAN REPLY YES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING TO RESELL A VERY
DIRECTOR OF HEALTH SERVICES FOR
HUMBOLDT SENIOR RESOURCE CENTER
AND CITED -- DIRECTOR FOR IN
MISSISSIPPI I JUST WANTED TO
TELL YOU A QUICK STORY ABOUTAN
EIGHTY YEAR OLD WOMAN WHEELCHAIR
BOUND NO FAMILY.
AND SHE WAS ON A WAITING LIST
FOR THE SINGER -- DELIVERED
MALES AND DIDN'T HAVE A
MICROWAVE SHE WAS COOKING HER
MEALS ON AN OLD STOVE THAT ONLY
ONE BURNER WORKED IN THE VERY
BACK.
WHEELCHAIR BOUND AND THEN SHE
WAS HAVING TO REACH FORWARD PULL
IT ON TO HER LAP ONTO A TOWEL
AND ABLE TO TRY TO STIR IT
BECAUSE SHE HAD NO OTHER WAY TO
TRY TO GET MALES.
IN MISSISSIPPI WHEN WE ADMITTED --
WAS ABLE TO GET I'M A LITTLE
SMALL TO BUTTER STOVE SEND OUT A
HANDY MAN WHO MADE HER A WAIST
HIGH.
A LITTLE COUNTERED SO THAT NOW
SHE CAN COOK HER OWN MEALS.
AND IT'S THOSE KINDS OF STORIES
AND ONE MORE QUICK -- ONE OF THE
WAY A MAN WHO HAD A VERY OLD
QUEEN SIZE MATTRESS AND SUCH A
SMALL ROOM THAT THE HEATER.
THE ACTUAL FLOOR HEATER WAS
COVERED BY HER BED SO HER CHOICE
WAS EITHER A BED TO SLEEP ON OR
HAVE HE AND WE WERE ABLE TO GET
RID OF THAT OLD MATTRESS AND GET
HER NEW SMALL BED TO FIT IN HER
ROOM SO SHE CAN HAVE BOTH THE
BED.
AND HEAT.
THANK YOU.
NANCY ROBERT FROM JEWISH FAMILY
SERVICE AGAIN WE WE LIKE
INDEPENDENCE AT HOME WE WERE AN
ORIGINAL PILOT SITE STARTING IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE AND THIS
IS A PROGRAM THAT HAS BEEN THE
HEART AND SOUL FOR WHAT WE DO
FOR FRAIL SENIORS -- MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE TALKED A LOT
ABOUT WHAT IT DOES [inaudible]
BUT WE ARE SITTING HERE WITH WE
HAVEN'T GOTTEN INCREASE
STRAIGHTEN THIRTEEN YEARS AS YOU
POINTED OUT.
NONE OF US WOULD BE STANDING
HERE IF WE WERE GETTING PAID
WHAT WE GOT PAID THIRTEEN YEARS
AGO.
AND WE SIT THERE AS AN AGENCY
AND I WILL TELL YOU OUR CFO SAID
TO ME LAST WEEK.
HOW LONG CAN WE AFFORD TO
PROVIDE THIS WE DON'T RECEIVE
RATES?
THAT COVER OUR COSTS.
AND ON THE OTHER HAND WILL LOOK
AT HIM AND SAY THIS IS OUR
MISSION.
HOW DO WE STOP BUT WE CAN'T KEEP
DOING IT IF WE CAN'T AFFORD TO
PAY OUR STAFF WE CAN'T YOU KNOW
WERE LOS ANGELES?
IT'S A HIGH COST OF LIVING AND
OUR STAFF DESERVE A LIVING AN
APPROPRIATE WAGE AND SO TO THE
SENIORS WITH CARE.
FOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THE THING.
UP BARB PORTER IN MISSISSIPPI
SITE DIRECTOR FOR CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY. SEVEN SITTING HERE
TAKING ALL OF THIS AND I FIRST
OF ALL WANNA SAY IT FEELS SO
DARN GOOD TO BE IN AN ATMOSPHERE
WHERE PEOPLE CARE ABOUT THE LESS
FORTUNATE.
IN THE LEGISLATURE'S AREN'T
AFRAID TO EXPRESS IT SO THANK
YOU FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY HEART
FOR THAT NUMBER.
ONE NUMBER.
TWO YOU WANTED TO KNOW ABOUT
WEIGHTLESS I'VE GOT A WAIT LIST.
IN FOR THE PAST SIXTEEN MONTHS
I'VE BEEN DOCUMENTING WHO'S BEEN
ON THAT WAIT LISTED WHAT HAPPENS
TO THEM IF THEY DON'T GET TO
COME IN OUR PROGRAM.
AND SEVENTEEN PEOPLE FOR THAT
LAST WEIGHTLESS NEVER GOT INTO
OUR PROGRAM BECAUSE THEY ENDED
UP IN A SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
I DEFY ANYONE IN THIS ROOM SINK
I CAN'T WAIT TO SPEND THE LAST
FEW MONTHS OF MY LIFE.
IN A NURSING HOME I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY WANTS THAT IN IN
MISSISSIPPI IS THAT.
FOR ANY GIVEN LITTLE SECRET
PROGRAM THAT NOT MANY KNOW ABOUT
THE DOES EXACTLY THAT THE KEEPS
DIGNITY GOING FOR THE PEOPLE
THAT DESERVE IT THE MOST.
SO ANYWAY OF THOSE SEVENTEEN
PEOPLE THAT WANTED TO SKILLED
NURSING HOME LET ME JUST LEAVE
ON THIS MY DAD TOLD ME ONCE HE
SAYS.
NEVER DATE A GUY.
BECAUSE NO MATTER WHAT HE TALKS
ABOUT IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT THE
MONEY AND I NEVER QUITE REALIZE
THAT BUT WHEN I'M SO I WAS
SITTING HERE THINKING BECAUSE IT
IS ABOUT THE MONEY WHAT DO YOU
MAKE THE DECISION.
OUR HEARTS IN THE RIGHT PLACE
CHILDREN ARE NEEDY YOU KNOW
OLDER TO ME THERE'S SO MANY
PLACES SO HOW DO YOU MAKE THAT
DECISION SO LET ME GIVE YOU A
MONEY ONE WHICH IS SORT OF OUT
OF MY BAILIWICK.
IN THAT IS IN CONTRA COSTA IT'S
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
EMPHASIS P. COMPARED TO EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY IF YOU JUST DO
THE MATH AND THAT ALONE AND
FORGET ALL ABOUT THE WARM FUZZY
FEELINGS.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
A GOOD DECISION I PUT MY FAITH
AND TRUST IN YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
YEA ON THE MATH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ON
WISE WAY HEAD I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF LONG TERM
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR PARTNERS
IN CARE FOUNDATION.
PARTNERS IN CARE FOUNDATION
SERVES ON AVERAGE OF ABOUT WELL
A LITTLE OVER A THOUSAND AND MRS
P. BENEFICIARIES -- THROUGHOUT
THE LOOK GREATER LOS ANGELES AND
AN OLD VALLEY -- KERN COUNTY AND
SANTA BARBARA -- COUNTY.
AND AS A PREVIOUS.
MISSISSIPPI CARE MANAGER I KNOW
THE IMPACT.
THAT EMPHASIS CAN.
DO IN TERMS OF ADDRESSING BOTH
MEDICAL AND SOCIAL DETERMINANTS
OF HEALTH.
MOST IMPORTANTLY KEEP BEING A
CLIENTS AWAY FROM HIGHER COST
INSTITUTIONAL CARE SETTINGS.
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE MRS JONES.
I'M SORRY I GET A LITTLE MOTION
ABOUT MRS JONES -- BECAUSE I
HELP KOURTNEY.
A MRS JONES IS AN EIGHTY THREE
YEAR OLD -- THE LADY THAT OWNED
EMESIS P. WAS THE ONLY PROGRAM
TO HELP MRS JONES COORDINATE AND
AND ENSURE HER SAFETY -- AFTER
THE SANTA BARBARA FIRES AND
FLOODS AND THAT'S JUST NOT
UNIQUE TO MRS JONES IT'S WHAT
ALL THIRTY EIGHT M. S. S. P. R.
PROVIDERS DO.
THROUGHOUT THE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THIS HIGH TOUCH AN
INTENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT
SERVICE SO YOUR SUPPORT FOR
EMPHASIS P. IS A SUPPORT FOR ALL
OF US IN THE STATE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
Q..
CAROL SO FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
REQUEST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT BRIEF.
ME.
TO I APPRECIATE THAT VERY VERY
VERY MUCH.
ONLY BECAUSE LIKE FOR EVERYONE
TO BE ABLE TO GET HOME TO THEIR
BASS INTO THEIR DINNERS.
BUT I WANT TO HEAR FROM THE REST
OF YOU AS WELL.
SO I'M SORRY TO DISAPPOINT THEM.
YOU'LL NEVER DISAPPOINT ME I
WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU I JUST
WANTED TO THANK HER THOUGH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME MY NAME
IS THERESA AGAIN I'M THE SITE
DIRECTOR OF TWO SITES.
SERVING SACRAMENTO PLASTER YOLO
AND YUBA COUNTIES -- SO THE
FIRST THING I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
IS OUR PARTICIPANTS AND I KNOW
YOU REFERENCE EARLIER ENJOYING
SEEN PARTICIPANTS FROM ANOTHER
PROGRAM.
WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE OUR
PARTICIPANTS HERE.
THEY CAN'T MAKE IT FOR THE MOST
PART -- YOU KNOW THEY THEY ARE
IN WHEELCHAIRS -- THERE ON
WALKERS OR THEIR BED BOUND --
BUT I HAVE A SOLUTION.
WE'VE BEEN FILMING OUR
PARTICIPANTS AND GETTING THEIR
STORIES AND I WOULD LOVE TO
SHARE THAT WITH THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THEY CAN TALK
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF IN
MISSISSIPPI -- THE OTHER THING
I'D LIKE TO TO TALK ABOUT IS --
COST SAVINGS SO.
WE HAVE ONE PARTICIPANT OUR
PROGRAM WHO'S BEEN WITH OUR
PROGRAM FOR EIGHTEEN AND THREE
QUARTER YEARS -- OVER THE COST
OF OR OVER THE THE THE COURSE OF
THAT TIME.
THERE'S BEEN A COST SAVINGS OF
3235%.
INCLUDING THE COST OF AYE HSS
WITH MS AS P. AS OPPOSED TO
NURSING HOME PLACEMENT.
SO IT'S JUST A REMINDER ABOUT
HOW GREAT THIS PROGRAM IS ON THE
COST SAVINGS THAT THIS PROGRAM
HAS FOR A COMMUNITY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I WAS ASKING AYE.
WHEN YOU MENTIONED ABOUT THE
VIDEO?
OF COURSE WE'D LIKE TO SEE A
GREAT IF YOU WENT THROUGH THE
THE THE THE TIME AND EFFORT TO
PUT THAT TOGETHER.
WE WOULD LOVE TO TO READ TO SEE
THAT SO I WAS ASKING WORK COULD
BE SENT ON THE LAST PAGE OF THE
BUT OF THE AGENDA.
YOU'LL SEE THE INFORMATION FOR
NICOLE BUSCA.
WHO IS OUR CONSULTANTS ARE CHIEF
CONSULTANT HERE -- ON THIS PART
OF SUPPORT OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I REALLY APPRECIATE IT OR
ARE WE DON'T OFTEN GET THIS KIND
OF RECEPTION -- WHEN WE COME TO
THESE HEARING SIR I I DO REALLY
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU THANK
YOU?
HI MY NAME IS DYLAN BUT LOW IN A
MISSILE SHORT CASE MANAGER WITH
THE SACRAMENTO MS HAS P. SITE
I'VE BEEN WITH THEM SINCE TWENTY
THIRTEEN WHEN I FIRST STARTED I
WAS LIKE I'M GONNA GO GET MY
MASTERS IN SOCIAL WORK OR MAYBE
GO TO LAW SCHOOL.
THERESA OPEN WHO SPOKE BEFORE ME
SAID SOCIAL WORK GO TO SOCIAL
WORK I'M GOING TO FINISH THAT UP
IN MAY WAIT A MINUTE I'M AN
ATTORNEY
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE YOU AS AN
ATTORNEY TO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT
MIGHT BE MY NEXT TO GREEN ALL
RIGHT ALL RIGHT SO NOW OF THE
WAY.
AND I'M I'M GOING TO GRADUATE IN
MAY AND IT'S LIKELY THAT I'M NOT
GOING TO STAY WITH MS AS PAY
BECAUSE I HAVE A PASSION FOR
THIS WORK AND I HAVE A PASSION
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT I WORK WITH.
AND I'VE BEEN DOING IT FOR A
LONG TIME BUT WHEN YOU'RE
CONSTANTLY ASKED TO TAKE ON MORE
AND MORE OF A CASELOAD AND
YOU'RE NOT COMPENSATED FOR THAT
IN A WAY THAT YOU CAN AFFORD TO
LIVE INDEPENDENTLY YOURSELF.
YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF SOME
REALLY HARD QUESTIONS SO I
CERTAINLY DIDN'T GET INTO IT TO
MAKE. SIX FIGURES BY IT IS AN
ISSUE THAT WE ARE CONSTANTLY UP
AGAINST AND I HAVE SEEN STAFF
COME IN AN HOUR AND ROTATE
REALLY REALLY GOOD SOCIAL
WORKERS WHO LOVE WHAT THEY'RE
DOING AND THEY'RE NOT ABLE.
TO SO I AM HERE IN SUPPORT OF
EVERYTHING EVERYONE SAID BEFORE
ME AND I THANK YOU FOR THE
CONSIDERATION AND THIS IS
DEFINITELY BEEN A LEARNING
EXPERIENCE TO BE A PART OF THE
S..
THANK YOU I WILL TELL YOU MY
SISTER WILL BE HAPPY SHE IS A
SOCIAL WORKER.
HI MY NAME IS CLAUDIA MENDES
FROM HEALTH PROJECTS CENTER FROM
MONTEREY COUNTY OFFICE AND JUST
TO ECHO EXACTLY WHICH SHE SAID
I'M A SUPERVISOR THERE.
JUST LAST YEAR ITSELF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I HAD FOURTEEN PEOPLE
LEAVE IT IS VERY HARD TO CARRY A
CASE ON IN BE ABLE TO TRAIN AT
THE SAME TIME.
AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT THAT
THERE'S NO GAPS IN BETWEEN.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S A TOUGH JOB HI
I AM LIVES THAT COULD DO SOCIAL
WORKER CASE MANAGER FROM SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY.
AND I JUST WANT TO STATE THAT --
THE CLIENTS THAT WE SERVE THEY
APPRECIATE THE MONTHLY CONTACT
THAT WE GIVE THEM BECAUSE SOME
OF THESE CLIENTS.
THAT'S THE ONLY CONTACT THAT
THEY HAVE SO I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THESE -- BUDGET THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND THE CONTRACT
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
INVESTMENT IN A MESS AS PETE
THERE A VITAL COMMUNITY PARTNERS
THANK YOU.
CLAY CAM CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF AREA AGENCIES ON AGING
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT I WANT SMALL
ANECDOTE SANTA CRUZ COUNTY GAVE
UP THERE AND I SAYS.
P. PROGRAM EIGHT YEARS AGO AND
THE REASON THEY GAVE IT UP AS
THE REIMBURSEMENT RATES WERE TOO
LOW. SEVEN YEARS AGO MONTEREY
COUNTY GAVE UP THERE.
AND THOSE ARE THE REASONS WHY
THIS IS SO CRITICAL THE PROGRAM
WORKS LUCKILY A LOCAL NONPROFIT
STEPPED IN IN BOTH THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND THEY CURRENTLY
PROVIDE THE SERVICE.
BUT NOW THEY'RE FACING THE
QUESTION CANDY CONTINUE TO
OPERATE SO IT'S AN ONGOING LONG
TERM PROBLEM.
WERE ON THE PROGRAMS WORK VERY
WELL THEY'RE ALL AGAINST THE
WALL THE FUNDING FOR THIS --
AUGMENTATION IS CRITICAL HOPE
YOU CONSIDER IT THANK YOU.
PLEASE A COMMON KHALKHAL Là AB
WE'D LIKE TO REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT THIS IS A WORK
DETERRENT FOR THE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM.
SO YOU YOU CAN SPEND LESS MONEY
ON US IF YOU SPEND MORE MONEY ON
THEM.
AND PERHAPS YOU WOULD CONSIDER
AMENDING THIS BUDGET REQUEST AND
MAKING IT AN ON GOING ALLEGATION
OUT ALLOCATION AS OPPOSED.
TO JUST THREE YEARS AND HAVING
THEM COME BACK THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JESSE WILLIAMS AND
I AM ASSISTANCE I DIRECTOR --
FOR TWO SITES HERE.
SACRAMENTO PLASTER YELLOW AND
YUBA.
OVER THE LAST TWO MONTHS I'VE
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF ACTION
GOING TO TO THE PARTICIPANTS
HOME.
AND INTERVIEWING THEM AND CATCH
IN THAT INTERVIEW ON CAMERA.
AND SO WHAT HAPPENED TO ME
DURING THAT PROCESS -- I BECAME
VERY EMOTIONAL -- AND IT WAS
VERY TOUGH FOR ME BECAUSE I TOOK
THE FEEDBACK THAT THE
PARTICIPANTS GAVE ME HOME WITH
ME -- WHEN YOU GUYS IF YOU GUYS
GET OPPORTUNITY TO WATCH THAT --
FILM YOU'LL SEE THAT SOME
OPERATIVES WITH OUR BAD BOUND.
WHEELCHAIR BOUND BUT LINE IN
HALF HEARING IMPAIRMENT.
THE FEEDBACK THAT THESE BUT IT'S
BEEN GAVE ME ABOUT M. S. S. P.
AND THEIR OWN WORDS WAS M. S. S.
P. IS NOTHING SHORT.
THAN A MIRACLE.
SO I WANT YOU GUYS TO REALLY PAY
ATTENTION TO WHAT THESE BUTTONS
BUT SAY ON THAT FILM IF YOU GET
A CHANCE TO SEE A AND REALLY BE
IN SUPPORT OF OUR ASKING.
THANK YOU.
WONDERFUL TO SEND THAT TO
NICOLE'S WELL OKAY.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN I'D LIKE TO
TO THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING THIS.
I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL OF THE
PANELISTS -- IT'S CLEAR THAT
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT WORKS.
AND HOW IT WORKS ON A SHOE
STRING NONE OF US WILL EVER KNOW.
AND IT REALLY HAS TO DO WITH A
BIG HEART OF THOSE WHO ARE
WILLING TO INVEST.
ALL OF THEIR TIME AND THEIR
EFFORT.
INTO SUCH A PROGRAM.
SO THANK YOU ALL I'D LIKE TO NOW
CALL UP THE PANELISTS FOR ISSUE
NUMBER SIX OUR LAST ISSUE
[inaudible]
REPORTER.
AND I REMIND YOU THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO HAS ALREADY
TESTIFIED IN THIS REGARD.
AND SHE INTRODUCED JOHN POINTER.
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE.
IS JOHN STILL HERE.
HEY JOHN COME ON UP.
IT'S LIKE A CONCERT YOU'VE GOT
THE THE LIKE GOING NINE HUH I'M
HERE I'M HERE.
ALL RIGHT JOHN TELL US A MISTER
POINTER PLEASE TELL US ALL ABOUT
THIS PROGRAM.
MS RUBIO SHARED SOME OF THE
BASICS ABOUT IT -- WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR FROM YOU NOW.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK. TO YOUR
COMMITTEE TODAY IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME.
I HAVE CONDENSED MY PRESENTATION
FROM SEVERAL PAGES. TWO ONE BUT
I BELIEVE I WILL STILL GET THE
MESSAGE.
ACROSS.
I'M HERE TODAY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE A
STATE AGENCY THAT IS CELEBRATING
ITS THIRTY EIGHTH YEAR.
ADVOCATING ON BEHALF OF OLDER
CALIFORNIANS.
AN AGENCY THAT HAS OVER TWO
HUNDRED LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL
SIGNED INTO LAW.
OVER ITS TIME PERIOD.
THAT TRANSLATES TO OVER FIVE
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL SIGNED INTO
LAW EACH YEAR.
THAT'S PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
THANK YOU I THINK SO.
TOO I'M BEFORE YOU TODAY
REQUESTING YOUR SUPPORT FOR OUR
ONGOING APPROPRIATION OF FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
THIS APPROACH PROVIDES A MUCH
NEEDED SOLUTION TO THE CURRENT.
FINANCIAL CRISIS FACING CSL AND
PROVIDES A PATHWAY FOR THE
AGENCY TO CONTINUE ITS ROLE AS
AN ADVOCATE FOR SENIORS.
WHEN SENIOR ISSUES ARE GROWING
EXPONENTIALLY IN THE STATE?
AND WE ARE ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS
THAT WITH A MASTER PLAN ON AGING.
WE WANT TO BE THERE WE WANT TO
BE PART OF THAT.
WE BELIEVE WE HAVE SOMETHING TO
OFFER IN REGARDS TO THAT.
AS A REMINDER.
THIS IS THE AGENCY.
THAT HAS AUTHORED SUCH IMPACTFUL
LEGISLATION AS SILVER ALERT.
SILVER ALERT AS THE COMPLEMENT
THE AMBER ALERT.
SOUL.
WHEN OUR?
MOTHER OR FATHER.
A RELATIVE.
DISAPPEARS THE FREEWAY SIGNS
LIGHT UP.
AND ENABLE US TO FIND BOMBER
DEATH.
I WILL GO INTO THE DETAILS OF
HOW WE GOT HERE INTO THIS
FINANCIAL SITUATION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO OUTLINED THAT.
ARE VERY EFFECTIVELY IN MY
OPINION.
I WANT TO REMIND YOU HOWEVER
THAT ARE PER PREACH BEGAN IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHEN WE
PRESENTED THIS COMMITTEE.
THIS IS MY FOURTH YEAR I'VE COME
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE.
PRESENTING THIS COMMITTEE WITH A
THREE YEAR FINANCING PLAN AS
PART OUR EFFORT TO HAVE AN
ONGOING APPROPRIATIONS.
INCLUDED THE GOVERNOR'S TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET.
SINCE THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
LEGISLATIVE SESSION CSL
SUBMITTED A PCP. FOR AN ONGOING
APPROPRIATION FOR INCLUSION OF
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET.
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
WE ARE BEFORE YOU TODAY.
WITH OUR REQUEST FOR AN ONGOING
APPROPRIATIONS.
IN CLOSING I AM REQUESTING YOUR
SUPPORT.
OF OUR REQUEST FOR AN ONGOING
APPROPRIATION IN THE AMOUNT OF
FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
LET ME REPEAT THAT IN AN
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH WE HAVE
TWENTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS.
AS A SURPLUS I'M NOT EVEN SURE I
CAN CALCULATE THIS AS A
PERCENTAGE ON MIKE IN FACT I
KNOW I COULDN'T ON MY PHONE.
I HAD TO CALL JANICE AND ASK HER
TO DO THE MATH.
OKAY FOUR HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARSIN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE WE HAVE TWENTY
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN A SURPLUS.
WITH THAT MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- I SAW
SAY THAT THE SENATE DOES HAVE A
GOOD OVERVIEW OF THE FUNDING --
THIS SENIOR LEGISLATURE'S
FUNDING HISTORY I ALSO WANT TO
MENTION THAT THE LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATED FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND IN SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND
ANOTHER THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TO
SUPPORT SENIOR LEGISLATURE'S
OPERATIONS.
THOSE APPROPRIATION FOR BOTH RE
APPROPRIATED AND WITH THAT CARRY
OVER FUNDING THAT SHOULD BE ABLE
TO FUND THE SCENE LEGISLATURE'S
OPERATIONS AND CAREER.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HELLO.
I'M PERSONALLY MEMBER REVIEWS
REQUEST HAPPY TO WORK WITH
FINANCE -- TO LOOK AT THE
PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY AROUND ON
THE BUDGET ESTIMATES AND
POTENTIAL LANGUAGE COPY TO
PROVIDE THAT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BEFORE YES MA'AM WE
MISS HER YES.
YES WE MUCH LESSER HARD
INITIALLY REST IN PEACE MAY SHE
REST IN PEACE SHE WAS A GREAT
ADVOCATE -- AND EVERY TIME SHE
SAW ANY OF US SHE'D MAKE SURE
SHE TOLD AS WITH THE NEEDS OF
OUR SENIORS WERE -- BUT I WANT
TO THANK YOU. FOR FOR STAYING
TILL THE END -- FOR WELL WORTH
ABOUT HIM CHAIR.
IT IS BECAUSE YOU YOU YOU GET TO
KNOW IT EVEN IN SPANISH THEY SAY
SET I'VE GONE BUT CHAIR THE ORAL.
SO YOU ARE THE GOAL IT TIED THAT
ENDS THIS THIS HEARING I DO WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND
FOR PROVIDING THIS.
TESTIMONY AND I THINK THAT THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME WE HAD THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
SOMETHING SO POSITIVE.
LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE COVERED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
SUBJECT.
DOOR DEAFENED BY VOLUNTEER FOR A
A RP WE STRONGLY SUPPORT BEING A
BUDGET REQUEST FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
THERE'S SO MUCH WORK TO BE DONE
WE NEED ALL HANDS ON DECK THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELL.
WE ARE DONE.
OF I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL OF YOU
THOSE OF YOU WHO REMAINED --
DIRECTOR MILLER THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE MISTER LONG --
AND THE REST OF YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE THIS
CONCLUDES OUR HEARING